foreign
happy Monday everybody it is Monday
Robert right at least I got the day of
the week right I think I'm gonna get the
tournament right as well welcome to the
chessable Masters this is an incredibly
exciting event the second of its kind
it's gonna be epic I'm your host
Grandmaster Daniel narditsky and
alongside me today my good friend
Grandmaster Robert Hess Robert good
morning to you
happy Monday thank you my friend happy
Monday it is a fun day because we have
the chessable Masters playing Dania
could not be any more exciting we have
such an electric field and a fun day
ahead of us an electric field an
electric format and first of all an
electric schedule because the chessable
Masters the finals will be happening
from April 3rd to April 7th there will
be six events in total the air things
Masters has already been held and
concluded chessable Masters coming up in
early April and the events will be
scattered from May to September the CCC
playoffs coming your way at the start of
December 2023 and the CCC finals from
16th to 23rd of December also 2023 so
this entire year is going to be
action-packed Robert it's time to take
your Google Calendars out make sure
you're not scheduling any meetings on
the dates of these finals
I'll schedule a meeting and that meeting
will be with the likes of you and David
Howell Tanya suchdev you know we're
going to have some fun commentating
these events there are so many across
the year and that's great because that
means we get to see all the top players
go at it month after month
we absolutely do and we will and we will
see them go after it today and they've
already gone after it before so let's
take a look at the standings at the
leaderboard as we currently see it you
can see the earnings on the right side
some dude named Magnus Carlson is a
topless with 150 points obviously the
points accumulated depends on which
division uh that you made it into and
how you did in that division we'll talk
more uh about the overall format and
remind you uh in just a moment but let's
take a second to admire all of the
players that we see Atop The List from
Carlson and Nakamura who duped it out in
the finals of the air things Masters to
Wesley so and Vladimir kramnik in 15th
Place Robert wherever you look you've
got former world champions and curl the
world and soon to be former world
champions let's not talk about that
uh well that's going to be a topic of
conversation for sure but you're right
there's kind of the who's who of Chess
some the young upstarts the teenagers
like our Genera geisi and gukesh and
then former world champions like
Vladimir chromic so no matter which
division you turn to whether it be
division one where we saw Magnus Carlsen
take down a car Nakamura all the way
down to division three where we saw Sam
sevion Who currently sits in the tie for
Ninth Place and prognanda who's there in
13th so many of the world's best players
indeed everybody wants a little bit of
that incredible prize fund speaking of
the prize fund will actually tell you
what it is and if you're just joining us
the adjustable Masters is unmissable for
many reasons one of which are these top
prizes thirty thousand uh for the winner
of the division one knockout but even if
you come in seventh 7 500 that is the
price of a pretty nice car so the prizes
are incredibly generous there we see the
entire overlay and the most important
thing whatever appeals to so many
Grandmasters is that everybody gets a
prize no matter what division you
actually make it in division two
division three you get a prize and there
we see the prizes for the final division
even if you get knocked out of division
three that's still a cool one thousand
dollars so if you don't have much of a
chance to make it past Magnus Carlson
Hikaru Nakamura you still have a chance
to make enough money to buy a car or a
very nice steak dinner Robert
so you're saying there's a chance and
that's important because the chest needs
this kind of ecosystem right because
we're used to seeing all the top players
in the world get their shot at huge
price ones that's great it's necessary
but it's also necessary to have you know
real income to players who may not start
with a 2-7 in their rating so it's great
to see this we also see players who
don't get to play much classical chess
but are superb at the quicker time
controls like the Olex under bortnicks
and the Jose Martinez's of the world so
it's really a tremendous event and we're
just getting started
I say this in the context of the PCL but
it applies to these events as well you
can discover new interesting players and
you watch these tournaments yes all of
the top guys are playing but if you're
looking for new 2600s to root for
players who might have slipped under the
crack and don't always win every
tournament you know we're also know
where to look if you want an overview of
the format uh thank you everybody for
giving the format a chance I think it's
a format that allows everybody to play
and everybody to get funneled in first
there is a Swiss stage it consists of
nine rounds of time control is the same
as in the PCL 10 minutes with a 2 second
increment the top 72 players the top 72
players Advanced to match play match
play consists of two games of ten plus
two the time control does not change uh
and the top 52 players advance to The
Knockout which will be held April 3rd
through 7th they will be slotted into
three divisions so that's the most
important thing so remember a lot of
players qualify Robert but not a lot
qualify into the very top division
no and very few do in fact only four
because we know four names already in
the top division and you know liftoff is
about to happen Donya I'm stoked it's at
the top of the hour and we have some
huge names from the world of Chess
participating and I'm seeing 145 plus
players it's going to be a slugfest
it is indeed yeah I'm looking at the
pre-registered Players we'll tell you
all about them in a moment but first uh
let's consider the overall format I keep
mentioning uh various divisions there
are three divisions in totals so first
of all the Swiss stage is open to any
Grand Master if you're a GM you
automatically qualify as well as the top
three players from the Monday qualifiers
which actually include some
non-grandmasters so we do have some IMS
and even some feed a masters playing as
already mentioned the time control is 10
minutes with a 2 second increment it's a
Swiss system players earn points across
nine rounds and the players with the
most points cumulatively are Atop The
Standing 72 players qualified to match
play it's a pretty easy format to follow
and we will be reminding you of it as
things go along but things are already
going along in the tournament so here we
go Robert seat belts fastened let's get
this underway
and normally you would say speed belts
fasten but this is a rapid time control
they start with 10 minutes they get a
little bit of increment as well but we
still see systems like the London and we
have the bishop F4 in this game I don't
know who invited this opening to the
party but for Laurent fresenay with the
black pieces he's taken a bit of a pause
here down in plays the calm quiet E6 I
mean they're just so many different
variations that you can play against the
London you have to sort through all of
them decide what you're really trying to
do here in the first round no need to
take any major risks by the way for us
and his opponent in this game I believe
is Andrew Hong a very exciting
Grandmaster from the Bay Area I know him
very well he's a one E4 player so I
don't know who's playing for him I've
never seen Andrew even touch the d-pawn
before five moves have been played
well sometimes you bring your special
preparation to the biggest stages and
having an opportunity to qualify for one
of the three divisions that's a pretty
big stage indeed and so far we see a
very quiet opening no pieces have been
traded there is a stare down of bishops
from D6 to F4 over here so uh you know
they're both biding their time and now
we see esterdam of the other Bishops
this seems like less of a choice more
likely that white will capture and we
see that the Knight on the rim isn't
looking so great but no pawns have been
traded Donia no pawns have been traded
this looks pretty
looks for white Andrew can rule
continuing to play quickly as he
establishes a night in the center he's
probably going to complete the pawn
triangle with C3 and the queen from D1
can actually go out in two different
directions it can move to A4 and harass
the Knight instead he pushes the pawn to
A4 Robert so he issues C3 and instead
expands immediately on the queen side I
like Andrew's position here in the early
going
yeah you have a little bit more control
of important squares you can throw and
move A5 at some point trying to open up
your Rook on A1 but for scene is he's
not going to be bothered by this kind of
stuff white is very solid but what are
you threatening the answer is nothing at
the moment and I love moves like this
Dania Knight back to B8 that was a Mis
Place night on the rim here it comes
back towards the center whether it's C6
or D7 you're gonna challenge this very
strong 995. and that's one of the
drawbacks of London it's hard to punish
someone for making multiple moves with
the same piece it's not an E4 opening
The Black Gang is perfectly safe and I
agree I think Laurent has solved all of
his opening problems as he gets his
Knight to C6 and initiates a further
minor piece trades and I think that
probably gives us a good opportunity I
see you're already surfing all of the
games I had a major decision anxiety
rubber when I was operating the board I
think you're you're experiencing that
now
you mean when there's vladisav artemiev
or Anish giri or Vladimir kramnik or
yancha stuff dude you're saying it's
hard to choose between their games like
you've been serious
I am I'm not jesting it's too early in
the day for my horrendous puns which
will eventually make an appearance Anish
giri I see you're hovering over this guy
named Anish Gary and a good choice
indeed because we've got a completely
different landscape from the previous
game
uh this seems like an issue for black
and it's not even so much on the board I
do like White's position look at the
clocks Tanya Anish has more time than he
started with 10 minutes five seconds
black on the other hand down to six and
a half minutes you're playing a stronger
player you're playing a well-prepared
player and you're playing a determined
inish giri who I know is taking this
very seriously he's been working he
wants to qualify for the main event he
couldn't participate in the first one
Donya because he had an over the board
conflict but he is ready to try to
qualify for the chessable Masters
division one and this Knight is ready to
jump into C4
and I'll just add that much like Fabiano
caruana I think Anish Gary this isn't
talked about as often but his rapid
performance and Blitz performance has
improved he's a very fast player I've
played a couple bullet matches with
Anish don't count him out in this
tournament just because you might not
associate his name necessarily with a
lot of Blitz victories and each giri is
here to play he is here to make it into
the top division that Knight on D2 is
here to make it to D5 as you're pointing
out Knight C4 Knight E3 Knight D5 is a
very straightforward maneuver black
needs to figure something out and Anish
Gary continues to play instantly
blistering speed by Geary in this nidorf
and Sergey trigalov with the black
pieces brings his Knight to C5 but the
big issue is while you're attacking this
Pawn E4 that's the great news you don't
have a similar Outpost white has D5
white is F5 as well when this Knight
hops back to E3 it is going to Leap
Forward into these vulnerable light
squares and queen F3 Anish finally set
and thought for a little bit Dania but
not thinking too much and playing very
natural strong moves developing this
bishop can also come to E3 and then win
White Castles Queen side D6 is
immediately a Target I think 96 should
be considered by dragolov trying to get
the Knight over to D4 and forcing white
to occupy the E3 square with the bishop
perhaps then black could follow up with
B7 B5 but it just occurred to me that
the Knight has a different Pathway to D5
it can go there through B6 with the
bishop on E3 the B6 square is covered
Knight B6 Knight D5 but still be a huge
problem
I don't see how Sergey pulls this up
he's already got five minutes he's
experiencing tremendous practical
problems he needs to change the course
of the game maybe stick a knight on D4
even if white plays Bishop E3 maybe try
to get the bishop air and something
going on the queen side
yeah but that feels like desperation
more than desire at this point because
your Pawn structure will be quite ugly
white is well developed but now that
Anish is thinking I feel like for the
first time all game you can say all
right I have a chance here when you're
playing a super Grand Master rated above
2750 and you're playing Super
preparation from the best engines in the
world you're kind of like I'm I might
get blown off the board but now that
Anish is finally using some time Dania I
feel like with the black pieces Sergey
trigalov he's like all right I'm playing
a normal game now we're both
Grandmasters I have a shot at least he's
gonna make his opponent use his own
brain rather than the spacebar and the
computer as I like to say uh when I'm
facing somebody who's playing instantly
and each Gary does indeed wow up on his
idea Knight E3 says go Knight D4 I don't
care I'm gonna move my queen back to D1
and eventually that c Pawn is going to
be liberated once the C3 Knight moves
out of the way if there's a trade on D5
for example if Last Knight is chased out
of D4 more problems or torture or Sergey
drigalov as he brings his Bishop out to
E6 the eval bar jumps up I still like
this for Anish giri yeah it just looks
way too easy with such good control of
the important squares you could start
with Bishop to G2 if you want to take
further control of D5 and protect this
Pawn on e4 I'm not sure it actually
needs defense because there are often
positions where when black takes this
Pawn E4 you still develop with Tempo
that's the key to a position like this
but I would not be giving away this Pawn
there's Queen A5 check ideas so you know
now that I've said it I think that and
he should take the necessary care to
make sure he doesn't drop a pawn in the
center so down there while Anish is
sitting and thinking should we try to
hop around and find some more fun
players it would be a crime not to it's
pretty hard to find fun players as we've
already determined you're looking at San
on Segura against vladislav or Tami of
who by the way I think has a great
chance to qualify into division one I
was discussing vladislava with oh yeah
you say our because you said who has a
great chance to qualify it I didn't know
who you were talking about because
shigerov is 2700 and our 10 is also
2700. I think both have a chance sigurov
is the more experienced Blitz player he
plays every title Tuesday but vladislava
Tammy of someone who hasn't been as
active Robert in over-the-board
tournament play even the last couple of
years the guy was 27.60 feet a for
goodness sake he dropped a little bit
but I still think that he has the
stylistic ingredients to make it very
very far in these knockout events
yeah I know he is really dangerous
because he's great at bullet chess in
addition to just being a strong player
and that's key because when you get into
those time scrambles you need to be
confident you need to be sure that you
can play the good moves and you don't
want to be fretting about your clock
like some of the other top players are
but in this position Dunya we see a Pawn
on A5 potentially overextended the pawn
on D4 doesn't a B4 excuse me doesn't
feel quite as vulnerable with the bishop
protecting it and it's Bishop on C5 very
powerful on this diagonal where yes
white is likely to put a bishop on E3
but that doesn't solve all of the
tension in the center of the board I
tend to like the chances for black we
often see Rook B8 Rook B5 at some moment
after that pawn yeah I'm liking this for
artemiev we also see in many cases the
positional sacrifice B3 black and push
the pawn and sacrifice it but in turn
shatter White's entire Queen side and
put the light squared Bishop out of
commission so B3 even now is perhaps a
little bit really our Tammy of style and
instead he takes the direct route he
trades on F3 will he subsequently trade
on E3 well he's got to do something
because white is now threatening to take
on C5 and then win the pawn on E5 so
decision time or a lot of slav who can
also play Knight F6 to D7 Robert if he
wants to keep the tension and try to
trade on his own terms
hey it looks like between the two of us
we can maybe play Oh almost as well as
the Superstar vladis of artemiev and F5
becomes an idea with a rook and the
Queen the same line they have to be very
very careful with this bishop staring
down the diagonal towards the black king
so I love this move Knight to D7 you're
just trying to hop this Knight forward
and you mentioned this idea of B3 before
done it with the Knight hopping the C5
potentially B3 becomes even more
promising I like how artemiev is dealing
with this game both on the board and on
the clock I was discussing vladislav
with Alexander Bortnick and the player
that we both compared him to is actually
Magnus Carlson I think he's got the same
exact style he loves to grind out equal
positions he's very very good in rui
Lopez and Italian structures with black
which is incredibly good right now
because everybody seems to play one of
these two openings and there he is the
man himself in deep concentration up on
time a lot of slav is off to a good
start in this game and in this
tournament
it kind of looks like he's in a dentist
office you know I feel like that's the
chair that we see there from him uh but
he's a Smooth Operator this guy like you
said he reminds many people his style of
Magnus Carlson he beat Magnus Carlson in
the world rapid Championship Magnus may
have won Gold but he lost one game and
one game only and it was to this man you
see on the screen in front of you so
Queen G3 Dania what does this do are you
really trying some cheeky Bishop H6 and
checkmating attack that's not gonna work
out and the eval bar is swinging
slightly in Black's favor but more
important than even the evaluation to me
is the clock he's keeping a two minute
lead it's a very healthy time Advantage
when vladislava artemiev is on form he
is really one of the hardest to beat
because his style is sewing Universal he
knows his openings anything positional
you're not going to crack lotuslav or
Tammy I think the only chance is to get
a very very tactical struggle but even
then lotuslav is a great calculator his
time management is good he just has no
holes in his game and indeed he might be
in a dentist office I think White's play
here is rather toothless if you will uh
that the wind up on that was way too
long but hey no I appreciate it give me
some slack it's it's before noon so I
don't want to talk about slack you know
we don't want to go into slack territory
right now too many people sending us
messages right now but I think the
artemia would like to send a message to
the rest of the field that he's here to
qualify for division one that's a name
that people do not want to see his fide
rating in classical chess may have
dipped to just about 2700 I say just as
if that's not a tremendous rating but I
think that people have lost sight of how
strong he is and this Rook on B5 is now
in line with his Pawn on A5 so don't I
feel like eventually C5 maybe bishop
takes Knight at some point but A5 is
just a Target
and it's even more of a Target after
White's last move Rook takes A5 already
has to be calculated Bishop takes Bishop
Rook takes rook and black is going to
drop A6 at the end of the line or you
have Bishop takes F7 check Desperado so
artemia snaps the bishop up gets his
Knight to C5 and he's just continuing to
wind his tentacles around White's pieces
F5 by the way is still very much in play
so he can play on the king side right
now he's focusing on the queen side and
if he can get sanan to push his own Pawn
to B3 that creates even more dark square
holes on the queen side uh that our
Tammy have occupy with his Knight and
potentially with his Rook great position
here for black
I could see this Knight going back to E6
The Rook taking the knights place on C5
and just going after those potentially
weak dark squares as you mentioned
because D4 and if B3 then C3 as well so
this position is fantastic for artemium
he is in the driver's seat here uh he is
up on the clock this Rook on A2 done yet
it is just a sad defensive piece and
also about to be vulnerable this B3 idea
that we've been talking about for a long
time just trying to hurt White's Pawn
structure and stopping B3 with the B3
move your own doesn't solve all the
problems and artemia playing quickly
this is bad news for shiger of a super
gym in his own right
absolutely our time we have is in
control playing quickly and a first
round win with a black pieces really
goes a long way it's a nine round event
you have some slack you can lose a game
here and there but I think seven out of
nine seven and a half and half nine
those are the scores that the top guys
are striving for to guarantee a
qualification into division one lots of
games still going I see a couple of
games have concluded Robert so I'll pass
the ball to you we've got
and we've got Lauren for sna we've got
Arthur's nexons against you Yang Yi so
it's not like you get a couple easy
pairings to start the tournament you're
facing 2600s right out of round one
there he pulled up Nate Sons who's got a
pretty good end game here against you
Yankee look at this
wow pretty good seems like an
understatement there's an E6 Pawn that
is isolated and already targeted by both
the Rooks this Knight on F3 can start
hopping around chasing Black's pawns I
really like this for Archers now that's
the thing about this Champion's chest
tour is you know archers is a streamer
as a commentator I think many don't know
him as a super strong chess player 2600
level player who could beat 2700s in any
given game so Dania at this point in
time I feel like white has so many
options A4 is probably a good move just
to try to soften the B5 Pawn once you
take we've shortened the pawn chain so
Knight D4 now actually threatens to win
a pawn so that's key it's a key thing to
remember for everybody a pawn chain is
only as strong as his base Pawn A6 is
hard to get to B5 is a lot closer to the
white pieces that's a great point I
would only add at the principle of two
weaknesses as we see you and get on the
screen there a concerned yuyenge on the
left side of your your screen Aaron
nimsovich in my system talked about the
principle of two weaknesses where one
big weakness can be defended
blackstrokes are doing a decent job of
keeping E6 protected the moment a second
weakness is created the the landscape
shifts immediately look at a knight that
could appear on D4 if it just attacks
the E6 Pawn well black can play King F7
if the B5 Pawn is also hanging that's
called a fork great call you are on a
roll A4 is on the board I think Nixon's
has tremendous winning chances here in
fact Robert I don't see a way for black
to defend the B5 Pawn because you cannot
afford to move a rook off of the e-file
then you lose E6 and A6 can also fall
after that
is hanging
this is a great display of technique
from a very strong grandmas in Arthur's
Nixons and I'm loving the way he's
playing this game black at some point
may decide to give up a pawn don't know
you and I talk about this often instead
of Defending passively you may give up
material so you're down maybe a pawn
maybe even two parts disappoint but you
have the activity you have a clear plan
so the Knight came into D5 Knight D4 it
is a double shot but B4 that's a great
call by you and played very quickly by
you Yang Yi and now I feel like after
the swap of Pawns if this Knight gets
into D3 you're targeting this loose B2
Pawn Robert I think Archer should have
considered putting the Rook on e4 in
order to prevent before one prophylactic
move would have gone a long long way
before Rook takes C4 and you keep the
tension but how hard is it to avoid the
temptation to play in it4 what Arthurs
might have underestimated is that after
the trade on before or you swap
everything on E6 at the end black puts a
knight on D3 and even if white can find
a way to liquidate the queen side pawns
the three on two with knights on the
board should be a draw so I actually
think you Yankee has found an excellent
defensive resource he should be able to
hold the game now
and it's hard to hold yourself back when
you see a move that looks like it just
wins a pawn how are you not going to
play it but you're right down your Rook
E4 showing a little bit more restraint
that would have held black position in
place and the status quo favored white
so after Knight E4 B4 it looks like Yugi
has very good chances to survive this
game so uh Tanya I mean so many fun
players in this field You Yankee artist
Nixon's just two of the many uh Knight
C6 played with a fork but this Rook
likely can just slide away and it does
you could have E6 this is what we're
talking about you can give away a pawn
but unfortunately C3 is loose and if you
take on B4 B2 will be loose this just
looks like a straightforward draw from
here on out yeah and I think makes sense
should make sure not to over press he's
low on time just take on B4 accept the
inevitable but this was great defensive
skill by you Yang Yu is going to secure
half a point I also see Sam sevian
facing shimanov and Alexi Serrano Alexi
serrana is playing in this tournament
that's a big deal I guess anything
Alexis serrana touches Robert in the
last year or so ever since the RCC he
seems to win except this game perhaps
yeah he um just won the European
Championship so congratulations to Alexi
Serrano he has finished in first place
along with Karel shevchenko they drew
very quickly in the final round so this
is your European Champion Alexi Serrano
but in this game oh that apparently was
a big mistake
both players
yeah the queen of the C6 trying to offer
the queen trade I think the reason why
Dania quick count black is up a pawn
here I wasn't even looking at that so
black is okay on the head yeah it's hard
to see that but black has an extra Pawn
five on four Black's time is not great
that is the big problem here and this is
Trang Sun from uh Vietnam very talented
player in fact he was one of the highest
rated players of my generation in the
world youth tournaments he was the
number one seed and well that apparently
was a big blunder down here why is that
is it because of that five and rookie
four Robert or is there some tactic here
that H4 Pawn oh and he misses it he
finds a similar move he wants Rook F4
but does white have some tactical
defense maybe rookie one Rook F4 rookie
seven check that shouldn't work because
Black's King has an envelope there on H6
that it can move to in case of a seventh
range check 30 cents though and Robert
Alexi serrana is second to none at
creating complications in his opponent's
time pressure I remember his game
against Dwayne Jones from the PCL he was
made at Seven Ways to Sunday or shall I
say seven ways to Monday he always finds
a way to weasel out of it will he be
able to repeat that in this game though
he's gonna need to because he does have
a lead on the clock he needs to find
some idea that just doesn't lose on the
spot Rook F4 is a deadly threat you're
hitting the queen also the pawn A4
behind it and this H4 Pawn which is the
most important one because your king is
vulnerable it might be a Checkmate so
what to do here you mentioned rookie one
doesn't seem to pan out
um maybe just not finding anything
Quincy earlier I think you were right
though bringing the queen to C6 or
somewhere where you trade it would give
white the best chances so actually
moving the queen to E6 may be an idea
but Rook F4 still hits you where it
hurts and if you play a move like Queen
to E3 black could consider take five but
maybe that's what Alexi wants a queen
end game increases the possibility of a
Perpetual there's a check on E7 that
could come at in timely fashion and I
think white actually might have
Perpetual King H6 you don't take on F6
you give a check on f8 you force Black's
King to the eighth rank then you take on
F6 and you Fork the B6 and G6 Pawn so
Queen E3 might be the only way to Stave
off defeat look at Alexi's clock though
90 seconds and he finds it he finds it
that was the only move to stay in the
game
and you see how quickly I plus king G7
I'm not taking this Pawn not yet but now
it is hanging because the queen is F7
squared that it's going to block it on
so I feel like for white the good news
is B6 is hanging if the pawn on D5 is
captured so that that may give you a
chance to stay in the game but Alexi now
down to almost a minute himself and the
moves are just easier for black to play
Queen E6 would be desirable but after
the trade black could still stick The
Rook on F4 and white could simply end up
two or even three pawns down in that
Rook end game the King on G7 will also
keep the E6 Pawn at Bay in the events of
a queen trade this was an incredible
move found instantly by Truong San Alexi
keeps the Queens on the board tries to
get the queen to C7 Rook F4 you're
pointing out Robert should basically end
the game just don't take on D5 and give
white a shot on the queen end game
and Rook at 4 play 27 seconds is enough
time for black with the two second
increment and G3 just take that pawn
over here the problem for white is now
any sort of Queen trade will just
liquidate into a lost Rook end game so
King G2 played I think that's good look
at the time by the way but Rook A3
another smart move by black Exquisite
time management but now he's down below
20 seconds he starts pushing his Queen
side pawns Alexi doesn't have a single
entry point the queen on D6 Robert is a
hero now you can take the pawn with
check Alexi trying one last counter play
attempt he's trying to get his Rook to
C7 but maybe just put the queen back on
D6 and control both E7 and C7 at the
same time
and what white wants to avoid is a check
right you don't want this queen to come
to E3 with check and trade Queen so
Queen E5 is such an excellent
centralization covering C7 trading
Queens the G3 Pawn is hanging down here
I think this they're more or less what's
stalemate ideas Yes actually flax Rook
moves away from G3 there could be
stalemate ideas but now not anymore
Queen G3 ends
yeah now there's Checkmate ideas or you
win the queen you win the game that's it
a win for trong sun with the black
pieces this is the Champions chest we're
playing this is how strong it is let's
try to find anishikiri's game they are
in time trouble over here but Anish now
up oh oh I think he forgot he forgot
that C3 was hanging at the end of that
line and suddenly it's probably a two
result game but Anish has to be careful
there goes that deep on Robert there's a
ton of Knight Forks Knight F6 to E4
could come at An Inconvenient time I
think black should be able to hold this
if he's careful although if this Rook
gets sidelined and you can't catch the
bee Pawn that would be bad news Knights
are slower moving pieces Bishop could
just sit on before it's a moment so this
is I agree with you chances for both and
if this King grabs that five uh very
smart that was really smart by Nisha it
was 96 to C4 was scary and now black has
to decide is he keeping the Deep on he
tries with Rook C4 King B3 The Rook can
move back to C3 the Knight slides into
D2 maybe King A4 try to escape the
checks King A5 and run that beep on up
the board
and the thing about these matchups done
is you know Anish feels like he's got to
win because you're playing someone who's
a bit lower rated a grand master still
oh don't fall for any checks but here
comes the d-pod how do you stop that
thing you're right Robert Anish might be
overpressing he's getting the bishop to
H6 without that Rook D4 would have
decided the game now four seconds for
Sergo as he pushes the pawn forward and
this is gonna be a drop
yeah I would just Swap and take on D2
and that forces the draw here whoa Anish
you're playing with fight you can only
lose this position I well maybe he's
King C7 I think black is gonna give up
the night for the pawn I don't think
sergoy is going to try really hard here
he's got to be careful in his own right
now it's a blunder the Knight to some D7
oh thankfully he can go over here but
Anish is a very skilled bullet player
and I think he's trying to show that off
are they a grief for a draw no at least
trade off the knife for the pawn but it
does make sense this is a clear draw so
uh can't really complain a couple games
are still remaining let's go to our
generic icy he is playing how do they
have so much time what move number is
this 101
a minute remaining on their clocks
they're just playing casually rustamov
though is going to hold to draw Sasha
Sasha is a nightmare opponent Robert I
played so many Blitz matches with him he
is from the old school he is not backing
down against the top juniors
he's afraid of nobody he also loves to
play in Arena Kings he likes to join
streams and just chat he's a really kind
presence in all of the communities so
Alex rustamov should be a familiar face
and he's not a face that Arjun Air Guys
he wanted to see in the first round but
this Knight that's the problem for for
black you can't stop the knight from
covering G4 and going back and forth
either to H6 or to F2 or the F6 can't
cover all the squares
the bishop is basically playing
whack-a-mole and you can control two or
even three squares at one time but as
you're pointing out the Knight has one
two three four five different retreating
squares from G4 E3 F2 H2 H6 and F6
mathematically you can't put put the
bishop on a square it covers all of them
Arjun except the inevitable a big old or
Sasha rustamov and you flipped on one of
the last remaining games that means I'm
gonna buy struggling to hold it but
successfully holds this position with
black
yeah this one's a draw just to note that
a file serves as a boundary now it's a
stalemate the first round is in the
books done it we have a bunch of players
happy to start with one out of one the
next round starting immediately so you
don't have much time to be sad if you
lost no you don't you gotta hunker down
if you lost uh you gotta remind yourself
this is a nine round event ladies and
gentlemen and it's not like just the top
spot qualifies you've got a little bit
of a margin for error but Robert
conversely when you lose it's not like a
Swiss open where you might face a much
weaker opponent you're still probably
going to get a pretty strong Grand
Master it's a brutal brutal field out
there
it is and Kristen churilla I guess not
aware the round has begun he probably
left his computer now he's there he's
playing D4 and you may know the name
Christian Trilla from his streaming he
is known as the count uh but he also has
the c-squared podcast with five minute
carwana and he's a very strong player
he's a dangerous opponent Donnie I
always feel like the players who play
very often on chess.com are scary to
meet for the super gems because they
have that experience in these rapid time
controls although at the moment it seems
like Christian doesn't know he's playing
rapid chess yeah he might be the count
but I don't know if he knows how to
count his time because he's taking 30
seconds
deciding which line he's going to play I
love this from gookesh I was worried he
would play the grunfeld no he insists on
a king's Indian defense Christian
actually likes to put his Pawn on E3 as
far as I know but this particular
version E4 is kind of obligatory I guess
you can play E3 he instead plays a
fiancado system with G3 very annoying I
was about to say that down that's the
exact word because you're King's Indian
Aficionado you love playing it now we're
into more grunfeld territory with D5 but
G3 it's always geared to stop the weapon
that is the King's Indian we get
aggressive chess you just stop it before
it begins and Christian you know he's
not taking up the mantle here he's not
designed to take on D5 he's saying you
could take me on C4 but then I get this
E4 push I get the long diagonal for my
Bishop it turns into more of a Catalan
yeah in many of these D4 openings you
have to be ready to play a prolonged
period of time down upon and gukesh with
a lot of decisions here in the early
going C6 was a possibility transitioning
to kind of a grunfeld slav cross instead
he plays this in very grunefully fashion
he takes on C4 says you're giving me the
pawn I'll take it and Christian has to
decide between castling a move like
Knight F3 to E5 trying to recover the
pawn immediately but that could
potentially backfire because moving the
metaphor F3 Robert it does soften up
your control of the D4 pawn and there
are some lines uh where black can
respond with like Knight F6 to G4 things
get very very tactical there uh rather
quickly
yeah because you're moving the same
piece twice in the opening typically not
recommended it is often available to
White just to recoup that pawn on C4 but
as Donya saying your knight is currently
giving an extra Defender to the D4
Square so I think for gukesh he has the
type of position he wants it's not a
symmetrical Pawn structure it's one
where he actually has more time and
let's not forget kukesh dominated this
tournament this play in the first time
around seven and a half out of nine and
then he says Hey Vladimir big Vlad
chromic come on you're a former world
champion but I'm the present and the
future let's go at it so I feel like
kukesh he backs down to nobody he has
won this event before that's valuable
experience and so uh what's going on by
the way with Christian Shirley he's got
to move at some point
yeah I mean I hope he made his coffee
before the tournament because we're a
couple of moves in and he's down to
seven and a half minutes I truly think
he is in relatively unfamiliar territory
I think he is a fianchetto player but D
takes C4 I think is significantly less
common than C6 and Christian might be
annoyed at himself for allowing a
theoretical line that he's not too
familiar with this is not the kind of
position you want to venture into
because hey you are down upon let's not
forget that it's not like uh you're you
know you're playing with a blank check
here
no yeah you are down some material and
now down the clock a bad combination I
just want to give a shout out quickly to
vladislavartamy If He Did In fact win
that first round against San shigerov so
he beat a super GM I just want to give
him that shout out and I'm looking at
the list the standings there uh bilodeau
that is uh karilla lexienko down in 16th
they're all tied for the same place Liam
lay the very strong player from Vietnam
super Grand Master former World Blitz
Champion he has one out of one round
exoduani prognanda the teenagers Dennis
lesbik they're all there so this is a
scary field done 95. stop reading out
obscure names Robert nobody knows these
people so it's not just reading out
random names then tell me some real
people who are in this tournament I just
want to prove to everybody that I am
indeed literate that I can see names in
screen and read them out to the audience
just trying to toot my own horn a little
bit and well done you mentioned 95 you
called it so not to toot your horn over
here what do you make of that decision
well C5 played the Eva bar are not the
biggest fan whoa C5 is a typical move
and this is what I was talking about it
hits white where it hurts on the D4 pawn
queen comes out to C7 forking the Knight
and the pawn technically of course white
could play Knight takes C4 you said the
position was asymmetrical it was up
until Black's last move now the pawn
structure is completely symmetrical and
generally white is a smidge better in
these positions because his light Square
Bishop is superior to its counterpart
but of course black is incredibly solid
and Christian again settles into a thing
Knight takes C4 seems automatic to me he
finally takes that pawn maybe he's
thinking about where he wants to put
this Knight after the Queen recoups the
pawn on C5 E3 is possible but that of
course blocks the bishop you could
support it with a move like Queen B3
Robert but then black snipe jumps out to
D4 and that could be very problematic as
well I do not like the way the Christian
is managing his clock here at all
and the position I just feel like black
is castled safely this Knight's under
attack you saw said the drawback of
pretty much every night move or how you
defend it B3 that's not gonna work out
opening this diagonal loosening your
knight over here Queen B3 as you
mentioned Knight C6 to D4 happens very
quickly I like kukash's position I don't
like Christian Trails clock management
and well I do want to go to a game of
somebody who goukash beat the first time
around didn't just beat him once beat
him Thrice in Vladimir krumnik because
krumnik is playing against alexianko uh
what is this the candidates right like
this is a two super Grand Masters
playing each other and Donna it is a
very close position where white has more
space
and it's just amazing to see Vladimir
kramnik play on these events he's such a
legend I mean I think just saying these
words is pretty empty his name and his
reputation speaks for itself so all of
these generational matchups are so
fascinating but alexenko is not backing
down I think he's got a great position
out of the opening you can see the
Knight on D5 the space Advantage but the
queen side pressure might be the most
problematic element of this position for
black if B5 comes at the right time and
it's just arrived at the next doorstep
right now if you play Knight takes D5
Robert then B take C6 and C takes B7
eats through the sort of backbone of
Black's entire Queen side maybe this is
what kremnich should go for Rook B8 but
the bishop on G7 is also passive so
wherever you look there's a lot of
drawbacks in Black's position here
that's right so going back to the live
board chromic is going to sit and think
for a bit he does not make these kind of
strategic decisions quickly he
understands that this is a critical
moment and that's actually one of the
most important attributes for a chess
player is knowing when to spend your
time knowing when it's a decision that
you cannot possibly take back because
for example if you take on B5 and white
takes back now you have established an
outside pass pawn and a very Advanced
one at that so you need to be very
careful here if you are chromic and I do
want to make note of the fact that no
dearbeck Abdul sitarov is at two out of
two he beat Rodrigo Vasquez from Chile
yes I mean he is just blitzing to a
perfect score is nodir Beck Abdul
sitarov so we'll see his games in the
future but look at Vlad right he's got
the green screen behind him he just took
this Knight on D5 down your big question
which way do you take back because no
matter you could take with a c Pawn
black doesn't have time to take B5
because this Knight is under attack
so previously I pointed out the the
possibility of BC but then things kind
of liquidate down and black holes C
takes D5 is an attempt to open the C
file which is important because there's
a backward Pawn on C7 so maybe CD and
then you can even push through the pawn
down a B6 just to really try to smash
open the C file put a rook on C1 I
really think elixenko should follow his
intuition here and C takes D5 is on the
board another decision out for Vlad he
can also play Knight D4 and try to take
some minor pieces off the board
generally that favors the side who is
more cramped and well it's pretty
obvious what side that is here
so you're calling him crap Nick
I'm in physical pain okay that was good
that was good
physical pain on the queen side here by
the way yeah he does not have much space
I love moves like this right because
everyone is focused on the pawn push to
take to push he says no let's get the
Rook to B1 I have a Target in my sights
and just to quickly show A variation oh
and F5 Play Because chromic realizes he
needs to start up some counter play uh
but at some moment if you decide to take
on B5 and try to use this pin along the
A5 with B6 white can just push through
to A6 and now you have a healthy past
Pawn with a rook behind it that's not
good news for black so I don't think we
will see a capture on B5 and Donna if we
don't see that move I feel like at some
point you also have to watch out for E
takes F5 if it's Knight where to get out
the way with D4 there's a queen with its
sights towards the king side
and you see this type of pressure uh
from the black perspective in the king's
Indian where black plays F5 and then
typically black plays F4 and then G5 the
problem is the a light squared Bishop
one of the first pieces of advice you
get as a king's Indian player do not
give away your light squared Bishop
because what other piece is capable of
controlling G4 here you can't even play
H5 because the G5 Pawn Falls it takes
way too long for black to generate King
side counter play in that time white is
going to break through on the king side
so kramnik I think he is going for your
original idea he's traded on B5 and I
think he's gonna follow up with B6 I
don't see any other moves
in that case A6 Rook C1 lots of options
for Gabriel alexenko who also sits with
a minute up on the clock
yeah B6 he plays it I mean I I know I
mentioned it so it would seem like I was
calling for it but I was actually shying
away from it I didn't like the look of
this because after A6 you just have this
past Pawn that is deep in Black's
territory but maybe you're right on
second thought perhaps a move like Rook
C1 getting out of this pin you can't
take on B6 or Rook is hanging and with
check the boot but Rook C1 just goes for
the C7 Pawn which is super valuable
because then D6 gets loose after it so
I'm with you Daniel I like the look of
Rook C1 Rook C1 hit C7 or A6 a lot of
players underestimate the value of a
pass Pawn in the middle game uh in the
end game you're trying to promote a pass
spawn in the middle game you often use
pass pawns as a vehicle to slow down and
tie down your opponent's pieces uh so
that you can transition your focus to a
weakness such as C7 in this case Bishop
D2 instead has been kirill's Choice over
protecting the A5 Fawn Now The Rook on
B5 is free to move back but move back
not in corel's vocabulary in the early
going of this game as he continues to
tighten the screws and tighten the
screws things getting very unpleasant
for Vladimir what he's holding for the
time being
yeah he isn't maybe it's time to make a
weird move like Rook A7 you preemptively
defend the pawn on C7 this Pawn on A5 is
still pinned to The Rook down here and
you get ready to bring your second rook
in the event white tries A6 so I think
Rook A7 is one of these little waiting
moves that actually has a very important
idea behind it to double up and put
pressure on A5 I think this is the way
that black gets out of this with as
little damage as possible
yeah it also contains the benefit of
protecting the C7 Pawn taking the sting
out of the move Rook A1 to C1 Rook A7 to
me is a crucial defensive move but
Vladimir is investing a lot of time here
you could also put a rook on C8 that
seems more passive but at least the
Rooks stay connected whatever decision
he makes he will need to make it fast
because Vladimir kramnik and the clock
have a slightly troubled pass don't they
and relationships tumultuous yeah I
agree and Rook A7 play this just looks
very strong I bring the next Rook over
so crumnik he's holding steady here he's
doing a good job
um Donna what do you say we quickly head
to another game and just try to catch
some other action we can of course come
back here very shortly we most certainly
will we've got alireza farouja uh who is
facing Maxime chagaya viewing of this
game and that was a great decision look
at this position I'm gonna make a very
I'm gonna Hazard a risky controversial
guess I think this came out of a night
or forever
oh wow you really go out in a limp there
yes indeed it came from a night orb with
a sacrifice of an exchange on C3 there
was a rook here previously it took a
night this Pawn took back and when I
look at this position Dania the first
thing I do is count how many pawns they
have seven per side so it is an extra
Rook for white compared to a bishop for
black and I don't see an attack for
white you can push upon the bishop can
always slide away I see pressure down
the C file which means you can't take
this Knight on B4 I see ideas of Knight
A2 check trying to win this Pawn on C3 I
love this for black I don't care what
the engine says it's not equal this is
just much easier to play practically
speaking for black this is why people
hype up the night or so much because
positions like these are really really
standard issue guy falls to two and a
half minutes he's trying to figure out a
way to stop Knight A2 check that is
actually the immediate threat obviously
we should point out that the Knight is
Untouchable because black is doubled on
the C file and queen C takes C2 would be
Checkmate so maybe King B2
is a possibility for white that steps
onto the long diagonal there's a bishop
on F6 which is just rearing to go after
a move like d65 and E5 D4 Black's
position is full of tactical potential
Max scene with Rook to H3 but now the
Rook is pinned by the bishop on E6
Robert I think you're looking at the
king side I'm looking at the king side I
think we're both looking at the same
move
we know it's funny H5 is not the move I
was initially thinking about but as you
start describing the position okay I
can't fault alireza for playing D5 he
wants E4 this is a great decision played
quickly Hikaru Nakamura likes to say
sometimes it's way more important to
play good moves quickly than the best
move slowly I don't like the fact that
others is thinking though after the pawn
capture on D5 because it had to be one
of your uh thoughts here but look at
this position Donna I don't see how
white survives as if if he does he is
playing
heroic Chess at this point Maxine will
have to play the perfect moves quickly
you know good moves aren't going to cut
it with White's King caught in the
crossfire D6 which counter-attacks
Black's Queen but then Knight A2 check
looks pretty strong as an intermediate
check then you can take on C3 and you've
also got of course discovered attacks
against the white king should it appear
on B2 Maxime is down to 90 seconds this
is why I like commentating and hate
playing sometimes because you imagine
what Maxime is going through right now
trying to we work his way through this
Thicket of complications but this clock
ticking down to zero
I mean you might just have to take on e4
but look how terrible that looks with
Knight A2 check hitting the king hitting
this Pawn the bishop is open over here
this Knight will end up on the C3 square
and then if this queen lands there no
way come on there's no way you're
surviving a position like this so uh for
chagaya now down to a minute what would
you say the odds are he survives like
two percent
well knowing his successful track record
in title Tuesdays he is also a good
bullet player he's got a shot he's got a
5 10 shot but it does appear that Queen
takes E4 is actually the only move to
stay in the game he has to figure out
that after Knight A2 check the king
moves to B1 you sack uh your H3 Rook on
C3 and then that final position maybe a
move like Knight D4 something
cold-blooded keeps whites King alive
because the only threat here is Queen B2
that is a made threat Robert Knight D4
might stay alive
oh my gosh I see what you're saying
Queen takes Queen E4 was played no I'm
laughing because it's hard to spot this
and maybe you're right and I was a
little bit harsh on his chances here he
has spotted discontinuation but he goes
to the center I you know it's hard to
fault him the email bar doesn't react
incredible what about this move
oh and Rook d8 oh that is Criminal using
a vulnerable King on T2
how is the evil bar going up for white
maybe somehow in that position with
sacrificing your you have to give up
your queen here you have the two Rooks
but the C3 is loose I'm not feeling this
but here's the thing Robert after Knight
takes C3
again you have to sack your H3 Rook on
C3 once you move the king out of the
check the bishop on E6 this sounds crazy
but it is trapped CA Rook the D7 square
is defended G4 is defended by White's
Queen so alireza will have to figure
something out in that position and
here's the other thing Robert the white
king when it sits on E2 is only one step
away from evacuating to perhaps the
safest Square on the board which is F1
oh my God I am I'm shocked because this
looks so scary and I was reacting to the
fact that King was out in the open this
king of Center but the material plays a
huge role here and this Pawn on D5 is
hitting this bishop Bishop takes D5
Queen takes D5 bro I'm just gonna put
this on the board very quickly because
the position like this with the King on
D2 with C3 threatened it looks like
black has some serious play but
according to the cold-blooded engine
it's like we just take this and figure
out the rest later maybe it's your
knight D4 idea that doesn't look very
easy either because the attack kind of
rages on but with pieces traded off
don't you I think that allows the white
king to get some shelter wow the Evo bar
going
what Lions I mean maybe you moved the
king away and then the back ring threats
uh might Force black to give up more
material I cannot believe the evaluation
here I think allreza wins this game
Robert my prediction is he wins if he
takes on D5 I just don't see Maxime
working out the complications but in the
event of Knight takes C3 I think should
I have comes back and wins so critical
moment right now which all he reads the
senses he's investing a ton of time
perhaps even his entire time Advantage
into deciding between these two
candidate moves
wow I'm just shocked by how chigaya was
playing that he took on e4 brings the
king to D2 and suddenly the evil bar
swinging his favorite another player
knows that I'm sure he's still very
nervous with his King out in the open
and all the black pieces staring down
but you have to be happy by the fact
that farooza seems Frozen I did just see
him blink so I know it's not his
internet connection it's just him
thinking I like the artwork behind him
as well uh but you know the Artistry
that he looks to display in the
chessboard oh he plays it this way
we've all been there you're looking at
the position there's no way every chess
principle says that I must have
something for Russia forces the queen
trade Queen takes C2 Rook takes C2 where
does white king run does it run to F3 do
you give up G4 Eva bar dropping is it
because of Rook C3 check
yeah but I mean quickly what was the
move if not for this seems like the eval
actually with more depth it's suggesting
that maybe black was actually in this
the whole time so it's one of these
positions that uh you know will have to
analyze in great detail with a a
physical board trying to work through it
but it does seem like alireza now has
the upper hand here if he plays this
accurately
if you can take on B3 Robert the other
move is Bishop E6 takes G4 giving up the
bishop kind of a Desperado move so you
have to decide which opposite colored
Bishop end game which Pawn structure you
actually want I think in both cases
Maxime should be able to hold the draw
his Bishop on B5 is on an Ideal location
he is completely immobilizing Black's
Pawn majority on the queen side so big
priority now for Maxime is to make sure
he doesn't drop any pawns on the king
side and that's exactly what he's doing
with a well-timed G5 I think he should
hold with a couple more careful moves
King G3 but the King on H3 and don't
give up your H4 Pawn
but done it blacks up a pawn and at some
point if I can establish this money for
watch out for this exchange sacrifice on
B5 I know that may seem wild but I'm
gonna give this check Force the king
away Play Bishop D4 with Tempo play E5
and seriously watch out for the
sacrifice because that a pawn runs very
quickly if you can get that pawn to A3
you don't even need to promote it
yeah no this is just and this king is
running towards the center he plays 55
to take away the C7 check
yay it's seriously almost time to think
about it oh it happens the problem is
maybe yeah as I said I promise The Rook
would be able to slide uh behind the
pawn rather than in front of it
and that's a deal breaker instead he
puts his Rook on F4 he ties down whites
King and now he's trying to get his own
King into the center but the problem is
Black's King doesn't really have any
purchase on this position even if you
get it to B4 maybe you try to get it to
before and then sack your Rook rate that
takes a long time and E6 is a big
weakness the black has to attend to and
maybe he puts his spot on E5 maybe now's
the time
yeah the king is centralized the bishop
covers the C7 Square so everything under
blast control watch out because you
can't lose sight of this F2 Pawn if
you're white you can't just run your
Rook to C8 you will drop this very
important Pawn H6 I really like that
move down you're trying to create
another weakness and if it's on G5
that's a dark square if you take and the
pawn takes back if this bishop can slide
back to E7 now you have a path to H4
forget the Evo bar if you're watching
this it's all about posing practical
problems four seconds for Chicago so
what you need is to face him with an
unexpected problem Ollie Russ is going
to move his King put his Bishop on E7
and try to move the King again to open
up the attack on the H4 Pawn if he wins
the second Pawn it's safe to say that
he's going to win the game patient V6 he
makes improvements Bishop C5 is possible
as well instead he shuffles his Rook to
E4 two seconds for two guys
it isn't this bishop wrap around here it
comes to F6 and H4 is falling down
Bishop F6 anyway and Rook H4 even though
the pawn is on a light Square you can't
defend it check on D7 though should guy
have not going away without a huge fight
and Rook F5 okay I like to move Bishop
forcing the king away now Rook F5 goes
to pick up this Pawn but maybe white has
just enough activity to stay in this one
and he attacks B7 that can be defended
by the bishop how do you counter-attack
E6 maybe bishop C4 should be considered
here
played it good I by you I was thinking
how in the world you survive this game
looks like black is taking charge I
would just play E5 in one check here the
king runs away I think you just need to
play this quickly it gives up
though this has to be good for black
right oh but Bishop D7
it traded Royce and you might have had a
blockade on the resulting pawns now it's
a three result game wait a second yeah
it's not over
no this phone is very fast this Rook
comes to A7 E5 is available in the near
future
okay so now you're trying to get your
king up and dislodge Black's Rook but
and again look for The Exchange
sacrifice on E6 and these pawns going
and that's what you guys keeping his
King close to the potential E6 Pawn
there goes the b-pawn you've got to keep
your Rook on the a file
before sacrificing the bishop might was
possible there
yep but he just says I'm Gonna Keep My
bishop and push the pawn is rookie six
winning if I think it is yeah here comes
the pawn because the king tries to get
up to F6 and you give a check and black
one by resonates just to quickly show
King F5 B2 King F6 you're about to
deliver a Checkmate that looks great but
it's not in time because actually you
don't even need to sacrifice your Bishop
stop Checkmate when the bishop can block
the queens of the perfect spot I was
thinking you have to play Queen ba but
no you literally keep your newly
promoted Queen this was Exquisite
handling of time pressure Byler as a
Frugal we take this stuff for granted
but he kept posing problems and posing
problems in the middle game and in the
end game he never let your guy of get in
a single easy move Robert and that's the
kind of spirit you need to display to
win in these types of tournaments
it is indeed and with seven grueling
rounds of play left in the Swiss before
we get to the match play we're gonna
take a short break but we're gonna
return just a few for more from the
chessful Masters playing stage we'll be
right back
hello this is Christoph zileki and
welcome to my keep it simple 1d4 course
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
makeyourchess.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
foreign
much but neither would a Sicilian
Defense to the untrained eye this is a
performance enhancer you don't see it
how about now manage your air quality
sharpen your performance change the game
with air things
[Music]
welcome back to the play and stage of
the chasseable Masters we are watching
the nine round switch which will
determine the 72 players that will fight
for a spot in one of three divisions
alongside Grand Master Robert Hess great
start to the tournament Grandmaster
Robert has
yeah I thought you might say great to
start the tournament Grandmaster Min
late because wonderful time well known
to the community I'm not that smooth
come on hey man you got it going on in
artemia by the way at a perfect two out
of two so these are both players who are
extremely dangerous of course vladislav
the higher rated player in all the time
patrols but Min he's a beast you
probably played Min more than anybody
else has
I have indeed and I've played in all
sorts of time controls from bullet to
Blitz I've never played him in a ten
plus two time control he recently got
his Grandmaster title which was a long
time coming Min was one of the strongest
IMS in history
and I don't know he seems to be off to a
pretty decent start this tournament two
out of Two and a nice Bishop on F4 a
kind of Queen's Gambit decline structure
I don't know what his Knight is doing on
D2 otherwise it's pretty standard fare
yeah why is that 992 is a good question
the answer is because a bishop
apparently came out to B4 with oh with
check on B4 here and then the knight
from F3 went back to D2 not something
you see every day but not wanting to
give up double pawns potentially so Min
just playing his own type of Chess he is
a perfect two out of two and I think
that uh in this game with the bishop 104
as you're saying it is quite a decent
start the pawn D5 creates tension here
black doesn't really want to take on C4
next because it will allow white to go
forward but the bishop 1 B7 will be a
happy camper if the diagonal remains
open so indeed it's going to be good for
black if I'll leave you for 30 seconds
Robert I think some people might have
heard what that is gotta make sure it's
not a you know it's not the police at
the door so I will be I will be right
back and I'll let you continue unpacking
this position as Min he was a Min up on
the clock but that time advantages no
longer I'll be right back Robert but I'm
listening to what you have to say so
please behave yourself
I appreciate that so we know who's not
here Donya it's a chair stream now but
D5 played by artemia both sides are
using a lot of time in the early stages
artemiev has in just over eight minutes
men under that and they've only played
eight moves so a surprisingly slow start
the two of the best bullet players on
site right now you know man is thinking
do I take this Pawn on D5 but he's aware
that our team is likely to take back
with the Knight on D5 he wants to keep
the diagonal open maybe we'll see a
queen land on the Square and oftentimes
just show a quick variation that black
doesn't even mind giving up this Pawn on
C7 because you get very very quick
counter play around this piece you can
play even Knight C6 bring a rook to C8
and you're just way too active as the
bishop on F1 can't get out with the g2
Pawn being loose over here so we'll see
how this one continues at this stage the
pawn was just captured on D5 the Knight
quickly recaptures I'm liking the look
of this for artemia from the perspective
of it being a rapid game or from just
how quickly he's playing chat what do
you think what is Donnie doing right now
that's my question because he told me
he'd be back in 30 seconds it's been
more than 30 seconds who do you think is
at his door so I want to hear your
thoughts in chat maybe we'll feature
some of those responses but all I know
is that uh Min he better be at his seat
he better be concentrated because
artemium is not going to make this easy
for him so well they sit and think I
think we'll go to a different game the
one between
if Alex cenko's name rings a bell it's
because he was in the Ken it's not
because he's a down his front door and
he just beat Vladimir krummick in the
previous round and oh hey look who's
back who was it it was a pest control I
had to open the door for them it's my
quarterly Pest Service because in North
Carolina
you don't want to mess with the
Cockroaches and I learned that the hard
way so but but they know that you
commentate with me so that's why they
came they thought I was being a pest
well you're always being a pest by
definition
knock on wood I haven't had any
cockroaches inside in the last couple of
months but
fast control everybody especially if you
live in a region like the South
see I'm adulting this is this is what
adult life is supposed to look like
running around during commentary how
unprofessional wait wait wait wait but
first of all hashtag adulting and then
second of all I'm looking at the
standings Alexandra castenoke is two out
of two so let's go the chess Queen is
taking part in this and she is playing
no dierberg Abdul sitar and what did we
just enter over here okay black just
took something on D5 and Alexandra
capture this is a dragon and
unfortunately for Sasha she had to
capture with the epon because Queen
takes D5 would have run into Bishop E6
then look at doterbeck he says you play
G4 I don't care I am gobbling everything
up and of course H5 here is more
standard I guess black will just
continue gobbling G takes F3 do you
believe in castanyak's attack here
um
just based on how you said it no I think
you really led me to I believe that
black should be doing all right and the
evob art is in Black's favor biasing me
a little bit and so I think that
Alexandra who beat Pepe Cuenca and
vibhav Suri in the last two rounds she's
been taken down her GM's wow opponents
in the first two she's being met with a
Super Jam right now so it's a different
level in this one and so done it I I
don't want to take on G4 because once
the bishop takes I feel like the king is
better protected but maybe I go for that
swing The Rook over to G1 real quick and
say I'm going to attack you with Knight
F4 and pawn to H5
yeah there's a lot of ways for it to
arrange her pieces on the king side five
minutes only for Cassandra she's three
minutes down to me H5 is still the most
natural continuation but you can also
take a Tempo to play a move like F4
which looks very awkward but maybe you
want to try to drive the king side up to
make H5 even stronger but Black's Bishop
is immediately going to jump into F5 wax
Queen can jump into A5 so it's not like
black is sleeping on the queen side
either white might very well be the one
who gets checkmated in the end
yeah there's a bishop the dragon Bishop
over here a second Bishop joined the
party and this looks like Troublesome
news for Alexandria who's dropped to
four and a half minutes on the clock so
we're looking at a position where white
king mate no you know safer than blacks
H5 it's slow moving on this flank and
she is moving quite slowly she's down
four minutes on the clock and you don't
want that to be the case against no
deerback Abdul sitarov the legendary
player from Uzbekistan legendary as a
teenager yes indeed that's what happens
when you win Olympiad gold for your
country and almost win Tata steel
unfortunately he lost his final round
and Anish giri was a belief program
I will never forget the final round of
Tata steel this year if you haven't seen
it one of these evenings you should do
yourself a favor and watch the playback
of the Tata steel final round one of the
most incredible moments of my
commentating career but Notre back the
thing is you're gonna get so many
chances you're at the start of your
chess career and how much he's already
accomplished is incredible trying to add
a qualification to the air things
Masters to his very impressive resume
casting down to three and a half minutes
Robert I just don't see her pulling this
one out at this point
and you could see her she's really
trying to pick out the best option here
but she's unsure and maybe you have to
go all in and sometimes just playing
these kind of quick moves like tags
virtue one but as you said the bishop
will slide back to F5 she starts at
Knight D4 which does take away the F5
square and looks like H5 is next so
Donna I feel like it's a type of move
that works out quite well in quicker
time controls but not when you're also
down four and a half minutes yeah I mean
H5 is essentially a pre-move black is
obviously not going to take that Knight
with his dark Square Bishop neuterbeck
might play a move like Queen A5 and
accumulate his pieces on the queen side
when you've got the eval bar behind you
it's so easy to just laugh White's
attack out of the room I think the
biggest problem Robert is that after
white plays H5 black is going to ignore
because H6 is not that dangerous the
black Bishop has the F6 Square the king
can hide on h8 and if white opens up the
H file even if white puts a queen on H2
you can imagine H5 HG and then Queen H2
you're not gonna be three anything all
that significant because Queen H7 is far
from Checkmate the king can run the
other way so I just feel like it takes
so much time for white to actually
generate a mate threat Black's going to
use that time to generate some mate
threats of his Zone and there he goes
good call Queen A5 going right after
this D5 Pawn uh that is an important
Central Pawn and also make the king feel
safer as the queen goes from d8 to the
center and over towards the king side so
I like this vision for no dearbeck we
will see more from him and for Alexandra
Good Start not looking great in this
third game and she plays H5 and done yet
I feel like Queen takes D5 is the move
that we're about to see very quickly it
was the point of Queen A5 and it does
bring that Queen closer to where the
action is happening
yeah Notre back cold-blooded and
composed he's not afraid of ghosts he's
not afraid of cockroaches either and
that Queen winding its tentacles around
white spawns much like a cockroach I
think Queen takes D5 is going to Signal
the imminent end of his stanyuk's
attacking chances and the end of this
game is near as well
yeah your point is well taken that after
this exchange the king will go out to F7
now it's not just game over on the spot
but if this King can successfully run
away back towards the center there will
be no attack and black will be one maybe
two maybe three pawns ahead at some
point and so that's the great news for
no deer back but let's go to some other
action just because you know these
rounds we're starting to see who is
going to rise to the top Den Laz and a
Wonder Liang they have two and a half
out of three so they've already finished
three games of action uh which game do
you want to head to because we also have
Jose Martinez he's one of those names
that you don't often see in classical
chess but here in the quicker time
controls online he is a force to be
reckoned with I absolutely think we
should go to his game especially given
the kind of position that he has
oh my goodness it's gonna take me about
30 minutes to adjust my eyes to this
position Jocelyn reacts a lot faster D5
instantly counter-attacking the bishop
the bishop moves back 90 is this the
hyperbole game Robert or are we watching
a rap what are we watching here I think
we're about to watch black create a past
pawn and try to promote it normally you
would give up your Rook for two minor
pieces but in the event of the capture
on C2 and I jumped ahead of myself here
A2 happens and A1 is Unstoppable so
black has some serious threats here with
that a pawn going up the board but Diana
the big question is is this night Frozen
like it has nowhere to go all of its
retreating squares are covered by
White's pieces so this is yakubayev the
other no dear Beck and he has the black
pieces here he's gone for a very
interesting solution and I just want to
point out that the E1 Square may be
where this Knight vacates to dania
yeah and that might be necessary of
course White's ideal scenario is to
slice off the connection between Black's
bishop and the Knight you can try to do
that in a variety of ways Bishop D3 is
one attempt but you're right after takes
take the Knight does jump into E1 and
white is in big trouble that A3 Pawn is
going to make its presence all there are
also maybe tactical ways to protect that
night even Queen A4 there that's what I
was thinking Roxy to Queen C2 even
followed by A2 you don't need to do that
you can play A2 immediately but this
just illustrates the power of past pawns
even in the middle game white doesn't
have the Personnel to deal with
everything at the same time so Robert
instead of Bishop D3 Jasper goes for a
more positional approach he sticks the
knight in the center he slices off
Black's contact with the E1 Square
and now I think Bishop D3 is a lot more
serious of a threat because you're going
to recapture with the Knight and again
you're going to keep the E1 Square
protected well that's kind of a sick
line that the Knight drops back the
cover E1 also G4 because the bishop
doesn't have G6 you would take it there
and if it goes to E4 at some point you
may be able to kick it as well so a
black needs to be very very careful at
this point I think that we love this
outside pass Pawn it's a runner we just
saw lines where you could sacrifice
material to make sure that it could
Sprint to the other side but right now
it's a pretty critical moment and I
think Queen A4 is the move that I would
be playing here just trying to over
protect the Knight for the moment and
then there likely will be a fancy night
jump in the future
can't believe the players are actually
thinking after what we just saw in the
last couple of moves with black has a
lot of calculating to do if he loses the
Knight he loses the game so he has to
rely on the power of that A3 Pawn I
agree Queen A4 lend as much support as
you can to that night and try to take
the sting out of Bishop D3 we've got
many other games though heating up I'm
looking at levonaroni and durarart
Bailey and Peter svidler always love to
see Peter Spindler in any event oh my
gosh wait good game to bring us to
because there's a Checkmate what's the
material by the way black is up in
exchange
I think droia Queen E5 Queen D4 is a
weird repetition not something you get
every day vasif could put his Queen on
H5 Robert if he wants to keep playing
but with the time deficit that he has
and an exchange down on the board I
think a draw is not a bad result here
no a draw looks uh very reasonable at
this point because when the queen gets
to H5 actually the black king can go to
G7 that Knight can't share the square
with the queen
I have a sick line for you after Queen
E5 black and play Queen takes C2 and you
might say oh well then the Knight moves
back in its Checkmate it wouldn't be
Checkmate F6 Rook takes F6 is the mating
line Rook D1 and Rook F1 wherever you
check the Rook drops back with a
discovery and the queen mates on G7 what
that's amazing because white was about
to get checkmated but it's Checkmate
first in the other direction and we see
Queen D4 back so we are likely to see a
repetition unless vasif says I'm ready
to play for a win I need to get a big
score to compete for that top division
let's go for Queen H5 but moves like
that backfire in time trouble the king
slides up to G7 and down there may even
be Queen takes F6 at some moment there
getting two Rooks for the Queen the
seats down under a minute on the clock
he's seriously thinking about it he's
got one and a half out of two so a draw
really not a disaster obviously the
thief is the younger player he wants to
defeat Peter svidler but at this point
45 seconds repeat moves make the draw
take a little break and come back
stronger the next game watch him play
Queen H5 with like five seconds on the
clock
you can't do that with no time right
like you have to do it now because I I
the more he thinks the more I think we
are going to get a repetition because
yes Queen F4 and queen D2 and that
should be that after Queen E5 and the
third and final time the suspicious
reach means the game ends in a draw so
why don't we go away from this somehow
they play on we'll come back to it but I
think there's so many other interesting
games that we might want to check in on
or not
he took all of his time and then decided
to play on in the most unlikely position
Robert I thought it was a bygone
conclusion that he was going to decline
the queen trade but no he's banking on
his Pawn mass of all moves B3 that was
like completely off my radar playing on
the other flank isn't black just going
to start bringing the second rook and
causing this white king some problems
like Rook d8
this is nutty this is absolutely nutty
to play on much less with 17 seconds on
the clock
I I'm shocked but you did make a great
point that this Knight going into D5
will be a pain like F5 here then Knight
D5 you just clog the D file and if the
white king gonna get up to the F4 Square
white can even play for a win here but
with the clock the way it is done yet
and these Pawns
going to be targeted by The Rook I feel
like Fiddler's gonna win this game
I do as well three seconds is with
advances his King he goes King G1 to
avoid getting pinned King G2 and King F3
might have been a more desirable path to
take now Peter can chase the night out
of F6 with his own King he can play King
G7 the Knight Will default back to D5
and then the E4 Pawn is going to be
tender perhaps black and attack it with
Rook E8 and there's Bishop takes F5 on
the horizon as well the E1 Rook is
undefended this was a very gutsy
decision a brave decision but
potentially I think a losing decision
Bishop C6 and the Knight has lost
contact with the Outpost on D5 you're
showing what black is about to do the
White's entire Queen side
here comes the bike everything is
yeah this one is just it's one of these
decisions you just can't make like I
understand we applaud it because it was
Brave but the other side of Bravery or
sometimes in uh conjunction with bravery
is maybe not the best decision and here
all the pawns are about to fall or this
way pin win win take everything you want
it's yours and Done It This is Gonna
backfire completely
you just couldn't decide he was trying
to sit on two chairs as the expression
goes he took all of his time okay now
we've got to make the draw he plays B3
he thinks that he can tricks Fiddler in
the end game but that was a decision
that he will regret for the rest of this
tournament if I see if it's going to be
on one and a half out of three and as
Peter Peter continues to take Pawn after
Pawn I think we can entrust the rest of
the game to him let's see if he's not
resigning but he will resign momentarily
yeah because this Rook takes E2 and
Bishop F3 check at the end of the
sequence and he went on time but he was
winning on the board so let's go
elsewhere by the way nudie Rebecca did
take down Alexander kostenic let's go to
the game between look at this Alex sanco
and Salim Salah up two minutes and with
what looks like a mating attack against
the black king
yeah this is a wild position so I'm with
four seconds and a losing position
that's more important
and I like senko just taking all of
Black's pieces last ditch attempt by
celebrity Perpetual check the king but
you are not going to touch that Bishop
you're avoiding it with a 10-foot pole
actually Robert the presence of that
Bishop helps white evade the checks
after Queen H1 King F2
and now white can even consider Queen
takes each one of the trade queens and
then go after all the queen side pawns
I'm not sold that's 100 winning you have
to be sure about that uh otherwise you
can bring your queen I think this way
and isn't that a forced Queen trade oh
the queen can take on F6 but black is
going backwards yeah Queen H2 is winning
Queen takes F6 and the H5 Pawn Falls
with Checkmate okay with full due
respect to Solo's on mass on the king
side I think White's two Rooks are going
to be just sufficient enough to win this
game King G3 and King H4 and upon his
whole life flies it's easy so let's go
to another game that's still in progress
we have Vinnie the Pooh and the big fish
Vladimir ferroseev and what a game we
tuned into here White's actually
temporarily up a piece but everything is
hanging in this position and there's a
mate attack for white
and that's the most important factor
otherwise black would just capture the
Knight on C4 and be 800 pawns up
actually only two pawns up but the
threat of Queen H7 forces uh feta save I
think to repeat moves in fact he's got
to be careful where he delivers the
track Queen G4 check is a very tricky
move King F2 Queen G3 forces the queen
trade with interest so in that case
white will have to sidestep the check on
F1 instead but this is going to be a
draw I don't see a way for feta Sev to
prolong this game there's a funny way to
lose it won't be funny for fedocia but
look at this for a ditchy metal if King
G2 was played an F3 check I know there
was better but King G3 it turns the
tables around you don't have a check on
D6 the Knight actually plays A Part here
as white goes and checkmates down the H
file so uh you know additional way way
way too strong bringing the king up to
F2 there's a check here as is played
where's this King going yeah it's this
kind of finding some trouble here he's
playing for the win oh my gosh Queen D7
King takes G5
no way but the queen comes to G7 with
check so Queen check but if king of
three there's G4 oh my gosh he's in a
path of no return I think he has to take
on G5 and drop the King on the H file
cheap okay so G4
oh Robert my goodness G4 King G2 F3 King
G3 instead fetusa just gets his Queen in
G7 there's no more main threat I think
he's gonna win this game he just wants
to push his pawns up the board oh wait a
second
now he's out of chapter three yeah you
just lose the pawn
he's trying to get him is he going with
that we're going F4 oh he brought her
this queen
what just happened
I guess that's Time Tunnel for you it's
not completely
I mean you know him he is a bullet Beast
though this Knight's coming real quick
game G5 you can't take that pawn because
of the fork here goes White's epon
mm-hmm
this King can run to E6 now that's the
good news for black now this is winning
he found he found the way out although
there is a check now that's pretty nasty
such a good move it's such a good move
it gets out of all the checks but it's
all getting his Rook to D7 just wait a
second no checks against this King on G5
so Rook D7 wait a second
oh my gosh seven and then seven is
winning he misses it
and now it stopped and the beat calling
can't be stopped
two E7 and King E8 and you're gonna give
your queen up for the night on F6
and it's still not over
check where's the king go this is Maiden
one everybody so you can't get a queen
just yet on H3 Ah that's six Falls and
that's that finally I mean we said that
like eight different times but the game
continued that's the nature of this kind
of time Patrol and the queen will
sacrifice for the Knight here once it
goes back
otherwise you're getting a queen check
you can run The Rook
a deep it's always winning there for a
move yeah right here Rook F7 check if
the King goes to G8 Knight F6 forces the
king over Rook H7 is checking mate
remember this configuration everybody
the Knight does uh the Lion's Share of
the work but if the king went the other
way you have Knight F6 that you can get
E7 check you push the pawn to the other
side and you're up all the material so
that was a winning Miss by editing it
was a one move idea but
you know you got to get those wins and
speaking of a win damn late gets one
over Armon mccallion
yeah big win for the former World Blitz
Champion speaking of former world
champions komsky's playing and Sam Sevin
is locked in an end game struggle
against David Antonio he's up upon looks
winning for black but I think it's
actually a draw because of the weakness
of the H5 Juan to which Flex Knight is
tied
yeah and the King can't get in the night
covers at Five but your king can't get
forward that's the bad news
let's go to the compsy game because you
mentioned a world championship Contender
I have to go here and oh gosh we're just
getting into a long end game that is
definitely a draw uh but komsky he has
that Wiley veteran experience do you
think there's any way he can trick his
opponent
I would say without the pawn perhaps
although Rook vs Bishop is a very
Elementary draw if you know the main
idea of moving into the corner opposite
the color of your Bishop with the
presence of the pawn Robert as long as
black doesn't blunder his Bishop E3
there was a good way to lose this should
be a Tetra ah but he's trying to trick
him please play E3 and the king would
have come around but as long as you
don't get forced to the back rank you'll
be okay
yeah and the king is going to chill on
the seventh rank now you could move your
Bishop to C2 the only thing to avoid is
putting the bishop on the same file as
the king Bishop F1 uh would be a blunder
because of Rook F6 for example
right so it's hard for black to blunder
if the pawn and Bishop are connected
with each other and you just don't want
to allow this Rook to check you and
force the king of the back rank but
that's why the king keeps going from
side to side so while this game looks
like a pretty simple split of the point
I'm just gonna look at the standings
here Donya farusia Abdus atarov artemiev
Liam
alexienko and ferrosev are at the top
with perfect three out of three scores
three out of three in a tournament like
this it's almost like getting nine out
of nine out of title Tuesday that's how
hard it is to win three games against
really strong Grand Masters it's only
cut out for a few Robert I called I'm
gonna give myself a pat on the back
vladislava Tammy if keep your eyes on
him because our temmiev is clearly in
good form this tournament
he is not going to let up without at
least aiming for a seven and a half out
of eight or eight out of nine camski by
the way is still trying he's got Black's
King oh very close to the edge and he's
going to win the pawn
but black king is near the correct
corner that's right so this Pawn can be
captured this is still a theoretical
draw at least white has more winning
chances than a few moves ago if this
king gets to the last rank you start
feeling like there's a shot yeah this is
this is the famous theoretical draw
because the bishop just goes like this
don't go there it's the stalemate the
problem is that it's a stalemate with
the bishop on G8 and a rook on E8 don't
go Bishop G8
you do to be careful because sometimes
you go to the wrong square and then the
Rook gets to attack the bishop but here
you have to check the king and the King
went to H6 the king would have gone this
way look at this technique flawless
but four seconds Anything Can Happen
white can make a thousand moves all it
takes is putting the bishop on the wrong
Square once but this is fantastic you
keep the bishop between G8 and H7 as
long as you can
this is something that for newer players
it won't make any sense but as long as
you study this at the top of it watch
out though oh there's a check here the
bishop slides back to H7 it's always a
thing don't go there now because Rook
see a check
Rook C8 and Rook C4 almost winning but
there's a fork on D5 there commsky is a
devilish player in these types of
positions and in any type of position
he's still trying but the bishop has too
many retreating squares that deliver a
check
that's right so you know you would
really like to go on a yoyo string
quickly deliver this mate
okay you got the bishop off here no we
always wondered he pre-moved it oh my
goodness
oh my goodness let's go back here
quickly
he had the perfect defense for so many
moves and he needed to just not put his
Bishop here where the king is anyways
like here Bishop C4 even Bishop A2
Robert because Rook to C3 again we talk
about this there are too many checks
Bishop F7 check and the process rinses
and repeats he pre-moves he didn't
expect gotta to step into G6
oh my gosh and it loses the bishop on
the spot because the king now is
smothered otherwise and that is a win
for gotta komsky I asked you the
question will gotta show that legendary
technique I've used the word legendary
often today Dania that was sick
that was a very well deserving label of
legendary he won Rook versus bishop and
pawn I have never seen anybody win that
against the GM got akomski is a wizard
but speaking of wizards we've got two
other Wizards facing off in round four
it's fedasev against artemy of it's a
Berlin it's Vladimir fedesaf who really
needs to try to make a push here with
the white pieces to stop the blistering
a lot of slav or Tim if he's cooking
with some fish oil early in this
tournament
but these aren't Wizards Tanya these are
Gotham Knights and Brazil Capybaras
because these two players play in the
Pro chess league federuseum for the
knights and uh artemiev he stepped in in
week two for the capybars their season
unfortunately has not gone the way that
they would have liked but he did help
them in that week so in week two
matchups so we see a symmetrical
position for now nothing too exciting as
of yet I'm just pumped about the
matchups we have because we have this
one we have farugia with the black
pieces against Liam and this position
already looks interesting I'm going to
open up the game between Abdus atarov
and alexenko so
kind of
pick your desired game done and we have
so many good ones in store for everybody
and this doesn't even take into account
all the people with two and a half out
of three
it does not indeed let's stick to
notorbeck's game for the time being
because we do have Notre back's camera
coming up and it's a classic Roy Lopez
Robert A couple of years ago a bishop on
D2 would have been Unthinkable in the
real Lopez you would have said for sure
that the player with the white piece
just isn't experienced in the ideas but
computers have breathed so much new life
into openings that we thought we
completely understood in fact we don't
understand anything at all as we now
realize
yeah the bishop on D2 what's the point
well of course it helps you try to
connect the Rooks but also takes away
this A5 square and in many positions
that Knight tries to jump out to A5 not
in this one and white can expand over
here on the Queensland B4 A4 C4 even in
some positions and the bishop is well
placed to protect this Pawn on B4
especially if this a pawn releases its
defense and with a knight gone from F6
black could consider an aggressive
approach with King h8 followed by F7 F5
but I feel like with black being as
cramped as he is that's probably ill
advised the knight from D7 also has a
decision to make it can jump to F6 it
can jump to B6 and lend some more
support to the queen side try to slow
down White's Pawn breaks that you
mentioned A4 and C4 so a pleasant
position I think for Notre back a small
time advantage that he's building up and
some decisions to be made for Karel
elixenko he needs to be careful if he
wants to stay balanced here
yeah you know it's one of these
decisions that you just make instantly
oh it doesn't matter where my knight
moves I'll just attack this bishop out
of here but you choose the wrong side of
the board and you can pay the price for
example if you play Knight to F6 and the
bishop slides back to B3 and A4 happens
this Rook is perfectly positioned on A1
and that's why Knight B6 was Alex
Cinco's choice he's just trying to make
A4 as difficult as possible so Daniel
what do you say do you actually think
that white has a better position the
eval Bar says it's about level uh in
this one who would you prefer to play
Black or White well as the
self-respecting king's Indian player I
have to say black anytime there's the F5
idea in any position I basically prefer
black but in all seriousness Robert if
you fall asleep here uh as notorbeck
which he most certainly doesn't he
strikes immediately with D4 but F5 is
still possible I think F5 and if you
play e takes F5 it's a classic idea E4
shoves the Knight out of the way and
black suddenly develops a pretty
menacing set of ideas on the king side
yeah this would be very very pleasant
for black and I'm wondering though after
F5 what about D takes E5 because if you
take this Pawn the Knight goes to D4 and
then Knight C6 is an idea devil as well
you know I'm just playing the position
you know I didn't like it necessarily
but I felt like I had to and there's
something that always worries me about a
king on h8 and a bishop on B3 I'm just
worried I'm gonna fall victim to some
kind of Checkmate that I was unaware was
gonna happen
yeah especially if you push the F Pawn
you could push it to F6 I think that's a
a likelier move than F5 but this is
exactly yeah Knight H4 Queen H5 96 here
two moves away from Checkmate any time
the king is out of squares you have to
be very very careful about these types
of mating mechanisms instead we have a
transformation alexenko decides to trade
on D4 which is a concession but his
Bishop comes out to B7 it hits C4 and C7
C5 is a rapid Queen side expansion that
could lock White's Bishop out of the
game permanently
yeah that actually looks very unpleasant
for a white there because if the pawn
gets of the C4 the bishop will be locked
down on A2 and that's a great Pawn chain
just blunting that Bishop's access in
the diagonal but this Knight wants to go
to F5 and the bishop goes to F6 so I
feel like white has what looks like
threats but they're one move threats and
black can Parry them and respond pretty
easily
what does subjector of say before he
takes the show to a break
I'll be right back
oh
I wasn't expecting you to use the last
part of his first name but how long ago
come up with that
well while you were you know explaining
the position eloquently and highlighting
ideas I was thinking of meaningless puns
Notre back is thinking about sacrificing
the E4 Pawn we both raised our eyebrows
is he intending Queen G4 when the bishop
will have to stay pegged
to the long diagonal to avoid Knight C6
very interesting play for Mr abdicator
do you believe this though are you
buying into this
no I also was thinking that you would
use a Terminator reference like I'll be
back or something like that but
you went a different chat is going to
impale me for that
why did they not capture on e4 what is
the drawback of taking what looks like a
frequent now I see it that if there's a
take on E7 Rook E1 there's a pin that
looks unpleasant but earlier I really
thought that
E4 could have been captured did he get
away with this
we're about to find out oh he's got
Queen B7 I think that's a Saving Grace
Queen E7 to B7 not only getting out of
the pin but also hitting the G2 pawn and
if you can force white to play F3 that
closes down the Avenue that White's
Queen otherwise would take to get to the
king side so maybe Queen G4 is a better
version of that trade still I think it's
clear that motorbike has overestimated
his play on the king side
yeah good find and a quick find by
alexenko there because I really thought
that this was going to be a problem but
he just no I went C5 I cleared the
seventh rank in comes Queen B7 with a
threat against this Pawn while escaping
the uh pin on the e-file
also important Robert Queen H4 would not
succeed there because of G3 and the
queen would be pushed right back to uh
right back to E7 and after we would pick
up the bishop so Queen B7 is a must find
and is this on the board yes it is
there's Queen B7
yeah no Alex senko he's been playing a
very good event thus far he took down
krumnick he beat Salem Salette in the
previous game so he's in fantastic shape
at the moment and not a player you
really want to mess with because when
he's on his best form when he's in on
his a game I mean he made the cabinets
after all
yeah you don't make the candidates by
accident he made it with a standout
performance in the Isle of Man
tournament which is of course a
qualifier of the top two spots I think
qualified to the candidates or is it
just the top spot
uh in that one it was uh the top spot
but then because he finished in that tie
there but the wild card was given to him
so I guess he didn't technically qualify
directly but he was eligible while based
on his amazing score in the grand Swiss
style Isle of Man
what an absolute scrub couldn't even win
that tournament but like senko is off to
a great start we've got plenty of other
players who are off to a great start I'm
looking at Levon against I mean top of
the buy of course we've already talked
about the artemi of game so we could
check back into that one and limb
against farusha those are our three big
matches you've put on the feta say of
our team game which is still more or
less symmetrical we've got a little bit
of an imbalance there with both players
saddled with weak pawns but the C6 Pawn
looks quite a bit weaker than the D4
Pawn I would give the slight edge here
to Mr fedesev yeah and it's Portland C6
can't be captured immediately because
Rook C8 will pick up this loose Knight
on C3 but I like the look of Knight E4
potentially though there's Bishop F5 to
deal with I feel like they're just
little things left and right the players
have to uh look out for but after Knight
takes D5 done and now I feel like
neither side has any real problems
exactly snoring is correct we're not
asleep but we just know where the
direction that this game is going so I'm
gonna already take us away from here we
will look back if it gets interesting
but you mentioned limley and ferrugia
why don't we take a look here and I see
a knight attacking the queen I see a
knight jumping into D6 I see a wonderful
Catalan Bishop I like White's position
yeah white is having a wonderful time I
don't know if menly is having a
wonderful time we will see but no
question that Lim has gotten precisely
the kind of position that you wanted of
a Catalan Knight D6 I think is next
wherever Black's Queen goes Queen E7
Knight D6 and you attack the tail of the
discovery so wherever black snipe goes
you take the Rook with Tempo and hit the
queen if Rook C7 happens there and B5
separates the two Knights black could
actually end up just flat out losing
material here if alireza is not careful
you can see the evil bar shooting up no
matter where the knight from C6 jumps to
you take E5 this is bad news
um so what moved his black player
because your Queen's under attack and I
don't see how Queen B8 helps with Knight
D6
um
you done yet this looks really really
bad
I'm at a loss Queen B6 96 Knight D4
can't do that either because the D4
square is protected twice this black
it's black just flat oh there is another
interesting line Robert Queen B8 Knight
D6 Rook d8 you might have Knight takes
B7 and queen takes E5 are you kidding me
exactly it's a monster
yeah look at this the pin along the
diagonal
he said oh
965 Bishop takes B7 and Rook B8 and you
win back the pawn so maybe this is what
alireza should try to bank on now Knight
takes B7 there was not forced but you
want to try to set traps when the
situation is this dire I think it was
good but you throw in Rook takes first
this is important inclusion because if
it takes Queen E5 Knight takes Bishop
takes Rook B8 the difference is the back
rank Checkmate so white has Rook C1
you've traded off the other rook in the
position if the bishop is captured Rook
seen his mate if the bishop is not
captured The Rook stops one square short
on C7 and white just dominates the
ensuing end game so I think that you
know you called it B7 is loose even
though it seems protected and that's why
Ali Reza is thinking it's a clear sign
that Lim lay is in charge of this game
Dania I think the Vietnamese super GM is
about to go to four to four
if you can find a couple more accurate
moves and he is doing just that jumping
into D6 there's also Rook C to d8 which
we haven't given as much coverage maybe
the path forward is to hit that Knight
how do you win B5 though is there some
sort of Knight D4 no then Queen takes D4
picks up the Knight and defends its
vis-a-vis on D6 I agree four minutes up
on the clock position is dire what do
you see yeah I see a move because it's
dire Rook d8 if B5 I'm sacking on D6 you
take on D6 I take on B5 and I say okay I
have a pawn and a knight for The Rook
black is in trouble right you see the
Evo bar it's all the way up but I see
some threats here I'm a stable at least
for the moment with my knight protected
uh over on C6
black is lost we know that or maybe it's
the best chance that you have
yeah when you're losing you want to
confront your opponent with some
Newfound problems here like Huang He
knows what he's doing he's gonna play B5
you want to sort of change the nature of
the position even if it's not
objectively the best option but with two
minutes on the clock the Restless clock
is dwindling his position
is very very unenviable here
does he even have another move says Rook
is under attack yeah
I think so I truly think the answer is
yes he's also down five minutes on the
clock and
oh E5
is there Knight E5 to G4 hitting F2
I was wondering how big a threat that is
because even if Queen takes F2 the king
could slide over to H1 but it's getting
really messy so we'll see Lemonade plays
B5 Knight G4 how is he gonna respond
yeah it is getting pretty Lionel there
over on the king side
BC Queen takes F2 King H1 there's 93 and
that's a big deal because if you have to
move your Rook away remember that The
Rook is defending the Knight so Rook G1
still not the end of the story by the
way Robert Rook takes D6 there's C takes
B7 that pawn is nothing to sneeze at
either but this is precisely what like
Huang wants to avoid against someone as
tactically gifted as alireza yeah the
engine says white is winning here but it
doesn't look that clear there could be a
smothered Checkmate on F2 if the Knight
replaces the queen Knight takes G2 at
some moment could be very threatening
opening up the light Square diagonal
that the white king is sitting on so
this is a very lamb lay move he plays E3
and says sorry I don't need to win a
full night to take this game if you move
your knight well where are you gonna
move it to Knight E5 comes to mind as an
option here but even after Knight E5 I
could see an argument for look at this
queen D4 strategic chess let's trade
Queens B7 is hanging I think that he's
just going to crush him in the end game
because let's say you don't lose a pawn
Rook C1 Rook C7 type ideas I'm sure
there are plenty of other tactics in the
position
white is just clearly the side for
choice
there's three enemies that alirez's door
the first is the clock he's now down
five minutes with only a minute to
defend this miserable position the
second is the state of his Knights
Robert the Knight have no purchase in
the center they're constantly Under Fire
and the third enemy is the B7 pawn and
his Queen side in general the Queens get
traded alireza won't have anything left
to defend the queen side with so I love
Queen D4 uh it's always hard to trade
into an end game when your opponent's in
time pressure you get the temptation to
keep the Queens on the board maybe
they'll blunder but that's not how these
2700s think they are scientists they try
to find the best move that was a great
call by you love Queen D4 I've just seen
enough of his games where he just says I
don't need to crush you by checkmating
you I'm just going to beat you in some a
better end game and here I'm not sure
what the better move is Rook D1 to
double Rook C wants to go the open file
um black may try Rook D7 as a way to
defend but you actually plunder in that
case like Rook C1 Rook D7 there's
tactics with his Rook being loose on D7
the Knight jumps oh go to F5 I'm going
to C8 yeah let's do it we have a rook
stare down if you take the Knight with
this Rook I'm not gonna take the D7
Brooke because this is check I'm going
to take here first and then I'm gonna
take your Rook for free thank you very
much I win the game and if you take the
Rook on D4 Knight 67 is an Intermezzo
with check and I win your rook and I win
a piece so this looks just very very
promising for white no matter what but
he slides the double
a slightly different approach Rook takes
G4 is now a threat that's very easy to
forget about by the way a move like Rook
D7 would be a common time pressure
blunder instead alireza has to move the
Knight out of G4 where will he move at
Knight F5 is still very much a threat
but then the Rook from d8 could slide to
E8 so I think I think Ali wrestle is
holding it together for now but he's
down to 30 seconds and a move like E4
keeps tightening the screws in the
center you could transition one of the
Rooks to the C file but I'll uh like one
is playing exclusively in the center
right now black Snipes get more and more
cramped with each passing move I mean
just the Quiet Moves those are always
The Killers E5 is Rook inside of A4 at
some moment the bishop on G2 means that
that Rook can't get over to A8 Knight G6
to stop it I think F4 would be what most
of us would do but then E5 happens and
there's tension between the pawns and we
can maybe establish an E5
I love what is doing he is playing this
patiently he's not just rushing in
alirez's time travel
yeah white has so many incremental
improvements that he can make from A4 to
a move like H4 you can expand on both
sides of the board but we've seen all
the rest of pull these kinds of games
out so White's gonna have to stay very
patient and pounce whenever he gets a
tactical opportunity but Robert alirez
is actually making strides here he's
improving his own position and once the
Knight is tossed away from D6 wait a
second The Rook on D4 is incredibly
vulnerable
so he goes Rook to C7 over here okay I
guess the white King was just stepping
up into the position
I feel like black is doing okay on the
board but what do you make of the clock
Donna you know how good otherwise is a
bullet but 20 seconds to nearly four
minutes that seems like too much to bear
white has to find a way to keep the
tension maybe you do that by trading off
a pair of Brooks Rook D4 to C4 leaves
black with only one Rook to defend all
of the infiltration squares instead by
going kind of treading water and
defending the second rank but alireza
keeps getting his pieces into the game
his position is better than it's been in
the last 20 moves I agree but I like
Knight F5 because the Rook takes him
before the Knight jumps back and you
would love to get this Knight to C6 this
night we're on C6 last in huge trouble
Syrian A7 protecting this E5 push there
it is here it comes
you're on a roll maybe it was worth for
alireza to move the Rook back to f8 now
the Knight is going to jump into C6
unless black stops him and 97 doesn't
actually prevent Knight C6 because of
the backrank May problem
wow he was Rook C4
how could that possibly work six
yes it does so he goes H5 and if E5
where's this Knight going up to G4
perhaps it has to it hits C5 and hits H2
but white can go after Black's Queen
side he just has to choose the right
time to do it
if you take on A7 Knight takes E4 it
happens and now black restores material
equality I wonder if there's a way to be
a little bit tricky here because Knight
takes E4 there might be king D3 in some
positions so Rook d8 check and then King
D3 with a fork of The Rook of the Knight
then black would probably slide to A4
and things do get complicated if Black's
Knights get active the situation becomes
a lot more complex and two-sided than it
has been thus far no question Robert
however the game ends that olly Reza's
defense here has been incredible
yes and by the way we do have Lavon
aronian gukesh and nodirbeck yakubayev
the other no dear back the strong strong
Uzbek board two at the Olympia but H3
look at this calm move Rook A4 oh and
apparently that's a mistake he took away
the G4 Square now it's time for Palm
push to E5 maybe the Knight goes into E4
but this feels like you're treading on
water here the white needs to watch over
Rook takes A2 as well but alireza has
been walking on hot coals for the last
15 moves and he continues to make
strikes his pieces are as active as
they've been maybe you snap that Knight
off the board Bishop takes C4 as painful
as it is to give up your Catalan Bishop
maybe now's the time you're indicating
King D3 no question that white is
playing for two results in that
resulting position if you leave the
Knight alive Robert it's so easy to
blunder something with white knight C3
check and Knight takes B5 is a major
problem if you infiltrate the seventh
rank good call by La Quang no I mean
he's just playing great chess right now
what is black gonna do here maybe H4
maybe to throw this Pawn off the board
try to create some weaknesses on the
third rank he plays A6 apparently that
was a huge blunder
can be 14 B5 is it that simple that's it
oh my goodness it is
look at the Knight on B5 compared to the
Knight on G6 it just dominates the
knight from far away and look at that
move A4 The Rook want to come to a300
King B5 he's rook d8 and qv5 it's over
beautiful you trap The Rook Exquisite
surgical scientific Precision by Lim how
do you how do these people do this
yeah please take me on E5 because Rook
A5 takes E5 and that may not even do the
job because the outside pass Pawn but
you take you move your Rook to E8 and
after The Rook moves over you take B6
that is a win for lamb land that's not
just any win that was a master class in
technique that was superb play from the
Vietnamese super Grand Master
it wasn't perfect objectively but man oh
man was he was like a Craftsman a
surgeon really sinking his teeth into
each weak square and finding the fastest
path to Victory knocking out alireza
faruja is like Huang Lim and otterbeck
trying to knock out carrilla like senko
both of these players still on perfect
scores how much stuff does white have
for the queen Geez Louise
uh two Rooks and one Queen Bishop and
now what queen exactly and this official
can always come back to stop this Pawn
for promoting that will be game over and
I mentioned we're gonna see abusive take
take and you're gonna win everything so
he does this takes number five after
King H6 there's probably Bishop G6 and
Bishop E7
oh look at you with your puzzle Rush
tactics I'm gonna show that quickly here
and that's mate no that's that's way
cooler because you don't even need the
Rook to deliver this kind of mate
although the queen can intercept let's
Checkmate on the next move so that was a
sick finish there Dania we just have a
couple games uh remaining in this round
and he's Geary being one of them whoa
okay
four seconds though
you can't stop the d-pawn if you move
blackstroke off of the eighth rank
beautiful
that's actually sick I'm like this Rook
is hanging what's going on but now
rookie seven was a good move he goes
Rook to Ian okay that's just simple bam
in E5
that's it Knight C7 Queen takes C7 is
going to end it and Antonio
what's his Cane down
and Anish giri up to three out of four
yeah that's a big win you need to hover
near the leaders because sometimes it
comes down to tie breaks right where you
make you know a huge tie and krumnik uh
what is happening here he is the black
pieces point one
oh
oh my gosh check King takes C4 Queen B4
B4 queen or no he trades Queens but the
pawn is it is it stoppable it isn't it
E6 E6
why is why was this the wrong move
though Bishop here
oh we missed it E6 was winning for white
how can you not push that pawn
I don't know but he's gonna stop this
one maybe he just was trying to ensure
he makes a draw but you can't just think
about the Half Point the full point was
in reach apparently but this is a
theoretical draw so let's go back to
that moment so you're saying E6 would
have won the game there and they agreed
to a draw so I'm using E6 I'm because E6
prevents black from promoting because
the e-pawn pushes through black can play
HR but then simply F6 and that actually
is the reason you're showing this line
the reason the bishop was better on G5
was because it prevents F6 here white
plays F6 and E7 and he comes or no
apparently that's not the move
King B3 okay simple simple yeah but no
but I see your point that with the
bishop over here on G5 it's very far
away from this King and it would have
kept the equality except for E6 no
you're not going to do C1 we just saw
what that loses but maybe there's a move
to throw in here I'm gonna cheat turn
the engine oh this is impossible yeah
that's impossible man
yeah
okay couple games still remaining though
you've put up way e who's struggling to
hold against Terry a nightmare opponent
but he forces the draw and we've got one
final game oh no where have I seen this
before no way where's gotta where's
gotta komsky
are these scores accurate this is how
strong the event is krikor mechatarian
has zero out of three thus far that is
unheard of that tells you all that you
need to know will we see a draw here or
will white blunder in a similar way and
you can see black kind of doing the same
thing that gotta did he just shuffle
your pieces and shuffle your pieces and
with five seconds left it's so common
that white makes one wrong pre-move
Bishop G8 here is exactly how I
blundered in the godakonski game
yeah no you just don't make a blunder
here this one is going to be a draw a
minute left here for Indian p and well
he's just gonna try to get crick or to
make that same mistake but I don't think
he will so uh Dania what do you say
should we stick this one out do you
think that crick or is going to be able
to hold it
I think he's gonna hold it he's keeping
over five seconds on his clock that
gives him enough time
or no oh he could have won The Rook if
roku's right there he could have just
won it on the spot
and he's gonna be kicking himself if he
ends up blundering but I don't think he
is he's defending this very very
confidently just don't go Bishop H7 here
and blunder into Checkmate I've seen
that before as well do we have another
game
uh well we apparently do
oh my goodness
we have Jordan Von Forest against Dennis
makinov and Diana and it's an extra Pawn
apparently that was a move that allows
black to win this makes sense even
outside pass Pawn King can go up the
board and everything is protected
White's epon is way way too far back
to make any pawn end games possible
we're gonna see a pawn end game and it's
like a Ferrari against a Ford
wow I was not expecting a car reference
it didn't matter if the phone was
stopped so that means Jordan red Forest
moves to two and a half out of four
that's good for the Dutchman but he'll
still have a lot of work to do to get
towards the top eight
okay so this game's over let's see if
crecourse opponent in Eon is still
trying to torture out a win in that end
game he is it's still going
it's going pretty going and he's made
zero progress he's just blundered his
rook and Creek a big big hold here he is
on the board as is his opponent with
half a point out of four as you said
Robert it's not because krikor is a bad
player God forbid he's a beast it's just
this is how brutal this event is
yeah super strong event the players are
four of nine rounds into the Swiss we
will get matches after that but like the
players Donnie and I are going to take a
short break because when we return it's
more from the chessful Masters playing
right here on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
what should I do
it's time to take control of your
journey towards chess Mastery Magnus
Carlson introduces chessable the
definitive solution for studying chess
move trainer uses the science of spaced
repetition to identify your strengths
and eliminate your weaknesses there's no
need to set up a board remember which
page you're on or keep track of all the
moves you miss get started now and join
our growing community of over one
hundred thousand chess enthusiasts
chessable take control of your journey
towards chess mastery
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
be your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
foreign
place a brick wall and a pensive
expression on the face of Grandmaster
Lavon aronian what more do you need well
of honoronian is one of many super Grand
Masters who are participating in the
chessable Masters we're watching The
Swiss stage here is a couple of notable
amateurs Robert who have decided to
participate
yeah you know a good old Pro-Am just
kidding all these players are concert
professionals they're fantastic players
uh some more experienced than others you
see a mix of teenagers along with the
veterans and you'll see Juan June the
Women's World Champion taking part in
fact some of the best female players in
the world are participating in the
Champions chess tour plan so that's
great to see uh great to see so many
familiar faces so many strong players in
the field and levonne aronian now 40
years old now a father still over 2 700
well over that he won the WR Chess
Masters in Germany recently he's uh
trying to get back to the form that we
know he's capable of and we've seen so
many times in so many years in the past
indeed we have in that tournament
victory has given him the confidence
that I think to overcome uh the plateau
the slump that he has found himself in
ever since the last U.S Championship no
question the lawn is going to get back
out of it and make his way toward 27.50
well we are going to make our way toward
round five
round five of his underway as the
players try to make one of the 72
qualifying spots and we have only two
perfect scores it's Lim against the
chess Warrior Robert not Rebecca
abdusatorov the biggest game of the
tournament thus far
yeah and we have just these two but that
doesn't mean they're gonna make quick
draws sometimes the end of a tournament
you're like okay if we draw we share
first and second place let's do that
it's still too early to make that draw
and we see you Urban Joey you'll be back
well he never left he's here to stay
that is
and his Queen stays in line with the
bishop if this Knight moves from B1 done
it we may see Bishop A3 at some point I
think it's too early to do that because
black is underdeveloped but sometimes
you do that to gain control of the dark
squares well nurderberg continues to
Blitz out his moves otherwise I would
say that E5 Robert is incredibly
committed it is committal but clearly
it's part of his preparation he is
potentially trying to shove that pawn
down to E4 the issue is that if you do
it too early white will capture on F6
and remove the defender of that pawn so
E4 is not possible and it's a committal
move because you're weakening a lot of
the light squares around the pawn right
D5 and F5 imagine white sticking a
knight on F5 things could get unpleasant
so Notre back is gonna have to
compensate by playing actively and
quickly getting his Bishop out and
putting his Rook on C8 to harass that
Queen
but he's played this opening before I
believe he used it against Wesley so and
Nish Geary and those super GMS and Tata
steel and classical chess he's a very
well prepared player he also often
dresses sharply even when he's playing
remotely you'll see him in a dress shirt
so he is a professional despite the fact
that he is just a teenager I mean he is
just so impressive at such a young age
but I'm with you man I'm looking at this
position Knight C4 just comes very
naturally to my eyes if this bishop
moves away from D6 maybe I'll put my
Bishop on A3 at the right moment maybe
I'll play the calm move H3 to kick this
bishop out the way I just like these
positions from the white side and I'm
looking at the player with the white
pieces it's Lim lay and he just crushed
Oliver is a farooza from that end game
I'm liking to start this one for him in
this game as well and I think he gets a
double white he was just White against
Ali Reza now he's white against
thunderbeck he's not coming here to make
a quick draw with the white pieces he
wants to get onto five out of five that
is going to give him a bigger cushion
especially uh given the fact that he
might get double black so he wants to
exploit every opportunity with the white
pieces you called it Robert Bishop to A3
the bishop could sink its teeth to D6
making matters even nastier for black in
the center Queen E8 Bishop D6 or even
Knight D6 trying to secure the bishop
pair lots of options here for limb but
Notre back he's holding things together
and if you play Bishop D6 too early
Robert I think black could simply take
and Slide the queen back up to E7 also
don't fall asleep on the possibility of
E5 to E4 which is now a distinct
possibility that White's Bishop has left
the long diagonal
absolutely that could be very dangerous
for white to deal with and we saw what
Lem can do with a knight on D6 here it
will not have a night staying there but
a game ago use it to great effect so
while uh he is thinking right now why
don't we go to that game between
artemiev and Lavon of ronian because we
had Lavon on camera we were talking
about how he had a down year in 2022 on
the chessboard but he started 2023 off
on the right foot he won a tournament in
Germany a super Grand Master around
Robin now with the black pieces in this
game Dunya he has the isolated Queen
Pawn but he also has quick activity when
you have an I said Pawn inherent to that
you've opened files give me his open E5
for Rook I'll move my Bishop out get the
open C file for the other rook and the
bishop on D6 stares to where the white
king is likely to go
that was a great breakdown I would only
add that the queen on D4 may look
menacing but it's not a good blockader
and there you see why it's very easy to
kick away that's precisely what Lavon
aronian does and a big decision by
bladislav he can stay on the fourth Rank
and play Queen H4 but with white
uncastled that seems to speculative
artemia playing in his style he's solid
and now the ball back in levon's court
where is he going to bring out is light
squared Bishop Bishop E6 is the most
obvious move and it is a little bit
passive but I still think Robert Bishop
E6 and Rook C8 with blacks pieces as
active as they are I don't think that
Lavon is experiencing any serious
problems here with equalizing yeah and
also this Pawn D5 is actually not
hanging in many positions because the
bishop on B2 is loose so just to show
what that looks like Bishop F5 if you
take on D5 you're going to see the Evo
bar yep very low because your Bishop
takes B2 if you take an F6 with check
Intermezzo the bishop or the queen can
take because they'll be in contact with
one another and if you take on uh B2 you
simply lose this Knight on D5 and the
bishop will be able to defend it you
can't push this Pawn to E4 black would
be a piece ahead so that would not be a
good decision for uh white but Bishop E6
Lavon says why get fancy I'm just gonna
defend this pawn another time I have all
my pieces there Rook C8 on the next turn
I feel like no opening issues for Lavon
aronian absolutely not uh his tremendous
piece activity compensates for uh the
weakness and I'll put that in air codes
because the isolated Pawn is defended
three different ways it's actually not
as much of a weakness as it appears and
the last thing I'll say Robert uh before
we can continue going around the horn is
that Knight to B5 which is a sort of
standard positional move trying to
circle the Knight background to D4 runs
into Knight F6 to E4 and I would say
that Knight E4 is a very important
resource or black you could even play
this move on his own volition in certain
situations but with Rook C8 and queen A5
on the horizon as well I might even go
as far as to say that I prefer black
here by a little bit I do too and I
think I know why you like the aggressive
intentions if this King ever castles you
have to watch out for this H2 Pawn uh
black has the activity and so yeah this
is a position where black has no issues
and is three minutes ahead in the clock
he wasn't even looking at that but Lavon
he's in great form in this event so
let's leave artemiev and Lavon as this
remains quite solid for now uh why don't
we go to den less and our generic icy
because teenagers they're near the top
of the standings done yet they will have
a good chance just like the rest of
these top gems and what do we have here
Dan Laz is a beast and he's showing that
in this game black is castled Queen side
why does castled Queen side but white is
the only one having fun on the queen
side
what is happening here I mean there's a
knight on D5 that's the only thing in
Black's favor right now is the presence
of that monster Knight but what is the
Knight really doing and is black capable
of dealing with the pressure down the C
file
that's an essential question by the way
I think you know Knight D6 check looks
scary to a lot of people oh I'm going to
give a check I'm going to win this Pawn
for the Rooks but you know that pre-move
Rook takes D6 would happen after Pawn
takes back Queen takes D6 black is much
better because the Rook wasn't doing
anything on d8 the Knight and the pawn
that now that they're gone Black's
pieces are freed up and structurally
it's too damaged for white to have a
good shot here so instead we saw take on
a four and queen A3 but that move not
approved of by the engine and I could
see why Dania the Knight on H5 hops into
F4 these Knights just controlling the
dark squares and D5 the bishop on the F1
has no useful diagonal and I think
Dennis he understood that Knight D6 will
be met with an exchange jacket price
what he might have underestimated is
that after A6 Knight D6 check looks like
the perfect time to cash in your chips
because after Rook takes D6 he takes D6
Robert you can't win the D6 Pawn
immediately but you could actually bring
your king up in that position position
to D7 I think this is happening on the
board we're going to see this line
unfold King D7 is next and the D6 spawn
is encircled you're gonna take it with
the queen and just like in the previous
instance of this sacrifice those Knights
are absolute monsters whites attack has
fizzled out and Dennis has cashed in his
chips too early
yeah no this is just the caitly kick on
D7 we typically don't like our Kings out
in the open in the center but this is
not open it's a closed position and
that's where the knights are thriving
here and what open files you go Rook G1
I shut down that file immediately yeah
there's nothing going on for white and
black will get this pawn and let's just
go into a queenless position as well you
don't have to necessarily trade Queens
so quickly for Black but even when we
get here you take on D5 I take back
ugly pawns no open files whatsoever a
very strong base pawns for black nothing
to attack this is great for our generic
icy as he plays King to D7
and he hasn't just equalized or solves
his problems white is the only one with
problems that end game Robert is
squarely worse or black there's no way
that Arjun takes a draw in a position
like this black is basically a blank
check here he can do whatever the heck
he wants and he doesn't have a single
Target this is tremendous understanding
by Arjun aragaisy these things that we
take for granted that's what makes the
super GM stick the realization that you
sack and exchange and bring your king
out in the middle game and somehow
you're better yeah welcome to Arjun era
guys's world
yeah that's a great world if you're a
chess fan especially a fan of from India
because Argentina guys he signed a 1.5
million dollar deal with Quant box great
to see sponsorship or chess players he's
with team mgd1 in the Pro chess League
uh they've helped represent him as our
generic geissi familiar face to the
Chess World he did qualify for division
one in the air things Masters he would
like to make it two four two so but
Daniel why don't we go back to our top
boards we haven't tuned in there in a
while and a lot has in fact changed on
the first one between limlay and no
deerback Abdus atarov and as we sit here
the material is even but I see a bishop
for white I see a pair of knights for
black I also see a knight on F5 and
should I call it a knife or is it still
just a knight
well it's more of a night than a knife
after Rook D5 it would be a knife if it
was supported let's say by another
Knight on G3 so Rook D5 poses white with
a dilemma you could drop the Knight back
to G3 and I still think white slightly
better the bishop on E3 Robert it should
be pointed out can slide back to B2 and
create tremendous problems for black on
the long diagonal Bishop takes F6 is
going to be a problem now black southern
Knight could come to the rescue with
Knight C6 to E5 but there's essential
sense in which black just doesn't have
any purchase in the center none of his
pieces are defended by pawns do you see
what I'm saying it's a little bit flimsy
so if anybody is likely to blunder it's
definitely Notre back but maybe once you
push the Knight out of F5 black and
stabilize with careful play
but I'm having nightmares and actually
that was not meant to be a pun but
you're gonna appreciate that anyway if
these Queens come off the board
if these Rooks come off the board then
I'm worried that this bishop can attack
anything the bishop can be useful for a
checkmating attack in this position but
if the major Pieces come off then the
knights will just venture to the light
squares and the bishop is helpless to do
much of anything so that's the future
I'm envisioning and if a queen comes to
D7 and there's a threat of Rook D2 and
some pieces have to come off the board I
feel like white does Need To Tread
carefully
yeah there's no question in my mind that
Notre back has made serious strides
compared to the position out of the
opening which we thought was clearly
better for White Queen D7 I humbly move
connecting the heavy pieces preparing to
infiltrate to D2 instead he's working on
some King side infiltration trying to
send this Knight to Timbuk2 on H1 that's
a serious positional threat I think it
forces White's hand maybe bishop B2
should be considered and maybe you don't
mind bringing your knight back to H1 but
psychologically Robert that is a really
hard thing to make yourself do I would I
would say Rook C1 I think is a likelier
move to at least give the Knight an exit
route via F1
well we can analyze for a second here
this could it goes Rook D1 I was going
to say it could have been a birthday
gift happy birthday to Lim lay but after
Bishop B2 you're threatening to take on
F6 and win this H5 pawn and if you go H4
Bishop F6 if you take here my knight
gets to H5 and you have a bad Pawn
structure and you take on G3
um Queen Chief how is this not just
amazing for white how is this only like
slightly better
I missed Queen G4 that's why I
discounted Bishop B2 and perhaps Lim
took the same path here white is
basically winning it's only 0.5 that's
crazy
I don't know that's crazy
you called it Robert they're trading
some pieces and with every piece that's
traded the power of White's Bishop as
you indicated is already quite a bit
diminished
yeah but I think he might take on F6 for
that reason because H takes I always
thought I'd checkmated myself but
thankfully just to show this here there
is no Checkmate because the queen can't
get to D1 with mate as the queen on G4
covers it I was suggesting white gopher
Checkmate then I was like horrified the
white king can't escape but then I
recognized that the queen is a great
piece on G4 attacking and defending but
speaking of Checkmate G6 runs into Queen
C8 so black would have to initiate
Perpetual check by taking on F2 and
luckily for him the queen is able to
pursue the white king to the edge of the
Earth because if the king hides on H2
there's a fork on D6 and I think we're
gonna see just that King G1 actually you
would have to be careful there with
black queen D1 boners the queen but
Queen takes E3 and queen H6 is the
Saving Grace that's what Notre back has
to see if he goes for this line and
guess what he is gone for this line
yeah he'll see it I mean that took a lot
of foresight I was worried uh for black
there I mean King F1 by the way there is
the check on D3 so we'll get the same
position so Queen D2 check and take Pawn
Yeah we're a good team there I feel like
King F1 might just be the simplest
solution and he's gonna go for it I
think we're gonna see this draw
and notibeck offers a draw like one uh
lim declines it but I just think he
didn't see the draw for that happens
sometimes yeah especially if you're in
Focus mode sometimes you're just like
really locked in on the screen of your
game but this will be a draw black has
no better than to repeat and look at how
quickly Lim's playing you know he's
ready for the draw it is agreed we have
both players moving to four and a half
out of five no more perfect scores but
let's go down to two maybe back to the
den Laz game against Arjun because that
one was full of life sorry I didn't
refresh the board we are now into an end
game suddenly where how in the world
does white just have two on a post
passers on the queen side while black
will hope pray maybe to get the pawns
going on the king side but they look
really slow
if I had to give an intuitive evaluation
I would say that white is winning A4 A5
A6 the red carpet is unrolled for the
pawn and we know how bad Knights are at
multitasking and handling past pawns
Rook to D5 trying to get the Rooks off
the board
and does white trade or does white keep
the Rooks on the board with a check on
C8
he trades and that was a mistake eval
bar dropped down how is that a mistake
it should have given too close to White
spawns I think that could be part of the
problem yeah and you know we actually
have to note that a few moves ago in
this position look at the King on E8
over here at this point white played the
move
Queen takes A6 and after King F Queen
takes D4 here Rook takes C6 that's how
we got to this position so it was an
extra exchange we saw that happen
earlier on white gave the exchange back
and then took all the queen side pawns
and that's how we eventually got this
ending but Anya the decision to trade
Rooks there it's clearly backfiring we
see the engine suggesting that black is
perfectly fine here as the king is way
too close
I think Dennis in his mind just forgot
that Black's King can be an actant in
stopping the progress of White's pawns
and it's not like you could just close
your eyes and twist your pawns the
Knight on D5 is really As Good As It
Gets if white plays B4 then you're not
going to be able to play A4 if you play
A4 then you create dark Square
weaknesses that black could use to set
up a blockade and I know this sounds
absolutely crazy off the wall but if
white is not careful Black's pawns
aren't just gonna sit idly by Archen is
making progress on the queen side maybe
it's time for Dennis kingside that is
maybe it's time for Dennis to accept the
inevitable and secure half a point
yes sometimes you just need to get the
result in the books before it's too late
and here H4 G4 you're right Donna this
is actually kind of scary just to show
something that if you take on D5 here
now black has split Pawns in Bowling you
never want to split in the end game
finally Eva bar catching up with us mere
mortals that the king cannot stop the
g-pawn as it pushes and the Depot at the
same time whereas when this King sits on
B7 it's just in front of both of White's
Pawn so I'm with you I'm I'm looking at
this end game the trajectory of the game
is in arjun's favor and if he's playing
a different game Connect Four he's
already won
it's crazy how a certain move can follow
chess principles to a T and yet not be
in the spirit of the position that
decision to trade Rooks white should
have kept the Rooks on the board that
would have helped him push response more
efficiently what's crazy is that he
hasn't even pushed respawns one square
the pawns have been on A3 and B4 forever
black is the only one who's making
progress and I think Bishop takes D5
here should be seriously considered but
might still be losing because black
could get those split pawns uh
essentially on demand Dennis drops his
King back here goes G4 arjun's
definitely playing for a win at this
point yeah and he may have the quicker
pawns because the black king is so close
in the center if you push the B5 then
you have the king coming to C5 as you
mentioned earlier given control of the
dark Square so G4 feels pretty strong
for black let's just take a little look
at another game just because well this
one is the end game we will definitely
come back to it we were looking at
artemiev and Levon of ronin earlier as
G4 has been played don't worry we'll
keep an eye I just want to check in here
it looks like artemia with a life
Advantage Dania into the end game
healthier Pawn structure two Pawn
Islands or white compared to three
because it's isolated Pawn here on D5
white is better with the blockade
no question the queen trade has been to
Black's detriments because now you're
saddled with the weakness of D5 and that
weakness isn't going anywhere white has
full control of the square in front of
the pawn the nominal positional played
by vladislavartame and he can torture
this one for as long as he wants but
with a minute on his clock to levon's
two I would assign a higher likelihood
of this game ending in a draw it's one
of the things that levonne ruin is best
at is putting pressure on his opponents
on the clock and then they often believe
him I've actually had conversations with
the best players in the world where
they're like LaVon just really good at
making you believe that he knows what
he's doing and that sounds hilarious
because he often does know what he's
doing but in certain openings he may not
actually be that familiar with it but
the speed with which he plays makes
people believe that he is within his
preparation but look at this Rook C3
preparing to take back onto the night
going after this Pawn on D5 or venturing
up to B5 and going after these loose
Queen side Pawns of your Donya white is
clearly significantly better
this is a very nasty ultimatum that
vladislavartamyu just posed to live on
either trade Rooks and make the past the
isolated Pawn even weaker give my knight
the C3 square or move your Rook away and
give me the only open file I always say
it when there's only one open file you
want to be the side that's controlling
it the E3 Pawn is a weakness that black
could latch onto but it could be
protected by the D Rook as well which
you could slide up to D3 and then the
other Rook is ready to infiltrate the
seventh rank
and aronia's time Advantage is getting
wiped out by this decision that he has
to make
this position looks terrible for black
right if you were yes game you think
it's just easy for white to play there's
a Target the C file will be yours if the
Rook doesn't trade if you do trade the
Knight is hopping around uh just
bothering you and you can't move out of
these pieces because with the knight at
C3 D5 needs all the defense it can get
yeah Black's King is very far away from
the pawn you want the King on E7 Levon
fiancheted his King that might have been
uh a uh potential source of Black's big
problems here if the King was on D6 here
at least you'd be able to use the Rooks
to contest the C file now Lavon is down
on the clock vladislava tamif has a
great chance to move to four and a half
out of five what a monster score that
would be
and Levant hasn't moved right he is down
to about 30 seconds he's for change
below his opponent on the clock and down
to Thursday he goes rookie eight you're
suggesting and look at how quickly
artemium goes in with the Knight he can
bring his Knight to C6 or B5 or simply
slide The Rook from D2 over to C2
because at some point this Rook wants to
get to C7
that's the thing there's no price tag
attached to any of White's moves you
could just torture this and milk this as
long as you want eventually though
White's gonna have to make something
concrete happen I would think our Tammy
will push his pawns up on the queen side
and clamp down even further this is a
nasty defensive task which awaits Lavon
aronian and I quickly want to switch to
another game I know Lavon down here 20
seconds but the end game we were looking
at before between Den less and our
generic guys look at this position
somehow the Evo Bar says it's equal
black did just steal a pawn over on A3
and what happens can black just simply
gobble up this Pawn I guess the answer
is no because the white king will start
calling after black spawns and then
you're gonna get them all
yeah and there might not be anything
better for Arjun aragaisi he actually
has to be just as wee bit careful if you
go down that line you do not want to
lose the H and G pawns because White's
going to be left with a corner Pawn it's
the wrong color Pawn as one Robert Hess
would point out so Arjun not gonna have
any problems King D4 could be met with
Knight B5 check some forking ideas there
so Dennis first dominates the Knight now
goes after Black's pawn and this is
certain to end in a draw and it's a very
hard fought draw indeed very clever you
know these Forks on C3 Knights are
tricky pieces especially he goes for it
what's that video someone's coming for
maybe the H2 Pawn Yeah the bishop the H2
pawn something but Bishop E8 should be
sufficient though Lex pawns go quite
quickly so H4 King takes oh it's
actually pretty close oh my gosh Knight
D2 check and then G3 and H3 and White's
Bishop doesn't have the C6 Square so
just a couple more accurate moves
required for lazovic yeah but now with
the King coming to C5 I think he's a
king F4 G3 you take oh he he makes the
truck doesn't want to test his hand
let's go back to artemiev and uh
our time you've blundered the H1 and he
hasn't been able to win the d-pawn this
is a flat out time scramble it's still a
three years old game yeah it is because
the clock but right now black is up a
pawn and maybe there'll be outside Cash
Pawn potential what in the world how did
this happen Levon is up a healthy Pawn
now
yell though actually how healthy is it
after King G4 never mind
[Laughter]
he pushed his pawns prematurely our
temmiev breaks apart his punching Lavon
says no I'm keeping my Pawn chain intact
one second oh Champion barely gets the
move off
a34 is it like Mutual zuk Swang here of
some sort but 97 check not possible
black snide on C6 dominating its
counterpart
okay okay but white going out 26. Lavon
wants to give up this Pawn go Knight C2
take this Pawn over here
mm-hmm but the Knight gets back towards
the side of the board and that should be
sufficient and black snide is too far
away we're going to get Mutual
liquidation and a draw still a great
result for levona Ronin I would go
Knight F3 there because now King F5
requires a couple more accurate moves
that b-pawn is faster than the G Pawn
right the king sits in front of the
g-pawn but what artemi was going to do
eventually is bring his Knight back try
to sacrifice it for this Pawn uh but
yeah he has B1 under control his King
just retreat yeah there's no way to
deflect the Knight on D2 that's a common
idea but it's not possible here Knight
B3 is of course met with Knight to B1
and it's all over
King C2 does the job you can just take
the pawn and we are gonna see
usually assure destruction and a draw
wow I cannot believe Avon had an extra
Pawn for a moment it was a blunder let's
go to uh prognandez game because he is
playing against yakubayev so we have a
matchup of two very young and talented
players oh gosh we have an extra piece
for black
it really is that H6 spawn might be a
force for harm if you move the bishop
off of this diagonal and you have to
ah no Bishop the kid could escape to G6
so this should be a draw
but watch over Knight G3 Bishop G4 when
the Kings on H4 that's the technique
construction that's ridiculous then
you'll have to defend F5 okay check the
king is here there is no Bishop G4
because the bishop covers the square
Bishop G6 still trying get your King off
of H4 just run back to H3 but don't
blunder the bishop don't play King H3
now and walking oh it's still a draw
actually after King H3
I thought there was a stalemate there I
don't think there is but now black has
no Machinery with which to check White's
King
right you need to check
and then get your Bishop to G4 but you
can't get everything you want especially
with this H Pawn still alive and trying
to run up the board so they're gonna
move around for a long long time over
here uh trying to squeeze out of Victory
although now there's clearly none to
draw on the spot what was that about a
long time
um sometimes a second is an eternity for
some people
all right you wiggled your way out of
that one one more game white trying to
wiggle his way out of a queen down
position he's got something resembling a
fortress but Black's King is going to
make its way to E1 I actually had a very
similar position
81 it's winning
you see this like the evil bar going up
and down up and down
why
oh the knight's coming to G4 once the
Knight gets a G4 to draw oh because you
can't win F2
oh I didn't see it he doesn't see it
but apparently it's still okay because
there's Knight F3 and black loses if you
play King E1 oh my gosh
well this is evgeny August by the way
H4 Queen G6 and 95 is a is it easy
blunder to make by the way
95 just checking make a move Sasha
King H3 King's F2 you can't bundle that
pawn that's for sure it feels like black
is the one hanging by a thread White's
gonna flag oh the F2 Pawn no it's over
and now he Flex
yeah afghaniac arrest the veteran
Grandmaster from Sweden uh not as
familiar with the online time controls
and just the mouse speed not there so
shimanov gets an important win Shimona
defeated Magus Carlson in the Pro chess
league so having a very very good week
well Black's King it came up to F2 and
it told whites King hey you're under
aggressed
okay I will be under arrest if I make
any more of these puns that's for sure
it's Notre back against fedesev around
five already underway Robert don't even
take a breath round six that is around
six of nine and we have no more perfect
scores remaining
what what what you told me you told me
not to take a breath so I was just
saving the last one a breath yeah yeah
okay that's what you're following my
instructions it's okay I think me making
a fool out of myself is a breath of
fresh air for you so uh you know you can
make me the laughing stock but we have a
caracon here this position is I don't
know the answer the question in a future
chat why is it the best
some people's opinion subjective take
we'll see uh but F6 played trying to
break down this Pawn on E5 done it Ben
Feingold would be very mad right now
never play F6 do you like the early F
Pawn push from federal save
Finn in this line of the Caro because
black generally castles Queen side and
speaking of which he castles Queen side
here and now you also often see white
playing Bishop F4 to G3 or queen D1 to
D2 by defending the bishop you're
reinforcing the threat of e takes F6 and
you're basically forcing Black's hand in
many cases you're forcing black to take
on E5 and you're establishing a clamp
over the E5 Square so the battle raging
on pretty early over the center white
takes her the Deep on Robert to vacate
the D4 Square for his Knight but C5
beats him to the punch
that was shocking to me like I of the
captures I was even thinking about
Bishop takes E5 which yeah was not going
to be the best but taking with the pawn
here just allowing C5 look at black
establishing uh not even a hangy Pawn
structure because you have another Pawn
E6 but this is just great positioning
for Black's pieces the pawn E5 is
overextended in many positions we can
see G5 Bishop G7 Knight E7 and the
Knight to C or to G6 and E5 could just
be under attack too many times so I
really don't like this opening from
abusatar of I think ferrosev kind of
going under the radar it's like he does
so often his position is excellent here
and a kind of weird mental apps uh by
notorbeck in the form of D takes C5
might have just forgotten the black and
take the D4 Square under control right
now the B3 Knight is kind of the bane of
White's existence I think he needs to
move it back urgently and just run his
Queen side pawns up the board because
Vladimir is not going to wait he's
pushing his Pawn to G5 and all it takes
for black is two or three moves and
White's entire King side is shattered
the bishop on G3 is incredibly
vulnerable to H uh the the march of the
H Pawn Robert this is a miserable
position for black I don't know if
notreck has enough time to get the
engine started on the queen side
and look at this 97 first so instead of
pushing the pawn just yet he says let me
get my knight out I can go G5 next I
feel like G5 is Black's next move no
matter what white does in this position
and there are other ideas this bishop
can go to E4 and Knight to F5 it's a
very common idea in many caracon
variations so I'm loving the look of
this for Federal Savings at four and a
half out of five and he's not a big fish
man he's been a shark for years and he's
just kind of going after his younger
opponent and look at abusatara but he is
locked in to calculating this position I
think he knows his position is bad and I
think he knows he's to get things
started on the queen side so I can
almost guarantee that he's going to move
his Knight off of B3 he's just trying to
assess the damage on the king side he's
asking himself am I gonna get mated here
and first he takes some prophylactic
measures he moves his Rook over to E1
maybe he'll tuck his Bishop back on F1
trying to keep the E5 Pawn from
collapsing because if that pawn
collapses the whole position collapses
but the position might be collapsing
anyway it's better to save runs his Jeep
on up the board what an opening by
Vladimir how do you get a plus one
position against Notre back with black
out of the opening and that is
ridiculously impressive
sometimes you need a little help from
your friends and I think taking on E5 in
this way and look this is a bit of
desperation it's not a bad move you said
you need to get those pawns going on the
queen side D4 with the idea at some
point I'm trying to push the D3 it comes
into mind but maybe black doesn't even
need to react because the center is
under Black's control at least for the
time being what about a move Knight B6
because if you take on D5 black at some
point we'll shove the C Pawn but can
take on D5 with all the pieces you think
with this Knight you can take with the
Rook I don't know what would you do
would you play D4 keep it closed Knight
B6 I wouldn't play D4 because that also
affords white a nice blockading Square
on D3 after D4 I've been saying this for
the last couple of moves and I think
motorbike will move the Knight back to
C1 and then he can push the pawn up to
B4 and undermine Black's Pawn chain
Knight B6 is a very mature move because
yeah you allow white to open the C file
but after Knight B6 as you're indicating
that blockading square C takes D5 Knight
E takes D5 we'll keep Black's Bishop on
f8 it's now playing a very important
role it's guarding the pawn on C5 and
Rook C1 as menacing as it looks doesn't
create any threats let me tell you
Knight C3 or Knight F4 is going to
create a very Minor Threat on on White's
Queen
yeah the queen is trapped he picked your
I don't know if it's not a four Knight
C3 Knight B4 the queen is still in big
trouble over here so it's just you have
to block with your knight now you're
moving backwards and that is not good so
uh better save doing the right thing he
understands how big of a moment this is
you just can't take it for granted and
for abusator of he's trying his best to
stir up some counter play He Is ahead on
the clock now that's the good news and
if D4 happens he at least has a clear
plan to blockade and strike with B4
maybe fedasev is also considering D take
C4 but we'll leave him to his devices
he's got plenty of time on the clock and
we have plenty of games to look at we've
got Lim on board two against e1u not
sure who that is off the top of my head
I think it's is it Santos Ruiz no no
it's who is that Alonso Roselle oh okay
I've heard that name yeah no his uh
rapid rating on chess.com Sky High to
start the day so not a name that maybe a
lot of people are familiar with but
right now four out of five doing really
well in this event and now playing White
against Lim lay I have to say Dania I'm
never a fan of single Bishop 183 like
this and I just that's the first thing I
note maybe the only thing is the open C
file good for you what is this bishop
doing on E3 it's ugly but it's also
dysfunctional because you want the
possibility of opening up the center
black has weak pawns Robert on the king
side and in the center but you're not
going to exploit them with a move like
Queen to C6 because that creates exactly
zero threats the Knight on G7 fulfilling
a very important defensive role so maybe
it's time to swallow your pride and drop
the bishop back to D2 quickly go E4 but
even that is hard to achieve because
black will play B4 how's our night on B1
getting out of the gates there
it's not you're taking away it's
developing square if you put a bishop so
it goes out to C3 but you already see
the eval bar going down in Black's favor
why simple chess Rook C8 this Knight we
just saw Pharisee bring his Knight to B6
lamlay can do the same thing kick the
Knight away with B4 get into C4 at some
point what is this bishop doing it's
just a tall Pawn
Lim lay is cooking with some hot grease
in this tournament look at the
confidence with which he's playing 17
moves in he spent less than two minutes
his pieces and his position are
breathing right you just sense the power
that he has on both sides of the board
Queen B6 here makes a lot of sense he
would love to get the Knight over to C4
but white is actually threatening to
take the pawn on B5 and support the
Knight with A4 so it might be worth
attending to that and he does just that
before now threatens to win a piece
I feel like black Smooths are too easy
and every single move for white takes 20
seconds an A4 play that is a big
decision you could take it because the
queen on D3 is under attack and you
could even maybe give the pawn back on
A3 if you want not sure you want to do
that you can play B4 Knight B4 is
mandatory there and Dania it seems like
white gets to keep the material so I
would be taking on A4 keeping the
position a little more open I would be
taking as well not to win the pawn
you're going to lose that pawn back in
fact you could even sacrifice it back by
playing a well times A3 to soften
White's control over the C3 square and
that Knight gets very loose also you
just know that the G7 Knight is waiting
for its Moment In The Sun It's gonna
jump to F5 and that's going to create
even more pressure on White's position I
know this sounds like an exaggeration
but this already might be borderline
lost from a practical standpoint and
even objectively
I completely agree because the queen D1
down goes B2 and queen D2 Bishop comes
out to B4 pinning this Knight and as you
said this Knight it may be waiting in
the wings but it's going to fly to the
F5 Square hit the bishop put pressure on
this Pawn don't forget about G4 to kick
this Knight out of here White's pieces
stepping on each other's toes black is
currently up a pawn as well with great
coordination of pieces and it's just
problematic situation for white so now
with four minutes remaining to seven and
a half no no no no no no no
no no no
yes yes yes says Lim he will move to
five and a half out of six with a win in
this game that will put him very very
close to qualification to the top group
I see her hovering over arjun's game
with alireza farrugia and farouja has
gotten crushed in this tournament by Lim
but he's come back he has four points
out of six not a terrible score but he
needs to win some games
only and he's won the others so that's a
pretty good tournament because sometimes
we think a loss is devastating but it's
the same result had he drawn two of his
games instead of just lost one so he
goes here with Queen C6 with black
what's the material count it's actually
even but it's not a symmetrical Pawn
structure white has this backward Pawn
on C3 potential weakness
but black has this clear weakness on E6
as well and the other imbalance of
course is Knight versus Bishop It
generally favors uh the Knight when the
position is as closed as it is but my
question is what are the prospects for
the Knight on B3 Arjun has maneuvered it
from F3 I thought he was going to go the
other way Robert I thought he was going
to go to H4 and then perhaps to G6 and
maybe E5 but he's concentrating on the
queen side maybe he's just trying to
keep the black Bishop at Bay you cannot
afford to let this Knight sink its teeth
into C5
if this bishop were on D7 or any of the
light squares
yeah you just resign because the Knight
would have hopped to C5 hop to E5 just
go through all the dark scores Queen to
F4 but the bishop 26 a very very strong
piece it's keeping Black's entire
positioned together but Donna I don't
like the lack of coordination like The
Rook on A4 Side Track the queen on C4 is
a bit far away from the black king and
is G4 a possibility at some point for
white Rook over to E1 I feel like
there's about to be a lot of pressure
going against this Pawn E6 you took the
words right out of my mouth The Rook on
A4 is pressuring the A2 Pawn but that
pawn is safely defended by White's Rook
which is multitasking defending A2
attacking E6 and Borussia back pedals at
exactly the right time I think he had to
play that move and he has to continue
backpedaling that Queen on C4 looks
menacing it's not helping in the defense
of the E6 spawn you have to bring it
back instead he brings his Bishop
forward a rook from A6 a sixth ranked
defensive strategy but his hands are
literally tied he has to keep C5 control
and here comes Arjun with G4 no this is
really unpleasant for black because your
Bishop yeah I can go into B2 and try to
attack this but dania's Point Remains
the Same as soon as your Bishop leaves
this Knight is hopping into C5 and
that's gonna hit the Rook hit the E6
pawn and Black's Mission Falls where G4
is automatic here for our generic I see
that's step one and you would love to
pile up more pressure you undouble your
Pawns in the process I see the eval bar
if I didn't know that it was even I
would think that white was significantly
better
and I think what is significantly better
from a practical standpoint Robert the
drawback of putting the bishop on A3
we're only seeing that now if the bishop
was still on D6 black would be able to
keep the king side closed with F5 F4 as
it stands black has to allow the king
side to open up either by taking on G4
or I think Rouge is doing the right
thing he's trying to trade on his own
terms and get his other Rook to an
active defensive post on F5
and I might have to go back to F6
because this queen will slide back to E2
black is Holding On by a thread here
after Queen E2 E6 is loose and The Rook
on A6 is targeted by the queen on C8 and
doing all the work here covering all the
hanging squares so I think that for now
alireza has his bases covered but Donna
it looks like it could fall apart at any
moment
yeah it most certainly does we talked
about the principle of two weaknesses
maybe what Arjun needs is to create a
second weakness maybe to go after
Black's King but alirez's clock
continues to dwindle and White's winning
chances I think continue to increase
okay Rook F6 on the board and the
situation kind of stabilizes for the
time being
yeah oh this is good defense by other
reason we know he's a very active player
he's finding the right decisions to stay
in this game so why don't we hop away
from this one as the night hops into a
D2 let's go to the game between artemiev
and Maxime vasila Grove you would think
you see this matchup okay we're playing
uh for first place oh there four to five
still great performance but that's how
strong the field is at the top and oh my
goodness there's a lot too many pieces
here on Earth is happening here this is
almost a symmetrical position in a weird
kind of way the night box which you do
not see every day but you actually see
that night box happen in these cattle
well not Catalan but these Queen's
Gambit accepted type positions that's uh
the opening is that this game featured
like seem has his hands full right now
because there are big big threats down
the C file it's not an equal battle
between the white rook and the black
queen
I feel like I'm playing a game of
Twister like I just put the colors on
the board but like I'm a contortionist
out here trying to figure out how the
knights are gonna wrap around each other
because this Knight can go to B5 at some
moment this Knight might go to B4 right
now I can't figure out what other
players should do because there is a
stare down of Epic Proportions here with
the Bishops lined up against each other
and night before was just played oh my
goodness there are crazy tactics here
with Knight C4 takes A5 eliminating the
defender of the B4 Knight that has to be
calculated of course Bishop takes F3
Robert necessitates G takes F3 which is
not desirable or Tammy if tries to avoid
that loud I seem
to take on B7 with the Knight is that
seriously holding on
yes it is because this Knight on C4 has
no good squares to jump to the bishop
jumps to the defense of this Knight on
B4 in addition to this Pawn over here so
I feel like black has everything under
control after Knight takes B7 and the
fact that mvl's thinking here leads me
to believe he is likely to play it no
feeling Robert is is more sinking than
thinking your opponent has a forced move
and then making your move your opponent
starts to think you realize wait a
second his move isn't actually forced I
think our team you have subconsciously
assumed Queen B7 is for then Knight
takes A5 gets the best of all worlds
whites kingside is intact and he wins
the queen Side Pawn but after Knight
takes B7 we will likely get some sort of
liquidation I think there's a high
probability that a lot of pieces get
traded but with the clocks dwindling we
also have a high probability of a crazy
time scramble
prone to getting into them
I was going to mention the same we have
tan Zhang Yi taking up board 1967 was
played by mvl and look at this position
Alexander Bortnick
she two and a half out of five very good
performance for her uh undoubtedly
outrage excuse me in every game she's
played but this one she's down to piece
so we tuned in at the wrong moment she's
having a good tournament and we are
hitting over the commentator's curse we
are indeed and Bortnick with that extra
night on C6 black has a couple of Pawns
but the most important Pawn is the one
on C5 once the Knight leaves C6 you
don't want to do that immediately
because of Rook d8 check so perhaps if
you you can inch your king over to D6
and open up the D5 Square for The Rook
portnick instead tackles the king side
and freezes Black's pawns this one's
basically over
what's the material so black actually
has two pawns only two pawns for the
piece and if this Knight moves there's
rookie five check as well to uh look at
because of this E3 E2 the H2 Pawn loose
Donna I feel like this is one of those
positions where the eval bar biases us
right black does legitimately have a
chance to survive I'm with you that
white should win but with a runner
coming up to E3 and maybe E2 in the near
future I feel like there's an outside
chance for tanjangi to survive there
certainly is but Vortec is demonstrating
filigree precision as he shifts his Rook
from the D file to the B file the Knight
on C6 dominates blackstroke on the air
interesting how strong the Knight can be
defensively uh because it defends E5 it
protects d8 and after E3 Rook B7 check I
have a feeling portnick has calculated
that position out to the end
yeah portnick is so strong uh he's so
used to these formats played in the
rapid Chess Championship last year the
global championship and he did quite
well in the Champions chess tour first
event the air things Masters and while
we have ton zhangi on camera while she's
playing in this event we got to make
mention that the women's candidates
finally comes to head on Tuesday March
28th after taking down their competitors
some of the strongest women in the game
including the pcl's Katarina Lucknow and
Alexander castenuk lay Ting ji and
tanjong Yi now Vie for a seat across
from reigning women's world champion Jew
and June we bring you live camera feeds
and exciting commentary of the match
right here at twitch.tv chess use the
command candidate it's in chat for all
the details and while I was reading that
out oh my gosh this is crazy she must be
happy that she was not screen right
there suddenly she's right back in it I
don't want to say I told you so but I
think I told you so you absolutely told
me so and Rook D2 check is found by
tanjongyi this was missed by Alexander
Bortnick after E2 white wins by covering
the e-file with his Knight but
apparently rookie fourcheck slips The
Rook into that little window Robert then
you play E2 and the connection between
The Rook of the pawn cannot be disrupted
and white has no Checkmate white
actually could lose so sick we need to
show this so if you play E2 to start
with you can see the eval bar go up
because if they're Knight E7 check the
king slides up then this Rook goes to E6
and we stop the pawn in its tracks and
we have an attack against the king so
instead of playing E2
she found rookie four and the point is
that the Knight no longer will block The
Rook on the e-file and this Pawn goes
for it Borden could lose this he
absolutely could lose this wherever the
King goes even King C3 meets with E2 you
can take the Rook on D2 congrats but the
Rook on e4 is the one that you can't get
to and the other thing Robert Rook b a
check is a paper tiger the king slips up
to G7 you have no way of ladder
checkmating black skin because the Rook
on F6 has no way of getting to one of
the squares one of the available squares
on the eighth rank how does white even
draw after E2
okay I think I see it but process of
elimination E2 Knight this analysis
board here E2 97 check you bring the
king up to G7 The Rook is under attack
so I protect the rook and I must have
some like Knight F5 check and oh my God
rookie three check
oh that's hilarious and the king would
have to run back and forth
it's a professional if If You Queen
Knight F5 double check if the King goes
to G8 Knight H6 check and then Rook f8
is check mate that's sick
b e a utiful that's amazing and E2 is on
the board and Sasha Bortnick has to
hunker down and hold this together
because
he's in full out panic mode right now
there was no way he expected that pawn
to reach the fourth rank now it's on the
second rank it threatens to promote and
Rook D6 that doesn't help because the d8
square and the E8 Square are protected
by Black's Twin Towers there
yeah the queen that will appear on E1
this is nasty 97 check step one and if
he finds G5 that means Rook E3 check
will be the only way to secure the draw
it seems for tanjong yi so
gosh this is a moment where Bortnick his
whole tournament uh could be in trouble
if he doesn't find G5 if he plays G5 is
able to secure a half Point based on a
repetition then he can still qualify for
some of the top two divisions but if he
loses this game it's starting to head in
the wrong direction for him and he's
done in 20 seconds
G5 is a cold-blooded move not easy to
find he has to realize that Knight F5 is
a mate threat and he has to see King C4
in response to rookie three check he has
to understand the black is unable to
promote he finds it
is
oh my goodness but it's a backfire
if you take takes it's gonna be this
repetition wow only different one
you can't stop the promotion so it's
going to be a draw by force back and
forth here this has been a crazy game
this has been a treat to watch in
fortnite there's no way to complicate
the game he holds the draw or we should
say holds the draw in amazing fashion we
have a Time scramble in our top game
between Notre back and fedesev
so back we go it's a better say I'm in
Big Time trouble he does have a rook to
just a knight now that sounds good but
the Queens are on the board the black
king is more open the bishop on G3 it's
slicing across the board there's a pin
here not if only this Knight could join
the party
crazy as it sounds but the Knight
actually fulfills an important defensive
task it's guarding the G2 Pawn which is
not important now but if the black queen
gets to the second rank it will be
important why does a fortress both
Queens are hanging
wow that was a sick move he's so quick
with that unbelievable he's keeping
himself over 10 seconds which is really
important and he's making progress he's
trying to force the Queens off the board
Rook B7 there's Queen h8 watch out you
really have to be careful as Queen h8
isn't just protecting the bishop oh my
gosh he was Queen of fate and then Queen
F6 Jack King E8 and if the Queens are
forced off the board black is winning
that's a sick fight that's the thing
about Federal Saving people like him
it's not just finding these game-ending
tactics is finding Maneuvers just like
this and he might play H5 he might go on
the attack and try to boot this bishop
out of here knowing Vladimir draw is not
in his vocabulary overnight he's gonna
massage this and try to build up some
time on his clock but the problem is
every year he's taking him two or three
seconds here goes the H Pawn and here
goes Vladimir fellas of Queen h8 I would
go Queen h8 stick that Queen in there
and hope for some sort of Perpetual or
counter play with queen h8 and Bishop to
E5 creating that battery on the dark
squares right get the queen in first the
bishop out second and they're gonna be
some problems but the Queens might be
forced off the board in some of the
positions there because the queen
doesn't have an escape route from h8 at
least not an easy one so for example H4
uh Queen h8 H4 Bishop E5 I could already
see an argument from like Queen d8
absolutely or queen to f8 trying to
trade those Queens off desperately so we
are seeing some moves so I'll get back
to the live board H4 Bishop F2 no that
was a mistake that's an incredibly
passive move he might have forgotten
that E5 is protected now he's on his
last legs and black is now the one going
after whites King King G6 hiding from
the checks
perfectly safe so where is The Knockout
blow is it Bishop D3 Queen F1 I think it
is why does almost win by the way you
have to keep your queen on that diagonal
Bishop D3 might end it
it's done you're just gonna go okay
we need shade then Rook takes E1 even
very good
yeah I just want to avoid all your
checks do everything with check you know
that's my plan
I mean C8 last Stitch attempt Rook takes
C1 check is the clinical move still a
little bit of work required I would not
call this game over just yet because the
pawns are on the same side the King on
G1 is a very hard piece to dislodge try
to save we'll have to massage this for a
while
he invite you to bring his King up into
the attack like at some point try to
trade Queens oh but he's gonna go E5 E4
that's really smart
that might do it E5 coming in the King
on H6 is so safe no checks even
hypothetically you can't put the queen
on any square that causes the king any
problems
I mean he's making a bunch of moves
he'll have to push upon it some moment
that moment will arrive
I think it already did arrive Robert if
it ain't broke don't fix it that Queen
on F6 was ideally placed I don't know
why he's brought his King one square to
the left there he goes finally and oh
look at this it's a cocoon around his
King everything protecting each other
Here Comes E4 now there's a Target on G2
I know white has pawns remaining but
with the King on H1 the pod on G2 is
spin King H1 there's Queen takes H3
check by the way
good find and I'm wondering Donnie at
some point we just line up the battery
and try to take on G2 like it's actually
don't think it's a winning well now it's
winning because you can't pretending H5
but look at that King slides over to H5
G4 on passant with made on the next move
filigree just kidding you made me and
resignation yeah no G4 would be a
checkmating idea but politics and Tony
was saying Queen takes G3 the queen
slides the corner and mate King takes
Queen G2 is checked and made a great win
from ferrosev unfortunately for Abdul
sitarov he now slips out of a tie for
first you can see it on his face he is
pretty upset about this result but uh
whoa do we already have
the next game starting like
that was the last game of the round it's
now round seven
don't blink you're missing action if you
blink
yeah but that was just a nice game from
federal Sam and it's hard to adjust
emotionally like he was at an emotional
high now he has to play Lim lay who's
maybe been playing the best chess out of
anybody we saw him take down farouza
we've seen him play with just just
expertise just class in all these locked
positions his strategic maneuvering has
been second to none and it looks like
another position with maneuvering right
the Knight comes to D7 is D takes C4 a
threat that Emily has to calculate now
I'm definitely thinking about it because
he pushed Upon A B4 D4 is a weird move
you're we're used to Queen C2 and Knight
C3 this is a modern treatment as Lim
advances his Pawn up to B4 preventing C5
of course but the drawback is that after
DC gotta Save By the way offered a draw
which Lim promptly declined
interesting wait but is it one of those
uh declining because you didn't see it
remember earlier there was that game
where they were repeating moves and it
seemed like it didn't notice it but here
it seems like he really wants to play on
throw all the pawns forward why don't
you I don't think Lynn wants things to
come down to the last couple of rounds
right he wants to win this game right
here build himself up with a cushion
because again he's going to get at least
one black game in the last two rounds
and he's on the white side of a cattle
and he's been on fire all tournament
wrong no need right now uh you know to
take a step back and take a draw with
white although I like the way finessev
is playing is white overextending
himself Robert on the queen side is
there a risk of that
there definitely is because if you push
the pawn to B5 which he didn't just do
then you're shutting down the side of
the board and black will quickly
developing a rook to C8 and this Knight
can hop into E4 as well but I like how
phariseev is thinking here he hasn't
responded just yet he's not sure do I
take with a c Pawn keep the symmetry do
I say with the epon I don't like the
look of that I think the Knight that's
actually quite entertaining it is
because the bishop is blocked you're
aiming for B4 I think that photo save is
off to a good start but Donna there's so
many important games at this stage wow
he took the e-pawn that okay I have to
say I'm really shocked by that I am as
well but that's vintage Vladimir fellas
he says you're declining a draw I'm not
getting a symmetrical Pawn structure I'm
taking it to you but White's taking it
to that C6 Pawn I think FedEx writing
his previous move just about right now
yeah you can't play Bishop B7 because
Pawn takes A5 and your Bishop is loose
down here on B7 so I think this was
maybe a mistake that Federal Sav is
going to regret when you start thinking
afterwards very natural move that's a
very bad sign but let's keep on going I
did want to call our attention to the
game between levonne aronian and Arjun
aragaisi both these two with five out of
six and Donya this started from an
alapin Sicilian we both played that
throughout our entire careers I feel
like black though with the queen and the
bishop lined up can't be too unhappy
here he most certainly cannot mate in
one was not missed by levonaroni and the
night guards G2 but we could get a bunch
of Peace trades and I take C5 has to be
calculated that's what Arjun is
dedicating his time to de5 Knight D7 and
Bishop F3 there looks very menacing
Robert but the queen can calmly slide
back to C8 once the light skirt Bishops
are traded if anything I think it's
white who has to tread with caution
because the E5 Pawn is weak and if you
support it without four then you're
weakening a lot of those squares in the
center the E4 Square well I could sink
his teeth into that Bishop C5 Knight C5
Knight C3 these this is exactly how you
lose control over a game that you think
you're not risking in and Lavon just
seems frustrated
he should be frustrated but C4 wow
that's a big Choice all right I actually
like that move a lot because the biggest
drawback of playing F4 was black quickly
playing C4 but if your opponent is
already on that square then it's locked
up and after F4 there might even be F5
so I actually think Lavon with the move
C4 he's changed my entire thought
process about the position these are the
small moves that again that we kind of
take for granted it's easy to gloss over
it yet if Levon holds this position it
will be because he played C4 at the
right moment I think Arjun will respond
with B4 then the Bishops are going to
get traded and that position is a lot
more eminently holdable for white than
the one with black spawn on C4 as you
were indicating
the phone might be playing this not just
to hold him oh whoa Knight takes E5 the
poem was hanging but I didn't like the
look of this position because I did
double pawns so what you have a past
pawn and it's protected from afar by
this bishop on E2 so I really didn't not
like the decision from Arjun and done it
if you remember their game in tata Steel
Arjun held but it was an end game where
Lavon was pressing and pressing and for
a moment had a winning position and you
have a lot less time to hold anywhere's
position in in a 10 plus two time
control so Lavon presumably is going to
move his Queen away I think the presence
of the Queen's favors white just because
Black's Queen on D7 is a Sitting Duck
it's gonna be attacked by a rook from D1
so Queen C2 comes to mind B3 is a way to
deploy the dark squared Bishop but
instead levoni started playing with an
abundance of caution you get the sense
that he wants to eliminate his risk your
eyebrows are raised Mr Hess
because I'm just realizing how simple it
is Lavon is just playing great chess
he's I have an outside pass pawn bishop
D2 may even go to C3 and put pressure on
this diagonal White's pieces are all
perfectly placed and the fact that Arjun
is thinking there may be a rook D1 check
to throw in here as well because of the
King has to go to C7 you have to be very
very careful wow the Knight gets kicked
I don't know how to play this position I
think that's what I've learned oh
absolutely this is the kind of position
where I think it's easy to evaluate it's
clear that white is pressing but that's
literally all I know about this position
how do you play it do you push F5 where
do you put the pieces this is where
super GMS really Excel these chaotic
unbalanced positions unbalanced not in
the pieces that remain on the board
that's symmetrical but just the pawn
structure and the undefined nature of
this position so many candidate moves
and Lavon is known for playing fast and
accurately in these types of positions
yeah so we see a position clearly better
for look at Knight C4 maybe there's a
fork over here Rook can come to D1 with
check the pawn on F4 is defended the
bishop I flipped the board by accident
the bishop May slide into E3 just you
know keeping the development going The
Rook can go to A1 later I feel like
white just has a free hand in this game
so we'll leave them to it we'll see if
Levon can convert his Advantage is
growing by the turn after that move in
Bishop F6 it seems like white can just
develop with Bishop to E3 and go after
this Pawn on C5 and a bit of a shocking
misevaluation for Arjun aragaisi who
didn't have to accept this position at
all he could have kept things
symmetrical with B4 probably
underestimating the power of White's B5
Pawn coupled with the increased
coordination of White's pieces he's
going to lose upon and he's going to be
getting tortured for the rest of the
game so but there was a tactic here that
maybe this is what he missed Knight
takes F4 oh three is pinned yeah Rook 64
is the winning move because you take
with the bishop on D4 not Pawn takes
when The Rook can take back with check
the Knight takes on E2 with check and
then you grab your Bishop black as a
piece of head but Rook takes D4 Pawn
takes then Bishop takes F4 white has two
pieces and a pass Pawn for this rook in
a winning position so I think Arjun now
is he just lost like his position is
really looking uh quite hopeless white
is going upon ahead at minimum and has
an outside passer so finally we've tried
this before I don't think we have to try
it again we can go to the game between
Savion and prognanda because these two
are familiar foes Dania in division
three at the air things Masters they
made it all the way to the final Seven
Beat probably not earlier then probably
went through the losers bracket made it
through the Grand Final where Savion
beat him a second time will it be a
third
we will see seven has also excelled in
the PCL for the Garden State passers he
has been the Undisputed MVP of that team
and we have an end game here a similar
end game in terms of the pieces left to
Arjun against aronian but this could not
be more different positionally the
center is closed I think white is the
one who's pressing here he's got
slightly better control of the center
with that pawn chain from G2 to E4 and
of course the Bishops are currently
staring at each other both sides trying
to trade on their own terms of course
the ball right now is in Black's Court
Prague has to decide is he taking on D4
is he opening up the center with d65
probably not immediately because the
pawn is lost after the bishop trade
followed by E takes D5 what do you make
of this well it's a tough question
because Bishop takes D4 I feel like in a
game setting if I put my commentator cap
aside and think about it from a player's
perspective I don't want to hand white a
second Pawn in the center and an open C
file so I don't want to play Bishop
takes D4 but I also don't want my Rook
to get stuck on A7 so both options have
a clear drawback here I think I would
rather keep the status quo because in
the locked position even if my Rook is
on A7 I'll quickly go back to A8 bring
it towards the center not the end of the
world so moves like Knight C6 don't come
to mind Knight G6 to some of these dark
squares and well A5 I wasn't thinking
about but now they're probably going to
played it I get it
yeah I mean it's a typical move that you
play in closed positions as you're
implying in a closed position the value
of each Tempo is greatly diminished
because there is no imminent danger that
you're going to lose something that your
opponent is going to launch an attack
there is I think a danger that White's
going to get his Knight over to D5 which
is exactly what he's doing maybe time
for black to slink that Knight back to
E7 and keep the bases covered I think
the likeliest outcome is a draw but
Prague I think is trying to unbalance
the game preparing B7 B5 and all of a
sudden his Rooks are going to coordinate
on the B file and white could experience
major problems with his Pawn on B2
that's partially why he played A5 this
is genius play Robert he understood what
he wanted to do he immobilizes White's
b-pawn and Sam Savion taking drastic
measures to keep the position I think
that's what he needs to do
yeah but you know he's ready for a fight
because he's wearing his hockey jersey
again
they're fighting all the time and so he
goes C4 to stop B5 he's got a further
clamp on D5 he could even play C5
himself if you're not careful let's say
you make H6 I'm looking at C5 as a
legitimate try you see the eval bar is
actually agreeing with me for a change
because if their Pawn takes Rook D7
check and that's lights out not only is
C7 hanging my knight is about to jump in
to go after your G7 Pawn that's a big
issue so you see prognanda take
um
well you know what he took the words
from Searching for Bobby Fischer take
the draw yes they did I have nothing
more to say about this game
okay let's go to our other games that
are still in progress look at this game
between Lim lay and phariseev what in
the world are we seeing here is fedese
of setting up his pieces for the next
game
it seems like it it's a knight on B8
Rook on A8
but that night wasn't always on V8 and
moving from D7 and that's never a good
sign if you have to make the move Knight
D7 to B8 you know you're in trouble
speaking of trouble
is he just dead lost or white is
obviously threatening
you're trying to figure out how we got
here I don't blame you he gave up a Pawn
on B5 I mean his position is just bad
he's got his pieces can't really move
the Knight on D7 dominated by a pawn
three squares away but it goes B5 and
then Knight B8 those moves don't really
seem like they work together very well
and then he goes 94 to block the attack
on his Queen but that's a pin and the
Knight just went back to D2 where this
is under attack I see that whoa oh oh
that is a sick tactic but it only brings
black to a pawn down position I think
this was the only chance Queen takes A4
Robert Bishop takes B5 then black is
going to recapture The Rook with his
queen of course because the Knight is
pinned then white is going to take twice
on e4 and we're going to get a three on
three with an extra D4 Pawn oh this is
gonna be miserable for fedesaf
yeah these are the types of positions
where white gets to play without any
risk whatsoever if you play perfectly as
black you make a draw you make one
inaccuracy you're groveling for that
half point but the Evo bar is pretty
high here so there must be something uh
that white has some kind of crazy tactic
I'm gonna cheat I'm acknowledging it I'm
not gonna find it myself I don't see it
oh come on no come on look at this queen
takes Rook Bishop takes Knight and
instead of taking back here you take on
e4 with your bishop and the point
everybody is if you lose if you take the
queen on A4 Bishop H7 is a counter check
opening up this Rook to the queen and
when all is said and done white is in
exchange ahead a rook for just a bishop
so you would play Bishop E4 and after
Queen 66 you throw in Bishop takes H7
check and you take a different Pawn one
where the black king is less safe the
pawn on D5 is still a weakness Dunya
this is ridiculous of it Lemley finds it
and he hasn't moved yet so he might oh
my gosh
he's in the form of his life
the fact that he hasn't moved again it
tells us that he is at least intuitively
aware that a different option exists he
is in the form of his life he is cooking
cooking right now in every game and the
speed Robert the speed with which he
executes this line tells us all that we
need to know about his form in this
tournament but his work is not done yet
he will be up upon he will still need to
demonstrate very precise technique to
cash this in to a full point
gosh I mean this is a former World Blitz
Champion we're talking about it's not
wait what
swam 99 of the way to the shore and then
turn back back to the alley now this is
still very good for white but am I wrong
in saying that the position after Bishop
takes H7 even intuitively looked a lot
more appetizing I I think though this is
more his style and it sounds weird to
say when both positions are up a pawn
but he's saying I can just he's won
positions like this where it's even
material so instead of the pawn being on
D5 if they're not being a clear passer
he sees the plus he sees that he could
push his Pawn in the very near future to
D5 uh their back rank problems for this
King this Knight can hop out the C4 and
D5 then D6 so even though the evil bar
maybe was leading us to think about
Bishop takes H7 a little bit more we do
see that the pluses here and this Pawn
is going to be pushed very quickly with
the Knight hopping to C4 I agree I think
this is borderline lost from a practical
standpoint look at Black's clock and you
know you have to understand that the
engine doesn't care how long it's
defending for but fedesev is looking at
this and saying I'm gonna have to defend
this potentially for the next 50 moves
there's no there's no statutes with
limitations on White's ability uh to
convert this position he can Shuffle and
Shuffle and Shuffle and as long as the
d-pawn stays Alive Black will have to
stay on his heels so can Vladimir
fettisafe pull out a draw here that
would be quite the indication of his
form which has thus far been excellent
and the good news for federal save is
this king is a bit alone if this queen
were on H3 and his Knight gets to G4 we
may see the tables turn he goes queen of
five he wants exactly that but when the
Knight slides back to E3 done it's the
perfect Defender it attacks the queen it
protects the G4 Square from a Night Hop
it covers the D5 Pawn so it does
everything at once and queen C6 keep
everything nice and protected I feel
like it's heading slowly but surely H5
in lem's Direction H5 Alpha zero style I
got you down here but look at the clock
are you worried for federal Sav
I definitely am now he has demonstrated
ridiculous accuracy in far more trying
circumstances he had 10 seconds against
Notre back his King was wide open but in
that game he was up in exchange he
converted it to a win holding a draw
when you've got no time when your
opponent has four minutes is perhaps
even more difficult he brings all hands
on deck he stops the pawn in its tracks
but the Rook is now hanging you can't
leave the eighth rank your defenses are
stretched to the Limit do you play Queen
D6
and a clean trade or is that just too
depressing for black to hold
no actually there may be good chances
there but I think uh lemon might even
play Queen A5 just keep the pieces on
the board Queens are the worst block
haters and that's because they get
kicked out so easily with a knight jump
in the near future so I do think that
this is trouble for the big fish uh you
know he offered a draw earlier in this
game now he's praying that a draw for is
made at some point because he is just
down a pawn and it's a clear passer that
has a rook behind it I think trading
Queens is consistent with limb style but
it's not like with Queens on the board
you're risking either so I would agree
oh Queen A5 keep the Queens on the board
because if you really really want to
Queen trade you can get it on demand you
can repeat the position as with black
down to a minute try to keep the Queens
on the board dislodge the queen with
your knight and keep pushing the Deep on
great winning chances for limb
okay he's just plenty of time so we will
come back to this game for sure but we
do want to switch back to levonne Ronin
versus Arjun eragisi Levon and Arjun
both in great shape thus far in
centralization by lim okay he's going to
keep that Advantage but look at this we
have an end game it's even material but
it's anything but even uh excuse me how
do you like that Bishop on E8 hello at
night how do you like me now says the
night as it moves to H1 and G3 and it
can get there through many different
airports or through only one air we can
get there through F1 or H1 of course
white has to watch the activity of black
skin so maybe put your King on E3 at the
right moment but Robert if the Knight
leaves its supervision of the E5 Square
then black can potentially generate
counter play with a well-timed e65
what's the limitation of a bishop it can
only stay in its diagonal so let's say I
do this thing here yo King D5 and I go
you're E5 then what what's your next one
next yeah yeah E4 and then what
so he goes up instead of back can't
really blame him his Bishop never moves
you drop this Pawn over here you can
play King to E3 at any moment this King
can't get in so levana ronian is in
really excellent form in the last couple
months so it's it's good to see that
Lavon I think if you're Arjun you say
couldn't you wait a little longer before
you started playing your best chess
again uh but this is a great showing
from aronian this is where tremendous
experience comes in handy you just don't
get too low with the lows you know that
ups and downs are the natural part of
the progression of a chess player's
career in lavonaroni and it is great to
see him as confident as he is back to
playing the style that we are so
familiar with that night is going to
make itself familiar with Black's King
side pawns and Gobble them up one by one
he only will have to take one Pawn
Robert once F7 is eliminated the G Pawn
is free to roam about the cabin
yeah this is a clear win and no
turbulence here that pawn is getting to
the other side so why don't we go to a
game that also is similarly one-sided it
is the Lemonade game against Federal
sale this is now easy for Lavon maybe we
actually I guess I feel like Arjun might
just resign in the next two moves so I
will I will try to see this finish here
instead of running away like I think
maybe Knight D6 but the ultimate in your
face win is to get the king over to F6
all hands on deck you have to reward
your pieces for the job that they have
done dominating that Bishop Arjun hasn't
even started his engine
and he's gonna have to make an emergency
landing but it's too late for that crash
and burn where Argent era guys see
another win for Lavon aronian six out of
seven can you believe it
I can I just think the level
yes in first place
the Queen's got traded
is Rook C5 just gonna win this Pawn
after Rook D4
and Rook at four king E7 that might have
been what went missed
protecting and attacking and you're
going to get some kind of Rook maneuver
at some what after King E7
there's no threat right oh there is
Knight takes D5 what am I talking about
you can take that so it goes Rook F3
trying to be clever
okay now Rook summer don't go Rook C5
Rook takes F6 is so easy to blunder
oh
you jinxed him that's your friend oh I
can't do that
oh my gosh he walks right into a night
Fork the moment I said it he plays an
even worse move because Rook D7 Rook
takes F7 wins everything
yeah just trade off no way winning King
upon game Dunya we were talking about
Rook C5 which was a way to go after this
Pawn which is a similar blunder because
Rook takes F6 King takes 94 backwards
knight move check and a fork he goes
Rook C7 and loses on the spot Knights
are so tricky even for super jams it's
never over he does so much to hold that
position he got the Queens off the board
he encircled the D5 Pawn when he was
knocking on the door he missed the last
available tactic Lim is a demon he's on
six and a half out of seven clear first
place good players are lucky that's what
we know that's what we always see right
now we are seeing a big game between Wei
and vladislava tell me if that is a very
uncharacteristic blunder we are used to
Perfection from feta save in time
pressure but he's human
he is human and well this is a very
level game between these two I know
photos say have down assuming photos
they have uh artemia we were just
looking at photosaves game he's had
those final seconds he's got to go like
he is really spending too much time for
my comfort
but it just seems like he's got
everything defended I don't see even a
single wave for Wei to generate to whip
up any sort of imbalance to exploit
Black's time pressure
yeah this is looking kind of a simple
position to hold so
is there a single plan actually I don't
see one
I don't see one either well I think his
plan should be to make a move in under
10 seconds
what do you think of that one that seems
playing for a win are Tammy have Swank
for a win I can guarantee it Bishop F6
he's going afterwards dark Square
weaknesses in the center wow good call
by you
and C5 is a huge threat right now so
he's definitely a C5 but then D5
B5 B5 instead outside pass Pawn black
should have a slight not advantage in
terms of objective evaluation but
there's a practical chances when you
have the outermost past Pawn you're
usually the happy camper but White's
gonna play D5 he's simultaneously
supporting that pawn with the queen and
preventing B4 black reinforces the
thread maybe time for Bishop E1 instead
he centralizes his bishop and he
blunders 84. yes he did but Bishop C5
helps D6 it's not just about the
quantity the quality of the pawns this
Pawn getting up to D6 oh you can't take
it because it's Bishop takes E5 check at
the end one second for limb for waiting
wonders if there should be foreign
what beautiful geometry and you called
it vladislav artemia was playing for a
win in a position that looked like he
was on the worst side of equality that
is unbelievable how quickly it turned
artemia is not to be trifled with but
let's keep on going there still are
games going all the reason for ruja is
playing in this one and God how many
wait
about to promote and it's gone yeah what
pawn are you talking about again well
he's got three other pawns on the queen
side I think he's gonna lose this
he has to set up some sort of a fortress
he might already have it set up maybe go
to B4 oh you're pointing it out Rook B4
and black skin can't get out of the cage
wait wait but apparently there was a way
to have an advantage for black this is
just a draw so we can see it clearly
this is
um a fortress there's nothing you can do
the king cannot although get out of the
a file
there is one hypothetical plan which
involves basically trapping White's King
in the corner the problem is you can't
do that you would want to go Queen E4
here but the Rook guards some of the
critical squares so all the rest is just
going to chill out and Shuffle the king
between F4 E5 F5 Etc yeah nothing to see
here and the players agree to withdraw
okay let's go to Vincent kymer I haven't
heard his name today I haven't said it
and he actually has four and a half out
of six he's looking like he's about to
move to potentially the five and a half
out of seven with the win that would get
towards the top of the standings he's up
one Pawn but he's four seconds left he
wants the second king E5 is Rook F3 type
of ideas going after the E3 Pawn but
check it's getting
bit
Black's gonna take on E3 with check this
is a draw King D6 though and practically
this is such a difficult position to
hold you need to go to the side Robert
Black's Rook cannot stay on E3 it has to
go to A3 and then A6 and check the white
king to Oblivion from the side
brings the king here he wants D6 and he
wants to get the Rook away okay you
check decent you want it provoke D6
because the King has nowhere to hide
and he tries to hide the king Under The
Rook but the Rook will just Shuffle
between the two corners
to Qantas and now we have a philodor
position are you the New Yorker here I
mean where did that accent come from oh
both of them both missed it I mean
honestly not much time left for white so
I get it but that was a shot that
Vincent kymer is more than capable of
seeing he may get a second chance
because I I think that it could be
blundered a second time here not in here
same yes because the Rook could take and
block
oh my gosh Rook end games and Vincent
climber they haven't mixed well since
Tata steel he's gonna look through this
game and kick himself because the win in
this game would have propelled him
through five and a half out of seven as
it stands he might be out of division
one qualification don't take that Rook
now if
you're wait Vincent is actually creating
some chances why did blacklight King C7
not sure King D6 King D6
because after still trying rookie six
okay
yeah yeah
okay but the thing is he's gonna keep
checking and when The Rook Blocks he's
gonna bring his Rook down the way don't
blunder Maiden one okay seven oh oh oh
with rookie six you're gonna lose this
he's gonna lose this
Rook H1 I think is the drop gosh yeah he
played it with a rook C6 check and the
king gets cut so you're starting to get
a little scared even if you're still
holding your long side I know those of
you who've read devaretsky's manually
like I never understood short side long
side what does that mean here you were
seeing it that this Rook is going to
give a ton of checks to the white king
but the draw is getting harder and
harder the path is getting more and more
narrow Vincent will push his Pawn to D6
now King B7
or King to C7 Rook C8 and D7 it's still
where is he going oh Rook H7 check after
D7 is still a draw and the King D6 I've
never seen this before
what a drawing mechanism
I just learned something me too
my he's removing that was cool go King
d8 King d18 D6
okay drop well let's just quickly show
that position uh where there was the win
right where was it
was a little earlier
no it was a little earlier oh so far
away
it was here
D6 check because if the Rook takes
unlike when The Rook was over here and
then the Rook could block with Rook D7
here Rook H7 check kicks the king away
you lose your rook and if you don't take
this Pawn after a D6 check you go King
D7 check the King goes the background
King E6 and now your King has to run
away but it's unfortunate for black and
white gets to push the pawn not now
because the pawn is pinned you simply
put King E7 D7 and d8
and what's important is that blackstroke
doesn't make it to the back rank when
white spawn is on the sixth rank you
want the Rook to be on B1 so it can
check from behind you wait for the pawn
to push forward here you're not in time
making zigzags its way out of the checks
because it's got the entire King side
with which to work Rook up one king G5
Etc and as you're pointing out black
doesn't have enough Defenders on the
promotion Square what a Miss what an end
game what a draw by black because it got
tough at the end
it certainly did and well at the top of
the standings it is getting tougher and
tough for the super GMS they're floating
to the top but there are still players
some young teenagers who are in Striking
Distance trying to make it to the top
eight in the matches So Daniel the
players they go on a break I think we'll
do the same and we'll be right back here
for the last few rounds of this playing
for the chesswell Masters
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
it's Danny here and as you may know
chess.com and chessable are now one and
I'm here to show you how you can make
your chest.com and accessible one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
going to ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pull positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
foreign
[Music]
round eight is underway at the chessable
Masters plan as the players buy for a
total of 72 spots divided into three
divisions Grandmaster Robert Hess and
Grandmaster Daniel narrative chopping it
up for you today Lei Quang Lim has been
shopping it up all tournament long
Robert as he's got six and a half out of
seven clear first place and I think one
more draw will probably secure him at
least one of the top eight spots
yeah he's nearing that territory where
you might click on that draw offer and
unlike in previous games where he's
declined it he would accept with open
arms and we see a position from the
rigos in here look at this the queen
hitting the bishop the bishop before
hitting the Knight but this has been
played in many in World Championship
matches Bishop takes F6 a possibility
but no Lim just is saying let's get into
a less forcing variation that's very
much his style done yet I think what
we've seen from him in this tournament
has been exemplary he doesn't want to
force the matters he wants to get a
slightly better position where his
opponent has no winning chances and he's
just going to comfortably press for that
Victory and you might have heard some
top players say that nowadays in really
the last couple of decades players are
moving toward universality and you could
say that top players really don't have
any weaknesses anymore I think that's
true to an extent but that does not mean
they don't have preferences they might
not as clearly defined of a style as
someone like Mikhail tall they might be
comfortable in most types of positions
but that doesn't mean that at their core
they don't have clear preferences and
like Huang Lim has been able to funnel
the game into precisely the kind of
territory in which he excels the most
positional grind it out games where he
has one time and time again and guess
what I think he's got a pretty Pleasant
position out of the opening again
he does please take me on C3 my Bishop
will take back I have a pair of Bishops
staring in useful dials now Bishop E7
well you're a bit passive good decisions
by aronian and Lim playing King H1 you
want some kind of f4 to happen and
doesn't want his King on this diagonal
where it could be checked so interesting
so far in this game between Lim lay and
aronia I just want to quickly shout out
Daniel I'm gonna name the people because
we have usernames and Donnie and I know
everyone in the Chess World more or less
I'm just gonna go through the list we
have limit six and after seven levonne
aronian clear second six out of seven
artemiev perusev abdusitarov all at five
and a half along with sevion prognanda
and Maxine versus Leon Beast then
aquarium that's Notre back yakubaya the
other notary back super strong player
from Uzbekistan underneath him we have
gandivam that is Arjun era geisey
followed by Maxime chagaya that's
fandorin we have kramnik I don't think
you need to any explanation of Vladimir
kramnik's username
young Belarusian Talent the Grand Master
behind him is a mean type of Dubai
Vincent kymer and raunik sedwani so
there you have it those are the
standings and there you have levonne
aronian so we have him on screen Dania
the sun is shining behind him his
position though not looking so bright I
would much prefer to have white here
yeah White's the one kind of sitting
around a fireplace with a glass of wine
in hand enjoying his advantage in the
center and on the king's side and
lavon's biggest source of counter play
might be that D file the bishop on D3 is
pretty loose he brings his Rook over to
the C file and white might very well
follow suit with Rook a to C1 the
tension really has reached Topeka there
has been no direct contact between the
armies just yet but that might change
the moment white plays E5 or F5 and then
all hell will probably break loose
and it's hard to evaluate these moves
because I know when I've had these
positions I'm always nervous that I play
E5 too soon how many games have we
looked at today where we've criticized
that pawn as being overextended and here
he refrains Lemley says I'm gonna play
Rook a D1 maybe at some point move this
bishop away even to C1 this bishop could
also think about going to B1 and that
sounds weird I thought you're saying
Lily has the better position why would
you Retreat your pieces well with the
Rook staring down the D file maybe
White's Rook needs open access to that
lane as well but I do prefer this bishop
on D3 to this bishop on E8 that's the
main difference maker with E5 on the
docket black could try to beat white to
the punch and play E5 himself I can
guarantee you that Lavon is investing
serious thought in that move but white
could strike with Knight to D5 of course
every time a pawn is moved squares are
weakened and I'm trying to puzzle out uh
tease out the complications after Knight
takes Pawn takes Rook takes that Rook on
D5 is the Sitting Duck Bishop takes H7
or queen E4 both lead to very nasty
consequences probably better to start
with Bishop takes H7 as you're
indicating and that's just down in
exchange in the resulting position if
you don't take the Bishop Robert then
then you're suffering even worse
consequences with the queen coming to H5
uh with with just massive checkmating
threats or Bishop back and then Quinn H5
yeah but the point is the same that no
matter the order there it's going to be
a huge problem a losing position for
black and so that's why you know you you
want to stop white from playing E5 but
you need to do it by having a good
follow-up not by playing E5 yourself
giving white the D5 but look at this the
eval bar is going up in Limitless favor
simple moves he wrote his Bishop back to
C2 quickly came to A6 so this is the
sign of a superstar player when they
make moves like Queen A6 shattering
their own Pawn structure double
isolation over on the queen side but the
danger of the attack is what's worrying
about so much and by the way the eval
has gone back down to the middle so
either there was a Miss I must go back a
couple moves because I'm not sure if
there was some kind of Miss in this
position after Queen B6 or if it just
got very high well no reason he oh okay
the best roof was literally impossible
Bishop D2 to E3 now I looked at this
Robert I said oh that makes sense you're
forcing the queen back to C7 and I was
like wait a second isn't the night
hanging
and then you're like is it the queen
trapped after Bishop C
or Knight D4 oh and Rook takes D4 guards
the bishop and reinforces the threat on
the queen oh my gosh Queen B6 the line
still doesn't end
what's the move here is it Rook no it's
not Rook D7 yes it is it is Bishop c594
you know I love stopping one square
short of expectations and that's what
Rook D7 does I thought oh I'm gonna take
your Rook but then you would take back
and you would survive no no no no Robert
Bishop C5 Knight A4
oh just continue to go after this queen
and once the queen moves somewhere you
trade Rooks and then you take this
hanging Bishop on C5 and you win the
game you take with the Knight you're up
a piece that is just an incredible
sequence like that is let's start really
mind-blowing stuff but we need to stop
dumbing it down for the audience these
lines are way too Elementary let's show
something actually worth its salts and
monaroni's Rook is now worth its salt
he's gotten a pair of knights off the
board E5 is still very much on the
horizon and white is still the one who
has to constantly make that decision uh
about when and whether to push his
Center Pawns
and what Lem is demonstrating in just
his opening choices in the way he plays
it may be objectively even if you have
the computer by your side and we're both
making the best engine moves but you
just look at this position it does seem
slightly more pleasant for white to play
with E5 if you play Bishop C6 that stops
E5 for now but then your queen on A6 is
kind of off to the side not really
participating so I still like the style
but let's uh let's go to a different
game because as I'm seeing there the
scoreboard Big Fish six and a half out
of eight so he already won his game done
who'd he beat
well he beat konavets and konovets is Mr
Samuel sevion not just somebody off the
street we are getting word by our
incredibly hard-working team that this
game lasted only 19 moves let's confirm
oh oh he missed a four
goodbye
stick a fork in them he's done and
that's a good win for federal Sav how
did that this position I did some
theoretical discussion we don't think it
was the weeds but was it what is it
really just a one blue blunder oh it was
he just and B4 was really the blunder
Robert because you can't at this point
after C takes before if you don't
recapture white creates a passer on the
queen side and wins easily oh what a
heartbreaker for Savion that is a bus
wait was this clock accurate 10 minutes
yes
he resigned with
he thought for a minute afterwards he
mistook his prep right he thought he was
still in prep he played before you are
doing well but Rook C4 ended the game on
the spot he thought for a minute and
resigned so that's a huge win for
federal sale who goes up to six and a
half at eight now he's in good shape to
make it to the matches to compete for
division one so let's uh go away from
this game but it's important to show and
do your tactics but yeah this was a nice
game for federal save and let's go to
some of the other games some of the
contestants trying to get to those top
eight spaces let's go to do Bob's game
we haven't talked on Daniel duboff all
day but from one Dania to another what
are you thinking about his position
well I think Dania has a very it's weird
to talk about Dania not being me it's
just a slight confusion right there but
no confusion in this position it's a
very symmetrical pun struck why does a
smidge better do to his pressure down
the f file but with his last move dubuff
says I don't care talk about pressure
you're gonna get some pressure down the
e-file if you don't move that Knight
away which is exactly what Arjun does
and Robert I think the Rooks are going
to get traded all of them and I think
we're heading furiously toward a draw
and look some sort of
see that he's in the darkness and I mean
it's night time I guess he is just
trying to uh you know fight for those
top places uh he's concentrated right
now and the issue Dania is that this
moment if you you're if it's division
one or bust for you and it shouldn't be
because there's a lot of prize money in
division two or dubov you might have to
take some risk and the same holds true
for Arjun in order to play for a win in
this position you might have to do
something completely wacky and generally
in my RCC commentating experience the
format is similar it's a nine round
Swiss followed by the finals
I would say that's probably gets you
into the top eight but seven out of nine
guarantees you the top eight so a limb
basically only needs a draw do love he's
got five points he really needs to try
to go two out of two or at least one and
a half out of two to give himself a
Fighting Chance
yeah and while there are many players
along with dubov and our generic I see
fighting for the top eight uh we'll
leave them to it in this position where
the knights may be about to venture
around the board let's go to Vladimir
kramnik because he has the black pieces
against Vincent kymer it's youth versus
veteran and what in the world are we
seeing here there's a Pawn on D5 and it
wasn't White's last move this Pawn
actually was here two turns ago 95 oh
okay who cares about the tension Bishop
B6 Rook D7 yeah okay Kingdom B1 I mean
these pawns can all be captured and
neither side is budging
this is a cluster you know what in the
center
fudge in the center with a Pawn on D5
attacked and defended eight thousand
times I could probably spend chromics
remaining time just counting the number
of Defenders on that pawn I was not a
math major in wink wink so of course
Robert in all seriousness the big
question for kramnik is whether to
release the tension in the center if so
which Pawn do you capture on D5 with or
do you play a move like Rook h8
it's a matter of exactly on that square
it's a matter of time before it explodes
it is indeed so do you go Rook hd8
kramnik says I don't care I'll just let
the center be that as it may I'm going
to make a positional move on the king
side classic Vladimir kramnik right
there
uh okay so G5 played it stops any kind
of f4 pushes this Knight at some point
to reroute is that actually important
like I'm trying to understand what why
G5 was played but I'm still just staring
down here in the center like this Pawn
is under attack a million times it's
attacking all sorts of stuff like I can
hurt your Pawn structure can I play
Bishop takes C7 and remove the guard of
your Pawn D6 is there gonna be a knight
takes C4 thrown in at some point Donna
can you translate this position for me
I'm sorry I just what okay let me tell
you what there's going to be is the time
scramble just a couple of moves because
every move is taking the players like at
least a minute white spent two minutes
on his last move kramnik spent one the
big problem for black is that Knight G6
runs into D takes C6 and blacks King
side uh queenside Pawn structure is
ruined so I think the Knight is staying
pegged to E5 in fact that's why kramnik
played G5 he wants to prevent white from
chasing the Knight away with F4 and I
think black's next move is likely to be
Rook h 8 to d8 if I'm honest I think
kymer is gonna just say enough with this
I think he's gonna take on E6 here and
at least clarify the position somewhat
maybe bishop D4 is uh one way to get to
that Knight but the Knight can also be
supported from F6 with Black's Bishop
I'm not trying to be making things more
confusing I'm sorry yeah no I'm very
confused but I think that we want to
take and take on C6 that is something
that you stated and I agree with because
okay I I can't possibly understand this
game so what I'm gonna do for the
benefit of everybody in all of humanity
not just people watching is I'm gonna
take us to another game they'll be
easier to dissect because they're making
little Pawn pushes in a complicated
position so I just don't get it let us
go to the game between limlay and Levon
of ronin that one hopefully easier to
understand yes indeed it is we see a
bishop stare down on the diagonal this
Knight can go into E4 but you can also
trade queens and take on B6 done it what
do you make of a decision like that for
white to go Knight against Bishop with
the Rooks on the board in that end game
that's so much tension in a lot of the
games well first of all it is in limlay
style he wants to eliminate risk he is
more than fine with the draw here what I
think White's the only one pushing
Bishop takes B6 Rook takes B6 Rook D7
and the big question is does this Knight
have serious prospects where can it go
well the obvious square is E4 and from
E4 Robert it can jump into F6 important
thing to remember is that a rook end
game does not equal draw we know that
all Rook end games are drawn except this
one that pawn and F6 is going to create
long-term problems on the eighth rank
white struck is more active this is
precisely what Lim is searching for
yeah because the white King has free
access into the position whereas the
black king is stuck thanks to that
double Pawn we also don't like double
pawns but as you say Pawn structure
often overrated 94 step one a very
important point for everyone to note
that if B4 is played white is not just
gonna be like let's just trade and have
a good time that brings The Rook up
attacks all sorts of Pawns You'll Play
A4 you keep the position close and maybe
black needs to go for this with a move
like B3 but done it's already getting
dicey with the white king going forward
if the Knight gets into F6 you have to
watch out for checkmates against this
game absolutely the H7 Pawn being
hanging so I'm liking the look of this
for white and maybe Knight F6 right away
you just you're talking about it Rook
end games favorable for white
and you're talking about made threats
that's not an exaggeration after Knight
F6 if white if black gobbles up the A3
partnership no problem you don't have
any pieces to Checkmate me with well
white says yo yes I do Rook DHS King E7
rookie at his mate but more impressively
King G7 seems to escape the worst of it
on H6 but no the worst of it is still
waiting for black after G4 what a
beautiful mating construction and G5 all
hands on deck the king is checkmated
would be dead
oh gosh that would not be fun so Knight
F6 actually still a good option here
that it might encourage the bishop to
take you don't want to do that if you
don't take the H7 Pawn is hanging and
you have to watch out for Forks on the
D7 Square because once that Rook moves
away the Knight would love to hop the D7
with back rank checkmating ideas I don't
like this for Levant he's down to two
minutes and well then lay decides to
keep the pawns on the board and okay now
that the evil bar is settling in Knight
F6 is still available perhaps keeping
more pawns on the queen side plays to
White's benefit
it's hard to say I mean it really
depends on Black's ability to keep the
activity of White's tandem at Bay Knight
F6 I think is coming next is White
having to improve his position maybe
Rook C7 first to open up the possibility
of eighth rank infiltration I think Lim
has to figure out the order does he play
Knight F6 first or does he move his Rook
maybe to A7 maybe to C7 I can see a case
me made for that but Rook before Robert
could be very nasty if the F4 Pawn is
also undefended never mind such I made
this move just like throw away oh what
is he doing of G5 throwing away he's
throwing away his Adventure I was just
saying King G3 is a move I just was kind
of suggesting to bring the king closer
and Lavon strikes with G5 and now it's
turning around completely but F5 yeah
rookie Savage
oh
but there's something wrong with this
what is it
but I'm looking at Lavon right now I'm
trying to see if he expects this it
doesn't seem like he did he doesn't seem
overly phased but just to show everybody
that we have to talk about this that e
takes F5 it looks like a free Pawn but
if the Rook takes E7 if the king takes
back Knight D5 is a fork white goes on
to win he is suing end game up a piece
so instead we saw the king slide to E8
and white can trade on E6 first or move
this Rook somewhere but done yeah I feel
like if the Rook goes to A7 this bishop
will at some point soon just go after
the E5 pawn and black would be the one
who's better that is I think what uh lim
underestimated
the power of that black Bishop when it
gets to D4 the pawn on B3 might not seem
dangerous but obviously once the bishop
lands on D4 you will be threatening to
take the knight any Rook end game with a
passed b-pawn is going to be winning for
black so
now Lim is the one who has to be careful
he goes for K7 and Bishop C5 has to be
calculated or not or just play it
immediately because you're Mr aronian
already calculated he says and the
bishop is going to D4 where it not just
throwing the pawn if Bishop takes Knight
and you take with a B Pawn we're about
to see the new Queen appear on the board
so rookie check played probably a good
decision you could take here now with
check if you'd like and H7 is loose oh
oh he takes F5 now it's possible
yeah that's starting to look very scary
was there any downside Robert to taking
on E6 first or do you think Lim might
have just forgotten that he takes F5 is
now a possibility
I don't know but Lavon did not forget he
plays it and Rook F6 it does seem like a
good double attack because both pawns
are loose but after Rook to F6 I feel
like there's a problem which is with
this King in general like this king is
in trouble Bishop D4 King E6 once you
take on F5 and you take on E5 here I
just don't like the look of this one bit
for white so Levon of ronian he may be
heading on to the top eight in a match
to play in or division one this is a
nightmare scenario for Lim who could
have secured qualification into the top
eight spots but we're jumping the gun
here just a little bit when you have
division one which is eight spots you
have the top four choosing their
opponents in spots four through eight so
the most desirable place to be is still
first place even though uh eight players
compete for the division one ticket so
laquan he's trying to take that risk win
this game guarantee himself first place
and it may have just backfired in a huge
way now Robert you'll have to draw the
game at least in the final round with
the black pieces if he wants to ensure
one of the top eight spots
all the way down yeah no you are correct
because his tie race likely are great so
he'll undoubtedly get into the top eight
if he is tied with a bunch of people but
Rook check Bishop D4 starting to look
very straightforward B2 is about to be
lost is black human down with oh gosh no
who's mating who
Robert who would have thought that it's
not the rook and Knight the checkmates
the blacking it's the other way around
and this is a devastating concession F4
you're highlighting B2 Rook D2 should be
winning on the spot
because this threatens The Rook it's
going to deliver a check oh my gosh this
happened out of nowhere
shocking turnaround Rook D5 trying to
initiate the Rook trade no way Lim lay
says
that was really well played there I
wasn't expecting that but Rook takes B2
that is a free Pawn as Lavon drops under
a minute he is just cruising right now
and he'll cruise to qualification for
the matches remember at the end of this
after nine run Swiss at the end it's uh
four players ultimately qualify for the
top division so eight people when
there'll be a match between them and
look at this Rook takes B2 by Lavon he
now has a pass Pawn
how can he get it going that's the big
question Rook C5 and Rook C2 yeah or
Bishop back first or Rook C2 immediate
lower Bishop there or not it's a mistake
apparently
oh no oh my gosh oh because it can't get
with the B file the king can't go to the
beetle it's a draw on the spot because
of the forks The Rook C5 check force is
Perpetual oh my gosh
or not he goes through B5 he missed it
he could have checked on C5 and forced
the Perpetual check what
that was clear right I mean Rook C5 if
you go this way Rook back if you go this
way you get mated we saw this Checkmate
earlier the king is gonna get mated so
oh my gosh are you kidding man Lim might
have just resigned the game in his mind
Robert now Knight C3 the problem is Rook
C2 he this is what he overlooked and
it's your your pick you either lose the
Knight or allow promotion unbelievable
what a miss
what a miss and he might have just
mentally given up
yeah because he did have a chance just
for a single move and for Lavon that was
some carelessness and you will not be
able to afford that when he ultimately
gets to the matches he's completely
winning right now you can't make a
mistake like that and remember in the
air things Masters in the game between
Wesley so and Hikaru Nakamura hey car
made a quick move he freaked out it was
a three-time repetition but he actually
made a losing move so Wesley could have
taken advantage of it uh but that was
neither here nor there it's a different
event and for Lavon he goes back he
wants to protect his Pawn he may just go
around this way there's no Knight on the
board to deliver checkmate
absurd I mean given what's happened in
this game I don't think we can call it
over until it actually ends F6 is one
last attempt by limb to threaten
Checkmate Lavon he has to figure out a
way to zigzag his way out of these
checks because King f8 F6 you don't want
to lose F7 and give black the connected
passers
yeah that's true but how do you get out
of it King D7
yeah can you just run away like just
bring everything there give the passers
up
what is he doing yo what are you doing
wait this might be wrong oh my God what
what the fun he shook his head too
he couldn't believe it did he forget it
was three-time repetition at that point
he couldn't have done anything because
to get the king to D7 you have to walk
through the three-time repetition no way
oh my gosh okay well I guess neither
player deserved to win that game so it
draws Fair we don't want to be overly
critical to players but that was
uncharacteristic of both of them yeah
talk about how great limlay has been
throughout and in that game he was quite
sloppy and Lavon when he was handed a
winning position did not capitalize him
oh my god oh
single worst piece I've like ever seen
besides Fiddler against Wesley Stone
Fisher random that is game over rounding
sidwani just like fellow teenager
Vincent kymer goes to six at eight
Vincent did beat Vladimir chronic just
to pull up the final position he finally
broke through uh oh wait you want a Time
moral degradation lives King A8 defends
against mate because Rook d8 is blocked
with Rook B8 kramnik is better in this
position because he's attacking B2
whoa whoa whoa whoa it lands it was
completely winning for Vincent they were
in time scramble so mistakes happen
Vincent kymer beats chromic on the clock
we've seen that one before hopefully it
doesn't send chronic back into
retirement there is increment in this
one uh but for Vlad uh a little bit too
slow and we have Joss from Jose Martinez
now
hey Daniel this one two extra pawns we
know Jasper he has made an outside shot
to get into that six and a half Point
range and that will be good for maybe
not playing for division one but he'll
maybe have the advantage trying to
compete for division two and we know how
generous the prizes are across all three
divisions Rook C7 would have forced to
The Rook trade but maybe it's easier to
keep the Rooks on the board you have to
be careful about pushing the puns the
last thing you want to do is give black
the chance to give up his Knight for
both of black spawns we know that rook
and Bishop vs rook in most circumstances
is a theoretical drop but I think C5 no
C5 doesn't work any longer it's not over
just yet Rook B1 check and the King
hides on B6 maybe no it going the other
way
because he doesn't allow Rook C1 going
out for these pawns he's gonna bring his
King back to B2 you know likely then
Bishop B4 then C5 it's finally about
time that his pawns go up the board
indeed and the bishop checks the king
985 very patient precise play thus far
but he has to break through that last
Maginot Line with uh the the Knight
guarding the C Pawn
yeah but now the knight's far away so it
feels like it's about time to push the
pawn and Josh from just Jose goes after
the night now the Knight is in no man's
land it's stranded gross the pond here
they come Jose is waiting for it and
waiting for it and finally I think he's
ready he's ready he's ready go ahead C5
is coming not yet and the the problem
for black is you can never trade minor
pieces it's easily winning rook and get
oh Bishop I was just saying can't afford
to trade pieces is this night about to
move and Bishop B5 happened no listen
anytime there is a night there are
chances for a draw anytime there is a
night but the night is fully dominated
by that Bishop on C3
there was Rook F2 pinning that night so
that was a grab perhaps Miss chance
there B6 B7 seems pretty straightforward
oh that's a hangar okay oh
very good with a win in the last round
Jose gives himself a chance
it's actually extremely good five
another eight is just a superb result
thus far but let's talk about the
standing so limlay with seven and eight
his tie breaks must be through the roof
is likely through to play the matches
then we have ferrosev behind him Levon
aronian who will be disappointed to only
in air quotes of six and a half but
let's see the start of the rounds we
have limlay and artemiev will we see a
five second draw what do you think we
very well might this does benefit both
players now listen six and a half does
not necessarily qualify you
mathematically if you look at the number
of people with five and a half which
extends below the screen it's gonna be
all about tie breaks with people who
have six and a half obviously Artemis
has some of the best tie breaks because
he's been atop the tournament standings
all tournaments long and we're both did
you see that because slim declined to
draw no no no Lim offered the draw
is The Ultimate Fighter no he's not a
mixed martial artist but he loves to
Duke it out he wait oh
what's that about juking it out I am
going to run away and go to another game
and okay Ronald said one he also Drew
against I think round it drew against
um mvl Lavon drew his game very quickly
so are we gonna have any games remaining
we do have oh the teenagers abusotarov
and kymer
I don't know if this game's gonna last a
while this is one of the most solid
lines that white can play against the
Karo Khan now does a draw satisfy Notre
back you get into the territory with
Notre back where a drum might not make
it his tie breaks are about middle of
the pack when it comes to players with
six and a half I think he's playing for
it
yeah and there's no way to predict how
the tie breaks will pin out and we
understand
what happened someone else all I was
gonna say is we're gonna have so many
people with six and a half Georg Meyer
we haven't looked at it all with a win
could get to Seven but I interrupted go
ahead wait georgmeyer is six out of
eight I haven't said his name a single
time today
I just even know he I mean I knew he
existed I didn't know he was playing
this tournament wait Anish Geary how
many points is a Nisha have I see him
down here
he's like kind of far down the standing
so I I have not kept sight of a niche on
the standings
and oh he's you're scrolling and
scrolling that's not good no it's not
but this position does look good for
white slightly better even if black gets
the break with E5 and that's clearly the
intention of bringing the Rook to E8
that rook in particular then you're
saddled with this isolated Pawn so I
like the way that abdusitara is handling
this and if he wins he will have a match
to determine whether or not he goes into
division one and Vincent kymer gives up
the bishop now it's not a pair of
Bishops it's only one but still done it
I really love these positions for white
The Exchange variation in the caracon
you control this E5 Square you bring a
second Rook over and the bishop stares
over at the king set so watch out for a
sacrifice on H7 as a relatively new
caricon player I hate these structures
with black you pointed out that E5 might
be a necessary evil but it is still an
evil you're left with an isolated Queen
Pawn on D5 I just don't see the appeal
of these types of positions for black
because you don't have anything going on
the queen side you can even play A6 and
maybe squeak B5 through big deal whites
Queen A6 will hang but even if white
screen moves back to C2 that's where it
wants to be anyway you induce a weakness
you double your rook's White's play it's
just a lot easier from a practical
standpoint as evidenced by notorbeck's
growing time advantage
yeah so he is a very quick player and he
started out well in this tournament a
six out of eight is a good result but
probably one and more didn't want to
have to rely on a win in the final round
G6 played by kymer and Daniel this is
one of those moments where if you're a
Vincent kymer if you're thinking about
it from an everyday point of view I want
to make a solid draw with black against
the super gem here like you might have
to take some risk because it you're
going to be fighting for division two
even if you lose the game
to fight for division one you have to
win so I want to see who is going to
take that risk first yeah and the fact
that there are 72 spots right and there
are three divisions it makes it a little
bit of a less pressure situation you
lose the game God forbid you're probably
gonna make it into the top 72 with six
out of nine so you're not out of prize
contention and uh with a loss but the
reward that you can attain with a win I
think is worth taking a big risk
speaking of risk H4 isn't that big of a
risk because white can follow up with G3
and the King side structure is still
healthy if you play H5 though that's
where you have to start being careful
because Robert if the H file opens with
his last move Vincent has signaled that
yeah open the age file I Dare You is the
rook's gonna come to Aha the queen from
C7 is aimed at H2 things are gonna get
spicy and Darcy if white plays H5
they definitely look like they could
heat up any moment in this game I'm just
gonna look minlay is playing against
Arjun Eric garci so I want to give the
players in contention they're due
because if one of these players wins
they get to six and a half out of nine
and as you see that would be a tie for
fourth place now we don't know the
standings because it's reliant on
opposition how they do in their final
games and that's always stressful for
the players Donya where they're looking
hey my opponent from round two who's
struggling can you please win your last
round game to help bolster my tie breaks
and there's a knight on D6 that is
protected by this Pawn on C7 but Dania
Arjun aragaisy he's definitely on the
worst side of this position because of
this Pawn structure on the queen side
but this might be bad for both players
we've got opposite colored Bishops I
think arjun's qualification chances are
basically nil there's no way he's
winning this Lim has to pull out uh all
of the stops minlay that is has to pull
out all of the stops he has to go for it
whether or not that requires taking a
risk that makes this a three result game
his only chance is to win this game and
get lucky in the tie breaks I think he's
making great progress he might win this
without even needing to take any risk
Rook C6 Rook fc1 his plan is clear
attack the C7 Pawn Force Black's Knight
into passivity on E8 and then maybe
create a second weakness maybe
infiltrate down the D file plenty of
winning chances here for white
yeah and Arjun is playing really quickly
but E3 restricts this Knight which is
heading for D4 it also makes sure this
bishop will never have a useful diagonal
and he says I don't care bring your
knight to D4 that doesn't scare me but I
feel like at some point this A7 Pawn is
just gonna drop if I put my Pawn E3
bring my Rook up to the A5 Square move
this bishop out the way back to D3
because white would love to get rid of
this Knight you don't want to help us to
color Bishops you want to take this
Knight so I feel like there will be an
opportunity for men as he wow brings his
Knight back towards the center I like
that but I feel like he's just much
better he's playing without any risk
let's keep on going I feel like we
should try to pay off as many games as
possible that have relevance to the
leaderboard here I see Den Laz he is the
last name on screen in 16th Place but
with a win he hops up into a tie that
ends in eight so he could actually
LeapFrog some of the others and what is
happening here Dania
and before we delve into this position I
want to caution people to take the
leaderboard with a grain of salt because
the tie breaks uh they do depend on the
results of the final round so don't make
any conclusions until the standings are
official we'll have to wait for all of
the games to end before you know who's
squeaked by with six and a half out of
eight Dan lazovic is trying to be one of
the lucky few I think he's got a great
position here Rook takes F6 is a huge
threat and in response to H6 Robert the
E5 Pawn Falls and the whole position
Falls as a consequence drastic measures
might be required here I don't know what
those drastic measures could look like
though
yeah how do you defend against both
threads Rook takes F6 is devastating you
remove the go
oh
that I think is exactly what Jose had to
do and that was the only move that
didn't lose
and what a move just to play it and then
be like okay I'm gonna return that is
nuts right like he gave up a rook for a
night calmly brings his Bishop to a safe
square and Dania I mean we see the
problems a knight is an amazing block
hater it stops the past pawn and stares
over it The Rook can the C file or queen
C5 check at the right moment the C3 Pawn
is a target I'll play H6 the boot your
queen out of there and then black
controls all of the key squares these
squares on the C file white doesn't have
any threats that was a really really
strong exchange Sacrifice from Jose
and Incredibly gutsy to do that as
quickly as he did I could totally see
somebody taking the remaining five
minutes on your clock and then you know
maybe taking on C3 with 50 seconds left
Jose understands that he has to leave
himself with enough time to handle the
consequences that was a brilliant
decision that is called Grand Master
Level plan Jose has given himself a
serious Fighting Chance this is
absolutely a three result game even if
objectively Black's compensation is not
fully sufficient
I think it is though right I agree I'm
sure you agree
um I agree looking at this position
where you this is the tricky part about
Chess steak
is that because of Knight F5 no
I can just take you there just take and
then Rook takes up five maybe but that
doesn't look like you know Rome wasn't
built with with those kinds of moves I
see what you're saying that you want to
double the Rooks with Queenie through
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go back and
move and see what it was
Knight F3 the only move to give that
Advantage a retreating move which seems
to hang this Pawn in some variations
with Queen Z5 but you're getting this E5
pawn and that's sort of the point okay
that's not easy to spot I forgive the
players already and queen E3 Knight D6 I
think that Jose is going to be
unforgiving here I love his position I
think he's better I think he has pretty
good winning chances earlier in this
game Jose offered a draw which was
declines an interesting decision Jose
must know that six out of nine does not
qualify him into the top eight but I
think a qualification into division two
uh is pretty palatable for Jose as well
those prizes are big so an interesting
decision but definitely Dennis wants to
make the top eight and he's I think he's
allowed all the stops here psychological
Ploy because once you offer the draw at
the beginning now you have your opponent
thinking I don't want that draw and if
the position calls for a draw he may
take a risk and that could benefit Jose
he gets a six and a half he'll be in a
tie with the people that you see on the
screen right now it's limlay erosayov
levada ronian they are clear with seven
or more points then we have artemiev
maxiva shiligrav Maxim shigayv uh
prognanda ronak sadwani all with six and
a half so anyone who has less than six
and a half you have no shot at
qualifying for division one because
eight people will play matches four
winners of those matches will make it to
division one of the Chesswood master so
Daniel Jose with a great position I
think we should look at the matchup
between Sam sebian and Daniel dubov
because that one is also very important
and after we just glance at that one I
think we should go back to the kymer
game against Abdul sitarov because of
one of them win they get a clear spot by
getting it to seven points
all sorts of shenanigans though
Happening Here on the board and on Sam
sevin's clock he's down to three minutes
he's coming off a very painful peace
blunder and trying to recover with a win
he's got some pretty strong tie breaks
so a win here does give him a serious
shot what's going on in the center
Robert Queen 65 Rook takes C4 there's
Rook D1 check there to force the Rook
trade
I don't know it's just nauseatingly
complicated
and Knight C5 played by dubov who maybe
is keeping some winning aspirations of
his own that Knight is about to hop into
D3 E5 is loose this bishop on C1 where
is it gonna go that's the big question
and I think both sides have their
chances here Dania I really think it's
far from clear and look at the clock
that's what she was relying on
so B4 here I think is the most
straightforward move Knight D3 Rook
takes E4 has to be calculated note that
F5 does not win The Rook it's still a
possible move you'd consider it because
it opens the f file but I don't think
it's the best that black can do on
passant gives white a Tempo and Black's
King is gonna get caught in the
crossfire so after Rook takes C4 you
have a critical moment it's going to be
reached in the game because B4 is on the
board with no hesitation he cannot
afford to hesitate any longer he's down
to two minutes
yeah he is and while duboff thinks I
mean this gives us an opportunity go
back to the game between abusotave and
kymer a winner in this game immediately
gets into the top four places which
means they actually will get to choose
their opponent that's it's not just
about getting the top eight uh that one
through four get to pick their opponents
and that's a pretty cool feature but
it's a kymer if I'm counting correctly
even material we have Knight against
Bishop that's usually good news for the
bishop but here it's good news for the
Knight because black can take and once
the bishop comes like play F5 King F6
bring that King into the center quickly
create a past Pawn I like that
opportunity for Vincent but he keeps the
Queens on
these positions always look deceptively
simple but they're actually very much
unbalanced I think if the bishop is
traded for the Knight we're probably
going to get a drug doing that
immediately would have allowed an
intermediate check on B2 so he drops the
screen to E2 first
really the big question is do the
players believe in their tie breaks if
they do that will really Define the
course of the game if they don't then
Vincent is going to do everything within
his power to unbalance this position
Bishop takes C6 is an implicit draw for
in this position so we're going to find
out what Notre back's mindset is with
his next move look looks pretty equal uh
noted Rick he doesn't really have too
many choices that black has no
weaknesses no gaps and Bishop takes C6
that is that draw for that you were
talking about and I feel like earlier in
the game Vincent offered a draw and no
Rebecca declined soon these players
probably will split the points let's go
away from this one let's go to the game
between Min and Arjun because
and with a win Min is not necessarily in
but does tie with six and a half out of
nine we'll see how his tie breaks are
this has been a crushing performance
byman Lane something off with Arjun who
spent less than three minutes to get a
piece down end game he just doesn't look
like the origin that we are familiar
with that we know in this tournament
he's going to lose this game most likely
unless he can whip up some counter play
against White's King maybe F5 is worth
trying maybe you should take on A2 and
try to collect as many pawns as you can
but then King E4 opens up a double
attack on the F1 and on the bishop Min
converts these types of positions in a
bullet game Robert I think he's gonna
make this happen
yeah it's a good find by you good point
this Rook will hit F7 the bishop ever
slides back to F6 The Rook can go to C1
Rook C1 is already a threat because
trading the Rooks will result in a
winning end game for Min Lei and we know
he has many fans so if you're in chat
come on let us know let's hear it we're
not rooting against our generic icy but
Min is a streamer so I'm sure many
people from his community are here so
you know show your support throw up
behind him because he may have a chance
to compete for division one and that's
what the Champions chess tour is all
about Rook C1 is all about winning C7
but I just want to say that the format
that was created it was very important
to everybody to give a legitimate chance
to all players not just the tippy top
not just the same people we see in all
the round Robins all strong players that
are in this tournament have a chance and
we're gonna see men potentially make it
into the top eight and try to get into
the division one that would be pretty
cool to see because well I don't think
we've seen a player done yet with a
rating that starts with two five instead
of two six or most of them at two seven
well I don't think men's rating is going
to start with 2-5 for much longer he is
no question 2600 strength a nightmare
matchup for any of the top guys man
never goes down without a fight and
Arjun well I don't think he's got a lot
of fight in him left the pawn on F7 is
not long for this board as one
commentator likes to say and F6 Knight
C6 look at the domination that the
Knight exerts over the bishop the bishop
will be trapped and Rook D2 can be met
with Rook to D1 that's a badass move get
the Rooks off the board get the bishop
off the board and you've got two pawns
to avoid having to checkmate with Knight
and Bishop
and you know it's going to be a sad
conclusion to the Swiss for Arjun as you
said it doesn't feel like the origin
we're accustomed to Arjun aragaisy at
his Peak is a dominant Force he's kind
of a wrecking ball of sorts he has won
over the board Blitz tournament he of
course has qualified to the air things
Master division one the last time around
so you're right something did feel off
at least in this final game and maybe it
just was a bit of a looking at the
standings thinking even with the win
you're not going to qualify or maybe I
have to win and then playing
suspiciously but either way Min is
looking like he is going to take this
game but his 40 seconds and that's yeah
one thing you have to look out for and
these guys it doesn't matter what form
they're in it doesn't matter how upset
they are they never give up it's
ingrained in their blood to fight until
the last drop of blood but White's pawns
are bleeding and Rook takes C7 here I
think just ends the game because then
white is up a full piece the Knight is
safe he goes G4 also good Rook takes H5
technically wins some material back but
not enough to change the outcome of the
game Rook A1 I think is the simplest you
go after the a pawn and
I think Arjun will resign if Min finds
that move
yeah as you said Rook takes H5 Pawn
takes King F7 you get two pieces for
Rook that's a good trade except for the
fact you're left with a rook against a
bishop and now you're going to win this
Pawn on A7 so our generic geiste we have
him on camera here but unfortunately for
him he's gonna drop down the territory
we'll have to fight for a division two
or maybe he'll even be so far down in
the standings that the best he can do is
division three but that's not where he
wants to be and we'll see I think next
time the Swiss happens the plan that he
will be an even better form than he was
in this game and in this tournament
yeah Min giving Arjun zero chances he's
not giving up a single one of his pawns
the king is infiltrating to D5 where is
it gonna hide I think it's gonna hide on
C6 using the C Pawn as an umbrella 20
seconds for minlay is an absolute
eternity with a two second increment but
we've got a couple of games that are
moving toward the time scramble phase I
know you're hovering over motorbike
statements kymer there's also Joshua
demolas lots of important games still
going you pulled up the pawn end game in
Notre back oh against Vincent camera
this is winning for black after King D6
oh oh because you can spring free upon
at some point and that's the big problem
so whoa
King C7 he's trying to triangulate
somehow but that might have
overcooked it
okay but I'm guessing that the path to a
draw now exactly it's gonna be like one
move that you have to finesse it but
King D6 so what's going on there King
d4j
I think he might have given up hopes of
winning this game they're repeating
What's Happening Here three-time
repetition
wait wait wait what is the downside so
G5 what's the oh the fear the fear might
be king E4 okay okay very difficult this
is extremely difficult because takes
takes this exactly is no longer a win so
having the evil bar completely biased us
from how difficult this path was because
at this point if you play F5 in fact
you're gonna lose the game you get a D5
but good for you the white king takes H5
and wins the game so at this point you
already have to make B5 and then after
A3 we get a position where King C5 is
played the King goes up to F5 takes and
you have to calculate all this stuff
where black essentially uh will be able
to
uh go for the a pawn in this situation
you get the H Pawn I get the a pawn and
I think that's how that goes or is it
is this the draw yeah okay good it's a
draw white promotes first but the option
Robert is that black is the one whole
having to hold the dry hair by the skin
of his teeth because white promotes a
check this is a theoretical draw with
the corner Pawn right but this is what
Vincent kymer estimated with the time
that he had remaining hey only what can
win a position like this it turns out
that instead of G takes H4 there's the
ridiculously hard move G4 looks like it
loses because White's King is closer to
Black's kingside pawns but Black's Pawn
is closer to promotion and that's all
that counts the G3 Pawn is indefensible
Black Inches his way runs Sprints his
way for that pawn also F5 I think was
winning followed by F4 but can you blame
Vincent for failing to calculate this
Thicket of crazy variations I don't
think so black promotes with check
exactly that's the key thing is it looks
like simultaneous promotion but
unfortunately you can't promote because
is in check so that was a really deep
continuation uh at first I think it
seemed more obvious than it was let's go
back to minlay because he's down to his
final
oh
[Music]
oh my goodness what happened he's up a
full piece
okay
no way blundered in one move what was 97
he but even here somehow it's
Rook F5 and Bishop E7
you move the king and Bishop D5 is made
no way
wait this mate
I think it is made Bishop C8 and C5
oh my gosh Bishop C8 that's how did he
miss that
yeah okay but still I mean if he made
any other moves around here anyway he's
up a piece and a pawn you have to feel
from inlay but Arjuna Regice you said
these top players they fight to The
Bitter End let's go back to denlaz and
jossom Jose Martinez we liked his
exchange sacrifice but we don't like his
position anymore and then last has a
rook is the safer King it seems because
there's a king out on H6 I don't know if
Queen takes F6 wins but it should
probably because I don't think black
checks but if black lacked tonight then
Queen takes F6 would be a draw the king
is stalemated so then last whatever he
does he actually should not win that
night and take on F6 but with the Knight
present you have no way to give it away
with Tempo I'm just going to show that
very quickly yeah I don't know how to do
that because I know how to give away the
knight in this position but your point
is well exactly King has no moves it's
stalemate so if you could give up both
the pieces at the same time it would be
a draw but this is no draw the king
moves back to safety this is Checkmate
in one D6
oh
it's that's me that's game set and match
potentially qualification for Dan Laz
who goes to six and a half points let's
see how this type the tie breaks are
working out so far he's in 11th place
not quite good enough to get to the top
eight but look at this game we have
sevian and dubov unfortunately for
Savion this is too easy the bishop goes
on the yo-yo string and the king is
there to defend that means that no
progress can be made
and both of them are going to have to
work their way out of division two they
will have six out of nine obviously not
enough to make it to the top eight looks
like we've got a couple more games
remaining those games aren't directly
impacting the top of the standings looks
like Vladimir kramnik might still be
playing though I don't see him there's
our antari there is I mean by I'll let
you choose uh the last couple of games
that we look at Solomon going to go down
wait a second I mean it's happened to
buy with the wink it's a six and a half
he does we haven't talked about him much
either he's slunk his way up to six and
a half this is crazy and imagine if he
gets to sneak into the top eight and he
is completely winning with past Pawn
over here Amin had a rough go of it in
the Pro chess League uh he was losing
most of his games but now he has a
winning position Rook A4 is huge F6 is
my Rook takes F4 check but Robert Rook
C2 is such a tempting move the problem
is you lose contact with the F4 Pawn you
give away just enough counter play but
he has just enough time I think to
figure this out take F4 go back to F2
maybe and then walk your king over to B2
I think Rook F2 is very important yes
because of teenage Rook G2 throw in that
move keep the king cut off I guess I
guess it's just so close right that you
don't need to deal with it yeah this is
easy ultimately Rook H2 and you're going
to give your Rook up for the H Pawn yeah
this is over A1 equals Queen and
resignation will follow
and that is a win for me to tell us
about where does he land let's see it oh
in 13th Place but the tie breaks will be
rearranged once the final round
concludes and we see him in lay in the
chat hope uh you're doing okay buddy I
know that was a tough finish there but
you had a great show of it and let's see
we have a few games remaining oh that
game is over sorry trying to click on
finished games
shigerov is taking on okay but these
games are much farther down the
standings and it will act who gets to
play for divisions two and three so that
is important because in this event 72
people will be involved in The Knockouts
and when all sudden done 52 people will
make it through to the respective
division and these games are also
important from a tiebreak perspective
the tie breaks are calculated by
cumulatively adding up all of the point
totals of your opponent so if somebody
like chess Warrior or Prague played one
of these guys he wants them to win
because the higher score your opponents
made the better your tie breaks because
the stronger opposition you face this is
a win as you're showing in San Antonio
will move to a respectable five and a
half out of nine where he will be joined
most likely by Rasmussen was about to
defeat
yeah I don't know why I said that with a
French accent
I don't know I kind of enjoyed it but
this is not a position that pisho will
enjoy he is just down a minor piece he
just planned out to the end but now that
the pieces are coordinated the way they
are F4 F3 the pawn is going to get to
the other side so this one here it's
clear that Swanee is going to win but
Daniel we don't know it who does funny
play did he play against Den Laz earlier
so this win helps his tie breaks these
things are not easily recognizable but
play a part in the Chess World it's
about to say mate
they absolutely do but that's the genius
of this format all games matter
you need to make the top 72 to be
eligible for the third division and if
you win the third division you get to
the second you win the second you get to
the first so there is a path forward but
the path has been cleared for the top
eight players like Huang and declare
first and let's see who made it Robert
10 less he said he did he made it in the
end wow and vintage unbelievable oh
that's unfortunate for kymer because
he's in ninth place he held that draw
against Abdus Atara but abdusitor of tie
breaks were amazing he finished in fifth
so just to be clear for everybody the
top eight will play each other it's one
through four they get to choose who they
play from five through eight now that's
Lemley he got the gold medal levonne
Ronin in second and tied with Vladimir
ferrosev in third we have vladislav
artemiev a super Grand Master From
Russia the Siberian elephant in fourth
we have no deerback Abdul sitar from
fifth we have mvl that's Leon beast and
sixth we have Maxim shagayev now that's
a very strong player
had a great event how did he get it's a
seventh place I mean that's the beauty
of these three you can lose the first
game or even the first two and all you
really see it is an incredibly strong
finish that's a lot more important than
a strong start
yes and Chicago I think you just saw it
throughout I mean he just hung in there
was able to get to six and a half at a
nine and then Den less Dennis leswick
the young fellow Russian Grandmaster he
won a title Tuesday that is obviously no
easy feat so he has proven himself and
he's proven himself once again it it's
unfortunate look behind him it's a
kheimer Amin Tabitha by you Yang Yi who
was the runner-up in division two of the
air things Masters we have prognanda who
is the runner-up at division three to
Sam sebian speaking of Sam seven he is
right there number 14 behind Veronica's
13th Place and then our generic I see
and Min Lei in 16th so these players who
didn't finish in the top eight they have
a chance to go to division two but right
now we're gonna focus on the four
players potentially advancing to
division one Donya
players it's a match but they want to
join Carlson Nakamura car one and so in
division one
indeed and Carlson Nakamura karawana so
they have already secured their spots in
the air things knockout which will be
coming your way at the start of April
that is why there are four more spots
open for a total of eight players that's
why we have eight total players who will
be contesting those four spots the four
winners of those mini matches join these
four incredibly weak players and then as
you can see the rest of the 72 players
are divided across division two and
division three Robert we should clarify
that 20 players are eliminated those are
the players who are in division three
and lose their first mini match those
who lose their first mini match in
division two they get seeded into
division three so they're still going to
be participating in the final
yeah you know they're fighting for the
spots so if you're in the top eight you
win you're in division one you're losing
your division two if you're the next
batch and you win you're in division two
but you lose you go down to D3 so let's
talk about the format here and the tie
breaks were in fact extremely close by
the way Vincent Conner misses out by a
half point on tie breaks the time Patrol
in the match play format will be 10
minutes plus two second increment they
will play two games so you need one nap
points you're through to your division
uh the top four from the Swiss they get
to choose their opponents who plays
fifth through eighth and the winners
they get to play in division one it's
funny calling the lower division it's
the better division uh but it one is
lower than two if we're just speaking
accounting terms but the winners they
get to play in division one and then
division two and so on for the next
batch of contestants
and just to complete that great summary
if each match is tied 1-1 then there is
an Armageddon game which we will almost
certainly get because we will have four
total matches here we have the top eight
players so Lim will choose one of the
players from the right side of the
column Notre back I seem I don't think
he's gonna choose Maxine but Sheila Graf
but you never know gukesh chose kramnik
last time my guess is Lim is going to
choose shigayv I think Lavon is going to
choose lazovic and then FedEx will have
an amazing choice between Notre back and
mvl yeah that is uh one of those coin
flips where you're like I don't really
know who I should play I I think Abdul
sitar will be the last pick just because
of his online prowess but mvo no slouch
either not only is he a former World
Blitz Champion that was over the board
chest 2021 he also has been a
semi-finalist for the speeches
championship in 2022 and famously beat
Magnus Carlson in the speeches
Championship uh several years back so
that's unenviable we have two Max teams
we have two vlads one vladislav one
Vladimir and the winners go to D1 the
losers go to division two so Donna this
is this is tough man I I don't know who
fetus or Tammy are going to choose
yeah I mean I think you're right it is
basically a toss-up I've made my four
predictions I think it's going to be Lim
against shigayev aronian against lazovic
and it's not like getting picked last in
PE class Maxine chagayev is obviously a
beast it's all comparative right you're
just comparing him to mvl and he is a
more palatable matchup better save I
think is going to choose mvl I'm with
you artemiev is going to have to pick up
the remains and face not Rebecca Abdus
tour of what a match that is going to be
but that's not the only entertainment
that we're gonna get we're gonna get two
other divisions losers in these four
mini matches advance to division two
knockout where they will be joined by
the winners of these individual mini
matches between these amazing players
wow look at the names here right these
people are fighting just to get into
division two on the left hand side of
your screen you see Vincent kymer super
gym I mean tapping to buy so talented
Iranian player who you know just won his
final round game to get into that Bunch
you genghi the runner-up in division two
at the air things Masters prognanda one
of the most talented players of his
generation a rising star along with
Radix and wani both these Indian
teenagers they really want to get into
division two Sam Sevin he won division
three he won a cool 5K won a bunch of
leaderboard points but he would like to
get into division two this time around
and then arjunera geisey he was in
division one the air things Masters he
is fighting just to get in division two
and then When Vladimir krumnik is number
17. I mean you kidding me look how tough
this is with minlay jagmire Eduardo
terzaga and Lavon panzerlaya finishing
the lineup there
indeed they do and of course the losers
of the division two matchups they move
to the division three knockout where
they will be joined by the winners of
this final divisions mini matches The
Losers of these mini matches will be
eliminated hence the 20 players who will
not be participating in the air things
knockout here are the the players in
division three this Robert tells you all
that you need to know about the
ridiculous strength of this tournament
Daniel dubov in 21st place I think the
last time anybody said those words it
was probably when he was rated 1600.
well you know these are actually still
the players of the back end oh I
apologize this is still division no you
case in point no the list is so long and
strong and look gukesh he made division
one last time he's here fighting for
division two and he's Geary he didn't
play in the air things Masters he is
having a shot just for division two I
say just as if it's not a great
accomplishment because this list is
super strong Salem select the last
player there from UAE I mean he is
nearly 2700 himself and we have rooted
macarian is isn't it
International master and if so this is
the highest Place finish from an IM oh
well Min is no longer than I am I keep
thinking of how he should be a GM but he
is now a GM how rudic of him to make it
to he's not polite to his Elders to the
Grand Masters but now we have this
actually is division three that includes
Anish giri
um no three pages that's still division
two I apologize that's still division
two we have uh oh no this is division
three I apologize can we just see
anisha's name and selection I thought
before so we're having some confusion
here yeah because we just had their
names in the previous list uh but we
will uh we will fix them it sounds like
we have some mistakes going with the
list so in fact
we admit it we acknowledge it we will
try to get everything underway so let's
uh try to make sure we have the players
correctly but these are the batch of
players that will be contesting uh for
the division three the winners get there
the losers are knocked out in their time
chakra and Mormon Jarvan 59th place in
52nd Place I mean come on come on Alexis
Serrata we were talking about him we
were singing his Praises Robert but
something didn't go quite right and yet
he still has a chance he still has a
path if he wins his division he's not
gonna be happy with 56th Place
this is just ridiculous just Alexi
Serrano wins the European Championship
signs online tries to get back in
division one he's fighting just to get
into division three let's finish off the
lineup because it goes all the way down
to 72 players who have a shot just to
make it into the division phase and
remember that last place in division
three if you go in there you lose both
your matches double elimination you
still get a cool one thousand dollars so
let's go to the final intestines by the
way we did see Alexandra because she
will have her opportunity to get into
the division
in 67th alexienko who beat krumnick 70.
oh my gosh where did he go I mean he was
doing great but that's the thing
everything turns at the drop of a hat in
this tournament you lose one game and
you get caught by the massive Peloton of
grand Masters
who uh want nothing more than to get a
shot at division one so The Losers of
these mini matches they get knocked out
as you're indicating with a thousand
dollars as a prize the winners of these
mini matches advance to the division
three knockout you win that you get a
spot into division two it's a long road
Robert a long road for these players to
make it into division one but that road
exists
yes the road may not lead to Rome but it
does lead to double elimination knockout
so from our top eight who will make the
final four and those four join Carlson
Nakamura so and carwana who have already
earned their way into the top division
that remains to be seen what you will
see right now is a little bit of break
maybe
take yourself enjoy yourself some water
some refreshments but when we come back
it's match time here at the air things
nope that was the last one this is the
Chester Masters playing we'll be right
back
you guys play chess you want to talk
about it let's do oh yeah where do you
play chess at you know okay when I say
chess the first word that pops into your
mind
protect my queen Hikaru intelligence
strategy tactics Toby Maguire oh my God
you saw Pawn sacrifice if you're on
Tinder and you're scrolling and someone
has a chess player on their profile is
that swipe left or swipe right
is good right yeah then yeah instant
swipe right okay super into that right
I'm into it you're ready that's probably
whatever the swipe is I don't not
interested so you're not interested in
chess players I'm not into chess players
around Tinder oh I get that I in fact
that checks out if I ask you to name one
chess player in the world can you name a
chess player
yeah no not gonna tell you the joy
capable
wow name another one oh Casper of Casper
if you name five other world champions
in the next 15 seconds I'm Gonna Give
You fifty dollars
ski
holgar
Carlson and
on holy
I just lost 50 whose idea was that
[Music]
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more
chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
foreign
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer
you don't see it how about now manage
your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
[Music]
welcome back to the chessable Masters
plane it's been a fascinating day of
action thus far but the best part is
still ahead we hope you've been enjoying
commentary by the great Grandmaster
Robert Hess the big smile on your face
are you as excited as I am for The
Knockout stage
I'm stoked Tanya because I feel like
unlike typical chess games played in
silence and mutual respect there has to
be some hostility here because the
players have chosen who exactly they
want to take on that must breed some
resentment
must breed some resentment indeed a lot
of tension between these Players let's
see who chose who we have Lim lay
against shigayv we have aronian against
lazovic gotta save Abdus and our Tammy
of mvl I already forgot what I predicted
now to clarify Robert I called this The
Knockout that's not quite right because
the losers of these mini matches they
still go to The Knockout it's just that
they play in division two and the
winners join the four people who have
booked their tickets already including
Magnus Carlson and they advance to
division one knockout what do you make
of these matchups
well limley has to be the heavy favorite
I'm just speaking honestly here
favorite Levon aronian against Dennis
lesovic also probably the favorite based
on levant's form in this event but
Dennis lazwick can upset anybody almost
took that Wesley so into the cgc last
year was it went and on to win the
tournament but in the first round he
almost got knocked out and I can't pick
between Federal save abusotarev and
artemy of an mvl those are toss-ups if
I've ever seen them they're absolutely
toss-ups I'm so excited for these four
matchups the format for folks is very
simple these mini mattress consist of
two games it's best of two the time
control the same as in the Swiss it's 10
minutes with a two second increment uh a
very familiar time control blind now we
know that the top four players selected
a player from uh places five through
eight hence the matchups that we have
and the winners secure uh division one
placement whereas the losers move into
the division two knockout in the event
of a tie in the events of a 1-1 tie we
get an Armageddon but we will cross that
bridge if we get there right now it's
time to cross the first Bridge as the
first games are about to begin seat
belts fasten folks here we go we've got
Lem Lim lay and chagayev on the cameras
in front of us
and limlay has the trophy case behind
him it looks like he's the coach for
Webster University he was a former
student at Webster University so he
knows what it takes to win he's won
national championships he's won a World
Bliss Championship he's an absolute
beast and he brings his Pony to E2 done
stepping in front of the bishop on F1
you're a king's Indian player what do
you make of the start
yeah this is an interesting this is a
flexible line which has the capacity to
transpose into a bunch of lines you
could get a samish if white puts the
pawn on F3 and then the dark squared
Bishop on E3 that's the likeliest
outcome should guy have can try to beat
white to the punch and that's kind of
what he does with H7 H5 you don't see
that every day in the king's Indian
structure you're pointing out Bishop H6
that is a pretty common idea though to
exchange the dark squid Bishops and it's
classy guy he's waiting as soon as this
bishop leaves then he plays Bishop H6
right you don't want to play it when
white has not spent the tempo developing
the bishop but if this Pawn goes to F3
then maybe you have to play Bishop H6
because it's now or never as the bishop
could try to slink away to F2
yeah very subtle positional play now for
both sides you called it Bishop H6 on
the board and he has gotten white
suspended Tempo but white wins this
Tempo back by hitting the Rook we should
also remember that black is now lost
castling rights so the king can't Castle
manually by walking to G7 I think that's
pretty likely it can also go Queen side
but with the weakness of the A5 pawn
something tells michugave is going to
seek shelter on the king side
nonetheless and you know what I like to
say the side that controls the pawn
brace is often the side with the
advantage but in a position like this
both sides actually control certain Pawn
breaks with F3 to reinforce this Pawn
the Knight can slide back to from F1 to
E3 and then maybe a timely G4 and for
black once you protect D6 because white
has the two pieces barreling down the D
file there could be a C6 at some moment
so both sides have their chances on
opposite sides of the board to break it
open maybe even an F4 at some moment if
a rook gets to F1 first Daniel really
this is anybody's game
yeah the move F4 weakens the E5 Square
after the trade but if white piles up on
the f file the F7 Pawn is going to get
caught in the crossfire so there's a
positional component to this game where
the players are jostling four positions
and outposts in the center but once F4
is played all bets are off and the game
transitions into squarely tactical water
so I'm expecting Rook F1 maybe Rook df1
so that the other Rook defends H4 but
first limb opts for your maneuver he's
going to get the Knight over into the
center and I like White's position
yeah no I think that white is looking
promising here Queen f8 that's kind of
one of those moves you play for Queen H6
potentially next but Knight E3 I'm not
phased by your queen going out to H6 he
doesn't really do much of anything it
has no future prospects so while these
two sit and think here I mean all four
matches in division or for the fight for
division one are underway so Donna
should we go to levana Ronin and Dennis
last week's game
can't go wrong with a little dose of
aronian Levon trying to get a little
dose of the bishop pair his Knight is on
A4 this started out as an Italian but
not every day do you see a knight for
Bishop trade Robert in the Italian
generally that should favor white but if
I'm reading Dennis lazovic's play
correctly he might be delaying short
castle for a very specific reason he
might want to go G5 and as you're
indicating go alongside that would not
be really in his style
but why else is he hesitating
maybe he just completed the development
and for Lavon he's like I'm gonna get
the bishop pair and just try to claim
that I have a slight Edge but what
Bishop Hare are we talking about as soon
as the stare down happens here you might
have to part with your light Square
Bishops and then you do have a bishop
against Knight situation but Tanya
you're a Vienna player once this bishop
is gone you would love to play them F4
with your darn knights in the way
now that's interesting I was going to
say f takes E6 is more standard fare
opening up the f file then castling
short becomes very likely lasovic
maintains the pawn structure as is by
taking back with the queen and I scratch
what I said I think he is going to
Castle kingside I don't think there was
a deep reason that he was delaying that
move and Lavon he should very well
consider taking on B6 moving the knight
from F3 either to H4 or back to D2 and
quickly shoving through F4 instead he
plays on the other flank first as he
grabs space on the queen side but he
weakens the D4 Square black could occupy
it with his Bishop straight away
that's a very interesting and big choice
for leswick because one thing he needs
to be afraid of even if it doesn't work
you have to look for the move C5 and the
reason it doesn't work is let's say you
just make some random move like rookie
eight after C5 takes takes the bishop
does have the safe haven in A5 it's a
bit awkward but you guys you can see
it's good for black because the pawns
are not connected for white on the DNC
file so just something to note that C5
is something that looks scary but does
not trap the bishop the bishop will get
the A5 square at the end of it so Anya
Knight takes B6 at some Owen so Bishop
D4 was your suggestion do you think
Dennis is gonna play it
well I think the other candidate move is
Knight F6 to D7 two can play at that
game white was the likelier one to
prepare F4 because the bishop on B2 is
just rearing to go it wants that
diagonal open but F5 as you're pointing
out is nothing to sneeze at either in
the events of a trade black quickly
doubles on the f file with his Rooks the
queen from E6 can slide over to G6 it's
obvious that both sides are capable of
attacking on the king side so this is
going to be a very rich maneuvering
struggle in the middle game lazovic
hopefully makes a decision rather
quickly because he's now down almost two
minutes on the clock
yeah no this is not an easy position to
figure out because Bishop D4 just to put
down his suggestion on the board after
Knight takes if you take with the pawn
you're already losing a pawn after B5
I'm kicking your knight of this you have
to take with the Knight and then F4
comes in and you can't take on F4
because your knight is loose at any
moment white could take on D4 to double
your Pawns in the center here this is
not easy for black and he chooses Knight
D7 and quickly Rook C1 is played from
Levon I think we should see F5 it's
about time that now black gets some
activity you have to but that makes D4
more enticing because you want to shut
down this Dark Sword diagonal with
moving F6 eventually so you've committed
to F5 I kind of want to take on the B6
and play D4 it's getting messy Donya I
think that uh lavon's time Advantage is
the biggest key to this position right
now but Dennis last week solid as ever
yeah this is a very complex position
Rook C1 might have been played just over
protect the C4 Pawn to make D4 possible
it's a rich position Bishop D4 on the
board but we've got a couple of other
games that are really heating up
including uh the game between Lim and
shigayev uh which we started out by
watching the pawn has reached G5 and it
looks like Lim is making tons of
progress on the king's side the side
that controls the pawn bricks has the
advantage and it's only one side with
the devastating Pawn breakdown the f
file this is a disaster disaster or
black doesn't it look like white had six
free moves the Knight went to F1 to E3
G4 G the black actually make moves let's
go back a second Queen H6 Knight G8 no
seriously like
black didn't actually make moves like
just shuffled around a little bit and
one hit all of this free time to open
the board up get the f file now this
Knight needs to get to E5 you're not
getting there as you can't go to C6
down here this is a disaster for
chigayov that's so instructive the fact
that the Knight can't reach E5
reposition the Knight two squares
forward and the landscape of the
position changes completely not only is
the Knight of monster but the F7 Pawn is
going to be very well protected as it
stands White's gonna double on the f
file that's a no-brainer and after
blackplay's Rook f8 or Castle's King
side which is illegal because black has
already moved his King about a thousand
times The Rook yeah
White's gonna triple up on the up file
Queen D2 to F2 is possible he can also
maneuver one of his knights from E3
somewhere around to F3 chase the queen
away and smash through in the center
with E5 White's the only who has any
winning chances here I think Lim has got
this in the bag actually yeah this is
looking great for him so while we see
that limb is in the driver's seat let's
go to a game we haven't looked at yet it
is the one between Federal Sav and Abdul
sitarov and we see in this position what
is going on here looking like Bishop for
federal sale that looks really strong to
me and take over the seafar Daniel this
seems like an easy position for feather
save to play
black is really struggling in this round
thus far Rook C7 the evil bar showing a
near decisive Advantage for white it's
not an overstatement because notorbeck
has gotten nothing going on the other
side of the board if anything the
presence of his Pawn on F5 only softens
up the king side even further as the
White Queen aims at the Knight slices
through the diagonal Rook C7 is coming
the pawn from B5 could anchor itself on
B6 to create an anchor Square for The
Rook on C7
the pawn on D6 this week Bishop A3 had
come at an inopportune time this is
this is a flattered disaster as well
yeah this bishop on G2 is going to be on
a long diagonal this Knight can go back
to D2 and up to C4 at some point maybe
even hop up to B6 so just keep on
Galloping towards the queen side can't
stop won't stop so this game it just
seems like has been out of hand if we
just quickly Zoom back here and this
Pawn went up to C5 and then takes on D6
at this moment he was black was saddled
with these pawns and you would think my
opponent has double isolated pawns I'm
going to leave them and Target them look
at ferocet this is how strong he is he
actually un doubles them for activity
because once the pieces Palm is gone
Here Comes B5 the Knight goes back to d8
give me that pawn and this is just nasty
and there was a subtlety that uh
Vladimir photo said I was going to say
Dimitri and dracon the fedes sidestepped
that intramzo B5 those are the moves
that we take for granting out obviously
he played but if you play Rook takes A4
you allow a trade followed by Knight D4
this enables black to discharge the
tension between takes a knight takes E2
is classic that might still be good for
white uh but there's absolutely no need
to allow the liquidation but I say if
pushes the pump through to B5 chases the
Knight away you don't see Notre back
experiencing these kinds of problems
right out of the opening very often
yeah and phariseev he's such a solid
player we know what he's capable of in
bullet scrambles he's a great tactician
everybody at the top level can do it all
but Federal save at his core he prefers
just to grind his opponents down he has
that sort of a strategic style Allah
karpov types just give me a small plus
I'm gonna make it work Lim lay has done
that marvelously today so we see Keith
rooting for a big fish a lot of people
out there are fans of federal Sav but we
have not checked in on another Vlad our
temmiev and mvl okay this is why we have
him look because as we look at this
position Dania it's very close white
should be better because the pawn on E5
is a static weakness and mvl he's
rocking the facial hair artemiev still
there in that dentist chair but I think
that this is not the pawn structure you
want for black
well I think the best way to think about
this is as a reverse night ORF in fact I
think you can get almost an identical
position with colors reversed in a 6 F4
night ORF if you think about it Pawn on
A3 yeah Queen on C2 Bishop B2 that's a
very common setup for Black in the night
off as good of an opening as it is you
don't necessarily want it with colors
reversed I think there's no question
that black is doing okay here but the
eval bar seems to disagree with that
assertion and it believes I think in the
activity of White's dark squared bishop
and perhaps in the possibility of white
opening up the center with a well-timed
D3 D4 upon break even now it has to be
considered
I'm considering it now that you mention
it and it looks very very strong to me
E4 is defended you'd be happy to gallop
your knight into E4 even for blacks turn
and black took on e4 you could give
black and Iceland a pawn or you could
take back with your knight leaving
yourself with this isolated Pawn which
you're okay with because of the activity
so Federal Sav down to 353 he strikes
with D4 mvo he looks down for a second
but he is going to calculating all of
this Pawn tension here Dania they can
all capture each other
yeah but all of this seems to favor
white and and rather one-sided fashion
fe4 the Knight jumps out if you play e
takes D4 then you yield all of your
central control the Knight jumps into D4
and at the end of the day White's dark
squared Bishop as they're highlighting
that's what really makes White's
position tick black also hasn't
completed his development that Bishop on
CA is blocking the rook's access to the
center I don't think MBL has time to
address all of his problems at the same
time I amend my opinion of this position
I think white is clearly better after D4
looks really really good for our Timmy
up here so let's just Bop around some
more just because all games are nearing
that point where the players getting
lower and lower on the clock back to the
game we started all with whoa
what a moment out of here says
oh I tuned in the right moment there
that is game over on the spot Knight E6
is the final strike if you take with the
bishop it doesn't matter after Pawn
takes there is a pin here so if you
can't take this Pawn You're Gonna Lose a
knight and then you take Rook takes Rook
oh wait a second I can't take with the
Knight what a glitch another glitch on
the server man you lose your queen and
more that is nasty stuff and by the way
since Chicago like didn't make any moves
look at what happened Knight F5 as soon
as we left that's a knife two out of
five please take a piece why don't you
let's open up that e-file your queen is
almost trapped your king is in the
center F6 is coming Donya this is nasty
limlay is not missing a beat we were
expecting a long maneuvering game he was
going to prepare F4 for dozens of moves
no not at all he plays F4 at the
earliest possible opportunity his
tactics are at an A plus level and 96 is
just the cherry on top this is an
unbelievable display in the Swiss and
now in the first game of the individual
matches he smashes through the f file
you snooze you lose and shigayev snoozed
for one move too long that was amazing
whoa we're not gonna snooze as well is
this a free piece
it is what is this bishop takes D5 HF
takes G3 H takes G3 and The Rook on C1
is defended by the bishop
I know that look from the big fish when
he leans back like that he's like yeah
I'm feeling good stretching the bishop
defends The Rook so politics G3 attacks
nothing and you could see the look on
abusatara's face he's like what did I
just do exactly his fishing was bad so
let's be clear about that Federal Sav
was really cruise control but this is
just a piece as soon as we tuned in
how was it it plundered it was blundered
with Knight D5 I mean the tension has
reached a peak but if you look at the
Evo bar black can reposition his Bishop
on the long diagonal Bishop D7 followed
by Bishop C6 Robert this game is very
far from over Knight D5 was a flat out
one move blunder yeah you're right in
Bishop D7 just to show that quickly the
queen has to move and I'm just gonna put
in a random Square once this Knight is
dealt with you take and then Bishop C6
as you mentioned maybe Knight C6 Bishop
C6 I'm not sure but either way look at
the eval bar saying black is right in
this so instead we saw Knight D5 double
question mark giving away this P I mean
this move it comes unexpectedly and it
just is a blunder on the spot game over
I think he might have forgotten that The
Rook on C1 is defended I know that
sounds crazy but that's the illusion I
walked into at first I was gonna say
wait a second F takes G3 and then white
has to move the Rook away but no the
rook and the bishop are connected that
is a very uncurricular blunder and I
think something's about to happen on the
board
I'm ready for it Robert
the bishop yeah that's an important
piece don't forget about that it defends
The Rook on C1 over there so
unfortunately for abusotarev and his
King is done he resigns game over
betosaev takes a one nil oh yes let's
get out of here and those players
they're gonna have to reset for the
second game of the match it is a
two-game match and if it's tied one to
one we do get hitting Armageddon but we
still have games going on right now
okay well this is not what I expected it
to turn to
all the matches that could result in
upsets this one is the likeliest I just
get that feeling that lazovic isn't
going to pass up the opportunity to make
The Knockout right now he's doing great
with the black pieces C5 here looks like
a move which addresses several issues at
once it creates a stronghold on D4 yes
it weakens the D6 Pawn but I think it's
a worthy price to pay because 96 to C7
as you're also indicating could force
Mass liquidation and uh what would be a
great result if lies will draw with the
black pieces here
fantastic recognition by Dennis lazovic
there because this Pawn D6 you can see
ghosts sometimes I'm creating a weakness
that's not good because it's a turn to
go everything was protected the problem
is in the pawn structure you often say
Pawn structure is overrated it's that
black can't move you're tied down the
Rook moves you lose the night the night
moves you lose the Rook so let's go C5
so you can move both at the same time
with Knight to C7 now the queen came to
D3 going out for this D6 Pawn Knight D4
was played we'll see a swap and then the
Knight will head into E4
I know the eval Bar says level but to me
this is not a clear-cut draw I actually
think both sides have some chances
because D6 remains a weakness and for
white like if you press a little bit too
hard I feel like you could it could
backfire and black could maybe get a
pass Pawn with a timely D5 black has an
eternal Knight on D4 that Knight cannot
be assailed it cannot be chased away can
only be traded but that's a lot easier
said than done now white could try to
access the equivalent square and play
Knight C3 followed by Knight D5 but it
seems to me that with the holes on the
light squares F3 is weak E2 is weak
black has more attacking potential if
this game devolves into an all-out
assault on both sides kick so there's a
case to be made that the game will end
in a draw because neither player wants
to take too much risk so we're gonna get
some sort of repetition I think that's
likely this to happen but I'm with you I
think Dennis uh has a smidge better
chances here to win this game
yes so while Dennis and Lavon they're
answering that end game phase looking
pretty level let's go to our other game
that is still remaining the one between
artemiev and Max Team Russia lagrav so
uh it seems like
after D4 the position opened up we saw e
takes D4 the bishop came to D-Day what
an interesting choice by artemiev
that was interesting he's loading up on
the F5 Pawn but then he's not taking it
a little bit of inconsistency by
vladislav
he takes out five seems pretty
compelling to me I think he was worried
about a knight getting to E5 Robert the
situation gets very complicated but here
you can maybe take and play Bishop E4 I
don't know exactly
Bishop before immediately looks pretty
good as well and D4 is a Sitting Duck
I'm gonna cheat this is not me I did not
find it I looked with the engine it says
F's oh no yeah come on this kind of move
you're gonna lose the pawn so let's
throw it forward you want to take on H7
to go after the black king or this is in
a game of 10 minute chess with just two
second increment yeah you're not finding
that if you do well you're winning this
whole thing
okay so instead we got a trade on D4 he
does take on F5 but a little bit later
he is up a pawn
but mvl addresses that not for long and
he doubles up on the long diagonal G7 is
hanging mvl should probably bring his
Queen back and he just did I think the
worst is behind black
although this A5 Pawn sticks out like a
sore thumb don't get checkmated so don't
go take that pawn a Checkmate in one is
threatened but after F3 Bishop D5 at
some point can white just grab this Pawn
I think he should I mean why else are
you putting the Knight on C4 if he wants
a draw then you should take the bishop
on D6 because that takes the sting out
of the potential Queen G3 which could be
very nasty if you lose contact with the
bishop
oh true turn around real quick you just
played the Swiss cheese variation on the
king side so Queen getting to G3 could
lead to a Checkmate so you got to be
very very careful if you're white
yeah you do and right now MBL is trying
to figure out where to put this bishop
Bishop C6 runs in tonight takes A5 and
that hits the bishop Queen G3 there has
to be calculated very carefully note
that white could also shift his King
over to F1 and in the events of a check
on the first rank you could block it
with a bishop on G1 I know that seems
very far-fetched but these are the kinds
of calculations that you have to do you
have to estimate the course of the game
you don't have the time to calculate
concretely and our temio is not in the
business of taking too many risks no but
he's also down under a minute so he has
to speed up rook E1 threads Rook E7 that
would be devastating and if black plays
rookie 8 A5 is hanging so opposite
colored Bishops leads to likely draw in
many positions and especially because
the F3 Pawn is under attack the G2 Pawn
is pinned so oh mvl takes a step back
he's just calmly retreating his Queen
and maybe he has enough to hold here
if you can squeak through A4 then he's
able to play rookie 8 without giving up
any pawns note that Rook takes C8 will
have to be met with Bishop takes C8 the
queen has to stay pegged to the G7 Pawn
that could enable white screen to
infiltrate with Queen C8 so our temmieve
has plenty of chances to win this game
but I think if the time situation were
flipped the chances would be more
realistic rookie 8 should hold the day
if MBL avoids a blunder
and artemia was setting up a trap like
please go ahead Free Pawn oh no my Pawn
The Rook goes to E7 and the black kings
of Charles rookie Seven's a threat
rookie eight should be played and well
this eight okay that's maybe a useful
move just get some love for your king
but rookie eight finally at long last
maybe D6 will fall at the end
but mvl has shown a reluctance to trade
Rooks and give up upon what you're
saying is that he's not actually giving
up a pawn after Queen takes D6 Queen
takes me through I think that's exactly
what he's calculating investing is last
70 seconds and he doesn't need all of
them rookie it on the board and a bishop
takes the A3 move and I think a draw is
now imminent
yes so this one looks likely to be a
draw though artery down to 15 seconds I
think he's just accept the fact yeah
this position is level he's never gonna
be in danger his King is perfectly safe
he can put his Queen on E5 King on H2
and there's no danger there and in fact
black has to get passive with Queen F7
and Can you steal this Pawn like it is
going to give me an extra Pawn for white
I didn't realize that A5 was hanging at
this point black strategy is very very
simple sit tight wait for white to start
pushing his King side pawns and then try
to find a way to force the queen trade
but that last part Robert is a lot
easier said than done if white moves his
pawns carefully
yeah but that's the keys move it
carefully if you ever push F4 it could
be a problem on G2 and so it's gonna be
back and forth let's go back to the
other game because Lavon aronian and
Dennis Lesnik were in ending so we're
going to take our attention back over
there as these players like they're
level because
all of a sudden wait where's my sniper
I don't see it I've looked at the queen
side the king side it is nowhere to be
seen did he blunder the Knight
I guess we'll find out after this game
ends
I thought that at some moment I was kind
of hovering over the game that when this
Pawn got to B5 oh Lavon he had some
chances but oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
whoa whoa whoa
he has Knight G3 Queen F7 how do you
make progress with white I actually
think a draw might even be likelier than
a win for white
although not with the queen over here
right like yeah because now it's a very
bad check and there's a check the queen
can block and trade and the Knight will
go around and win so as long as a queen
trade can happen white is doing very
well and the King has run all the way up
in the position
and it's gonna run all the way to the
queen side and it's going to be used as
an attacker the queen on C6 is so well
placed it's guarding both of White's
biggest assets I
yeah I think Knight D6 here might be one
way to do it
let's go over to C8 and go win the pawn
a good old-fashioned way with a fork
can you get some stalemate tricks not
with the additional Pawn on A7 which
will always have a move it's over Red
Rover Knight F6 and LeBron will pick up
Black's last remaining Pawn
that's it where did the Knight go like
oh my gosh Lavon just oh he got a team
hold him on the king side but this is
already a dangerous position for black
to deal with these pawns are Advanced
it's even based on the evaluation bar
but one inaccuracy after another White's
pieces go forward and that was the
losing blunder it seems Knight two E5
was wrong because it gave white time to
play G5 Knight C5 on the other hand
after check here G5 Knight takes E4
check check very importantly
indeed Knight C5 was missed great
technique by Lavon there at the end and
I think no we still have a game going
artemiev is still trying massaging
pushing his pawns but I really just
don't see a way for him to make progress
there's too many possibilities of a
queen trade black has too many checks in
the event that white plays a move like
F4
yeah you can never just push that pawn
open up the bishop yeah
take it that's a draw for
yeah our time he was gonna pretend to
try
that's a good way of putting it
pretending to try even if white could
win a second Pawn oftentimes it's still
going to be a drop but here great move
just keeping the pawns stuck in yeah
this is now very simple yeah this is
basic Betty you just keep your Bishop on
the D1 H5 diagonal white can't even play
G5 without giving up the H5 pun time to
offer a draw and that will make it time
for game two this is gonna be
fascinating with mvl having the white
pieces we know what he's capable of with
the white pieces
and Obstacle of Bishops you can get a
past Pawn but that's all you get because
black will stop it a draw is agree just
to finish that thought you get a pass
Pawn that's great but black will sit
back here with the king the bishop
covers the square and unfortunately
Bishops don't move to the other color so
this was a draw Daniel Lavon aronian
gets a did Lim lay so they have and so
did uh Federal save so three wins with
the white pieces Maxima Sheila grave the
only one that survived with black
it was not a good round for the black
pieces but that in itself contains the
silver lining for the players who lost
their first game they now have white and
winning On Demand with white is
generally exponentially easier it's
still incredibly hard try beating like
limp with the white pieces he hasn't
lost a single game this entire
tournament but they're gonna have to try
and that's what I love about the format
Robert watching GM's do everything in
their power to win it's just so
interesting because they have to avoid
so many lines that they otherwise would
consider playing lazovic wouldn't mind a
draw with LaVon in a normal tournament
with the white pieces here he's gonna
have to completely amend his style if he
wants to give himself a chance okay I'm
gonna ask you a question it's obvious
that Abdus tarv has the best chance is
because he's the best player who is down
one to nothing he is 27 30 plus between
chagayev and lazvik who do you give the
better odds to mounting a comeback
against their super GM opponents
I'm gonna stick with Dennis lazovic I
feel like Lim has shown such tremendous
form I just don't see Maxim chigayov
outplaying him on demand Dennis lastovic
in the meantime was on completely equal
terms with Levon aronian for that entire
game but as I said earlier Robert the
biggest issue is Dennis lazovic's style
he has a very solid style he makes a lot
of draws he doesn't lose a lot of games
but right now he might even want to go
one E4 something unexpected to get an
unbalanced position of some sort
yeah no you have to go outside your
normal repertoire because during that
break between the Swiss and the matches
what was levana Rooney doing he was
looking at openings he was saying what
to expect from Dennis lezovic so I think
you need to go outside the box and
abusotarev he's capable of doing that
chagayev also very solid player in
playing a extremely tough opponent but
what about the matchup between artemiev
and Maxine versus chilograph that was a
level game artemia maybe had one obscure
chance with that kind of crazy F6 move
but that was hard to find so who do you
see as the favorite mvl with the white
pieces or artemiev with his speed demon
skills
impossible to say mvl had a very tough
PCL match there where he lost to
Alexander indage twice in a row with
white and then with black so he has
erased the memory of that match he's
played much better today I'm gonna have
to give MBL a slight Edge Robert just
because of his phenomenal opening
preparation with the white pieces Maxine
shigayv he will have to display some
phenomenal preparation we have a
sicilian look at Lim he's like nah I
don't want to play karakan of Berlin I'm
gonna meet you at the top
I'm surprised by that and Knight D2 not
the most popular move you typically see
Knight C3 and you see limp pause now
limly is the coach of the Webster
University chess team they have many of
the best chess players in the world
there so many Grandmasters have made
Webster their home for several years so
he's had to look at all sorts of
variations that may not be in his
repertoire that's what a coach does but
he's paused because normally you try to
stop D5 but your knight to C3 but after
D5 here Dania and he plays D6 maybe
there was E5 turning this into more of a
French so D6 what do you think of that
choice by limit I like D6 I think it
might not be the best objective move but
you know that you're not going to get a
losing position with a shivanagan pawn
structure whereas if you're facing a
line that you've never seen before you
generally want to avoid a direct
confrontation so moves like D5 or E5 are
likely to result in some sort of force
sequence that should guys might be more
familiar with the way Lim is playing
this is a proven tried and true set up
that he knows is going to get him at
least a reasonable position yeah very
classical setup black often plays E5 but
white may eventually strike with F4
white wants to play E5 and leave black
with some isolated Queen Pawn so this is
an interesting start but I do want to
take our attention to another game that
has begun it's the one between Levon
aronian and Dennis lazovic because as we
see here it's a very different type of
game Dania where what year is this is
this like 2004 are we seeing vishy and
kromnic play what's going on here
well this is one of several viennas
right there's a Vienna that goes E4 E5
Knight C3 this is a different Vienna uh
Vienna variation within the ragozan or
black grabs the pawn on C4 and tries to
cling to it the white Rook moves up to
H3 all of these ideas are incredibly
well known as evidenced by
levonaronian's clock which is a very
disturbing sign for Dennis lazovic this
is the problem when you play Someone
Like levada Ronin he was formerly 28-35
about there as his Peak I think that it
was the fourth highest rating of all
time if I'm not mistaken behind Magnus
uh Kasparov carwana and I think Lavon
holds number four and he's played so
much Elite level chess he's had to
prepare thoroughly in countless events
and now he's here with the black pieces
and all he needs is a draw but I like
the type of position we have here
because one mistake from Lavon okay see
that's a move you play when you're
prepared who castles into a potential
attack the answer is Lavon aronian
because he has seen this before
I would see Rook G3 check king h8 queen
D2 and I wouldn't avoid that I would
avoid this with a 20-foot pole that
Queen's coming to H6 two made threats
created at once but it appears the Plex
Rook might get to G8 just in time but
Dennis is trying to set up mate threats
perhaps by getting the pawn to H6 but if
you get the pawn to H6 the Black Knight
can cover the g-pawn with Knight to G6
so he's gonna keep the pawn to H5 for
now where is the king going which way
I think you have to go in my eyes to f8
because you go to h8 the very natural
Queen D2 to H6 it goes f8 so oftentimes
with this Pawn structure whoa
oh my goodness if you take this one
and the rookuntigate is lost because the
Rooks are uncoordinated the bishop on C8
is really hurting black what an idea
so Dennis lesovic saying any prep You
Can Do I Can Do Better levada ronian
stopping to think right now and he could
lose this game in like three moves
because this King on f8 is not safe at
all
he has to move his Queen because Rook D1
on the next move is going to come with
devastating threats of a discovered
attack against the queen 96 and Knight
F5 white black I think has to move his
Queen preemptively but here's the thing
if you move it back to E7 I think white
will be able to shuffle his Queen over
to H6 and potentially even just take on
H7 Robert and promote that age Pawn
black doesn't have the Machinery to stop
that pawn with his Bishop stopping the
A8 Rook from participating
oh my goodness so you know at first I
was like LaVon experience he's played
this before then Dennis brings his Queen
out to D okay but I think Lavon still
within the relative framework of his
preparation you don't make a move like
Queen C5 that quickly unless you're just
double checking your memory there so
Queen C5 the evil bar has not changed
this is extremely impressive in both
players this is so so high level and
they are making all the top computer
moves Queen B3 I thought there was no
way he would find that Queen C5 same
thing from lavon's side Rook to C3 here
forces the queen to A5 but it's clear
that the position has more or less
stabilized I think Lavon has just enough
play and just enough pressure on the
knight uh to stabilize his position
ridiculous game so we are gonna leave
the players to it a lot of tactics
remain in this one but we have two games
that we have not checked out just yet
including the game between no dear Beck
Abdul sitarov and Vladimir ferrosev and
what am I looking at here we got this
Pawn structure where white has the
doubled C pawns but also the possibility
to expand on the king side at any moment
yeah
this is a very typical nimso Indian
structure where like obviously has the
superiority on the queen side and white
often has problems with the C4 Pawn but
F2 F4 could blast open the king side at
a moment's notice and with the presence
of White's uncontested dark squid Bishop
things can get very dicey if that Bishop
comes out to G5
this has been a theme ferrosev had an
unopposed Dark Sword Bishop in their
first game in this match and now it's
abdusitaros unopposed dark Square Bishop
he gives away a pawn this Pawn is
hanging there are two pieces attacking
it and now Federal saves us give me that
proof to me that you have more than just
equality with your compensation and
Tanya I feel like what white needs to do
is somehow get this Pawn back get your
Bishop to D4 I could see why you'd have
a plus there but instead goes out to G5
and says I'm gonna pin your knight and
the only way to break that pin is to
push your pawns and weaken your king
and he signals with this move that he's
not really in a hurry to win back the D4
Pawn he will want to win that pawn back
eventually it is a past Pawn but it's
safely blockaded by White's light
squared Bishop so that pawn isn't really
going anywhere nor is there a risk of
black opening up the center with D5
because white has established a bind on
that square with the two pawns that
you're highlighting so instead
neuterbeck trying to exploit everything
he can out of the king side while black
still hasn't completed his development
is there a case to be made for G7 G5 to
end the pin I don't know if that's a
human move
it's not a movie you make when all you
need is a draw but isn't White gonna
play F4 next to stop you exactly G5 and
then E5 and just try to crash through at
some point by opening up all your pieces
towards the F6 Square this is really
dangerous F4 Knight G3 the attack in
some ways is quite natural for white to
play so I feel like Federal save he's
gonna sit and think ponder about this
move G5 and for that long he goes for it
well better save I said it's not a human
move he's not a human he's a big fish
and big fishes tend to find G5 but
that's the easy part the hard part is to
follow it up accurately because F4 is
going to blast open the king side so
maybe you go Knight H5 and try to douse
the Flames of White's attack with a
couple of Trades maybe Knight G4 should
be considered uh preparing to plant the
Knight on E3 and he does play Knight G4
I don't envy this situation for FedEx
though notorbeck has gotten everything
he could have asked for out of the
opening yeah already H3 kicks the Knight
back to E5 and I want it there so when I
play F4 the whole board opens up black
may be doing okay if you're armed with
preparation or with the computer
assistance but with this King being so
open and F4 in the near future don't
play it now the Knight Will hop nope not
there over to E3 that would be a problem
for a white to deal with so I feel like
this is just a territory where both
sides are in some danger but I feel like
black really is the one that needs to
figure it out with the King being so
open
well Notre back is taking some time to
figure out his next course of action
whether he plays H3 or maybe brings the
queen up to D2 trying to take the sting
out of the move Knight E3 he can also
drop his light squared Bishop back and
open up a second attacker on the D4 Pawn
which is exactly what he does he's
trying to force Black's Queen to step
into F6 F4 is going to be even stronger
of a move now that the Rook x-rays the
queen not immediately of course but
maybe after a preliminary H3 the
position is heating up Robert this is
going to be a fascinating tactical
middle game struggle
wow I mean the queen F6 what a move to
play a knight coming back to E5 if it's
kicked with H3 I mean that just to show
a couple moves this is what I'd be
looking at BAM F4 look let's go forward
and it says that it just a position
that's dynamically balanced Knight takes
C4 I'm looking at this and black is up
two pawns here but look at the pawn
structure isolated pawns everywhere open
King in a must win game this is exactly
what you want for abusatara
and to follow this up I can play Bishop
F4 and quickly lift The Rook up to G3
black experiences problems with his
Queen which doesn't have any good
squares if it moves back to d8 you give
up H6 if it moves back to G7 you walk
into a potential pin after Rook to F3 so
from a practical perspective I would
take white a hundred times out of a
hundred guess what great call by uf4s on
the board and Notre back playing it all
very quickly to put additional pressure
on fedasev's clock
in the words of James Kennedy III you
know use the clock as a piece that's a
piece use it to your advantage yeah and
now it is an advantage for Abdus
terrible see if you can even this up
let's take a step back let's zoom out of
this one just because we need to check
in on all of our games we have not
looked at the game between mvl and
artemia early stages here artemiev once
again way down on the clock Donna this
has been what he's done all day he just
continues to burn clock in the early
stage of the game and then play very
precise to chess later
yeah he did that in the previous game he
had winning chances small winning
chances throughout the whole game but
mvl with some filigree Precision in the
defense holding the draw and now I think
from a objective perspective lack's
position is very comfortable I mean you
could not ask for more out of a real
Lopez than an active Bishop on B7 a
knight that from D7 can jump into C5 and
I'm wondering how mvl plans to meet that
move is it with Bishop to D5 or is he
just gonna leave the bishop on B3 and
say I don't care about giving you the
bishop pair what do you think I care I
would play Bishop D5 because dungey's
point is that the bishop is under attack
and if you take me on D5 I get to push
my Pawn into the center up for it a
little bit more maybe Knight C6 in the
future especially if I can kick out this
Knight over here but there are already
tactics like Knight D3 just things to
work out wise pieces are a bit loose and
the queen side is not fully developed so
I think both sides have their chances in
this game here uh artemio though he's
way way way down on the clock
and he has played Knight C5 but that
move this relatively natural move took
him another minute so at some point he's
going to have to accelerate his space
and when he does we will bring you more
of this game but I see your interest
peaked in a game that's already hit the
end game stage and it's lazovic against
Iranian and this cannot be good news for
Dennis lazavi who will have to squeeze a
win out of this equal material end game
no this one is liquidating too quickly
and that's the problem with playing
forcing variations if your opponent
knows it and knows it extremely
precisely the pieces just come off the
board sometimes and here we are it's a
completely level end game with Rook
bishop and three pawns per side there
are no chances there are no pass pawns
white is a little bit more active so
black does have a little bit to worry
about naming this Pawn on A5 but Dania
I'm really not seeing it you bring this
bishop back to DC okay E6 or D7 push the
pawn to A4 that's what I was aiming for
and the pawn on A5 can that's the
problem with the same colored Bishop end
game you can never attack the pawn on A5
the only way is to get the king all the
way over to the queen side that's not
very realistic and add to that the fact
that black can tie himself to the A4
Pawn which is exactly what LeBron is
doing that forces white to divert even
more resources away from attacking A5
this is a dead draw and LeBron with six
minutes on the clock trades the Bishops
and I don't think he'll have any trouble
holding half of the point and making his
way to division one
yeah white looks better because that's
an active rook and that's a passive Rook
but white can't increase the pressure
this King needs to somehow get to B5 but
while you're doing all that the black
Rook can go to G8 and go for this Pawn
on G3 so Levant okay he does it this way
very clever but the rooking company F6
and go after this Pawn we'll do a trade
we'll shake hands we'll make a draw and
like you said Lavon he looks well on his
way to division one so let's leave these
two let's go to a different game just
because Lavon seems to have this one
more or less wrapped up and what in the
world
has a crushing attack on the king side
how did this happen I'm just gonna take
us back we did expect to move E5 just to
close down the center but it only
remained closed for so long black has no
attack on the queen side this Pawn
structure covers all of the
breakthroughs and then G3 no way F4
let's just trade let's do this thing
King to B1 and then at this point the
queen went from one side to the other
inducing Bishop F6 you can't take on F4
I Shadow your Pawn structure and here
they all come let's Connect Four
we win we throw pawns forward Donna this
is just very clear-cut
and every move is very straightforward
Lim didn't get anything started on the
queen side in reality he was like one or
two moves away if he got c4n and
shattered White's Pawn cover it would be
a more double-edged game he does play C4
but it's a day late and a dollar short
your guy says congratulations yeah you
opened the C file that Knight on D2 from
the moment it was developed on move 5
has been the hero of White's defense and
White's attack keeping both of
blackstrokes completely at Bay
yeah should I have saw this the whole
way through he knew that that was going
to be the heroic piece he needed and
there's about to be an exchange
sacrifice on G7 which will lead to a
checkmating attack so this one I think
is completely over what a one-sided game
you can't play G6 because your Bishop on
F6 is loose so the position is going to
open up you have no choice and Maxime
shagayev is going to send this one to
tie breaks and to Armageddon bidding
it is indeed and you know that when
things get down to Armageddon Anything
Can Happen Lim lay had an amazing
tournament he's in clear first place he
got to choose his opponent but now he is
regretting his choice to play this is
selling Black's King is breeding fumes
over on the king side and I was thinking
yesterday maybe I'm breathing fumes how
is my own air quality
and if only there was a device Robert
that allowed us to measure that air
quality we can see some statistics there
this is the secret behind good
commentary it's good air quality and a
pretty humid office
wait is that say what 27 degrees Celsius
yeah it's 81. yeah what did you do you
turned off I turned off the AC like 10
minutes ago I'm sweating you you cranked
up the I do keep it on in high seven
normally I keep it at 73 or 74. I I like
a very warm temperature but I'm gonna
turn the AC on let's see how quickly it
gets down to 68. just do watch well
we're about to see how quickly this game
is going to conclude Rook takes G7 is in
fact lights out you just take this
bishop let's see how the temperature
drops let's say quickly the device
registers it but done it Bishop on G7 is
going to be captured and then
well h a queen and you can also take the
Rook on D4 on demand you know whenever
you want to you can just take another
piece King A1 Rook takes A4 check is
innocuous because the B2 Bishop is not
attacked by Black's Queen no no but this
is over okay this is actually really
important no King A1 is precise it seems
completely over but King A2 Rook takes
eight four actually got black in the
game because when you take the right
roof takes B2 habits with check and then
when your king takes on B2 there's Queen
C2 check the king tries to slide away
and not Queen C3 check that would be the
obvious looking move but the Knight
blocks and white winds you go back to C5
with check and the King has nowhere to
go you just keep checking the King on
the diagonal or on the same line on C2
so wow that was a good players they
never die they never die they squeeze
every last opportunity even when it
seems like nothing is going on the queen
side maximum Chicago though this is
basic Betty for him his King on A1 is
feeling safe his air quality is good
good
and let's see if his Armageddon skills
are gonna turn out to be good because
that's what's coming up for us
yeah and they're gonna have Armageddon
in this match we will not have
Armageddon in the levonne aronian Dennis
lazovic match levada Ronan he drew that
game it seemed with ease he moves on to
division one so congratulations to Lavon
and we will see more from lamb lay and
chagaya because it's one nil for now but
it's about to be one to one let's go to
a different game and why don't we go to
this one because black is winning but I
saw Queen on h8 and I was surprised how
many pawns is black up here
how many pawns is black up here give me
a couple minutes to count I believe that
white has four pawns and black has six
I guess seven
seven see I knew I would miscount so
black is three pawns up
what does white have in the form of
compensation
is there anything just Bishop D7 what's
White's next move gonna be can you at
least answer that
Bishop takes E5 Maybe
then you can just take and take on F6
black Alexa no danger here
I mean the six I thought that I'll be
honest with you I thought Notre back was
gonna go on to a crushing Victory when
he played F4
I thought that the game was going to be
decided in a couple of moves Vladimir
fetus is a freaking magician
he's just a beast I mean he's been
around for a long time now and I think
that he has a ton of respect in the
Chess World and we have interviewed him
so many times he just says I'm motivated
to put the best players in the world I
love rapid time controls and now he's
loving his life because he's up one
nothing after a convincing first Victory
now he can just bring his second Rook
towards the center there is no attack
whatsoever against the black king you
would need his Knight even if you got
your knight up to G7 I still don't see
The Knockout so Federal Sav he is really
just delivering in this tiebreak match
and it's official Maxim chagayev has won
his game so we've released one
Armageddon we're unlikely to have an
Armageddon in this match uh Lavon
aronian has already advanced to The
Knockout of division one lazovic will
have to make his way through division
two that leaves us with one more match
between our tamiev and mvl it is
currently tied at half a point a piece
what in the wide world what an
what in Gala do we have here
account
black is up a pawn
right yes black is up a pawn and this
Knight on B2 is over here looking a
little bit loose but speaking of loose
Knights this 94 is directly under attack
I feel like this is going artemia's way
because if you defend your knight with
the pawn you welcome this Knight into D3
and that's no good
so the bishop instead drops back to C3
but now you're welcoming the Knight or
are you back on A4 Bishop takes F7 check
is a Saving Grace for white without that
move by the way White's entire Central
Construction would have collapsed but
our tammyev's clock it didn't cost him
in the last game but this is a
significantly more complicated position
it's maybe time for C5 if you can get a
couple of minor pieces Lord I think it
becomes a lot easier to handle this in
acute time pressure
C5 is a great move and I think that's
what Artemis is going to play the fact
that he's thinking here this Knight's
under attack it has only one square to
go to I think he is going to play the
move C5 and after C5 you take this
Knight black takes this one and thank
you very much for the strong central
pods he plays it and I think this
Advantage is bigger than what the eval
bar is saying
yeah because after Bishop takes B2 which
might be forced if you move the Knight
away from D4 you'll allow a queen trade
the bishop on F6 also x-rays The Rook on
A1 that could be problematic tactically
but if you play Push two blacks Pawn
Phalanx in the center looks Mighty
imposing after C takes D4 I agree this
looks miserable suddenly for white
maybe there's some way there after
taking differently Rook D1 and quickly
try to win back the pawn but even if you
win this D4 Pawn A5 is hanging in so
many different positions black is going
to be up a pawn in this game I feel like
artemiev is in the never seat but he
only has 25 seconds left and that's the
amount of time very little where
blunders happen
I really think vladislavartame is one of
the best time scramblers in the world
it's an underrated skill for him he the
way in which he keeps his composure is
unbelievable he's also going to bring
his Rook into the game with Rook 88 and
Bishop F4 I think is what mvl is pinning
all of his hopes on he's trying to stick
his Knight onto D6 and really generate
threats against Black's undefended
pieces and 10 seconds now 12.1 for
artemiev
okay this is very important E7 square is
covered that would be a fork square but
after oh Knight D6
no he goes back to E3
maybe after Knight D6 there were some
like night at some point it's nice going
to move and The Rook on A1 is going to
be in trouble
what's crazy is that the Knight on B2
doesn't really have any retreating
squares Knight D3 I would seriously
consider on the next move so maybe MBL
should move his Rook out or play Knight
G4 to hit the tail of the discovery that
Bishop on F6 which can move to D4 should
the necessity arise but this Pawn also
can go up to C3 let's just defend that
Knight with a pawn advance and then
White's pieces are frozen this Knight is
so annoying because you can't play Rook
D1 I'm taking it if you play Rook B1
you're staring into a blockading piece
that is going to be protected by a pawn
so I actually think that activity is
hard to come by for Maxime he's spending
quite a lot a lot of time right now and
by the way Vladimir ferrosev he takes
game two as well is officially through
to division one of the chessable Masters
what an incredible tournament what a
mini match for Vladimir fedes
you want to break up just a tour of
loses zero to two not something that you
say often but this this is anybody's
game as our TMV makes some Luft for his
King and simultaneously stops White's
knight from jumping into G4 this is the
kind of class that he plays with even
with 10 seconds on the clock and he
might throw another opponent up G5 with
Tempo he said let's get those Rooks now
Knight D1 that Knight couldn't jump
anywhere it can go to D1 G5 still
available he takes first on G4 and
Knight takes G4 you called for it before
not easy to play with Rook D1 as a
potential response but Dania I feel like
not that many pawns remain so white has
a shot
but mvl he really likes the placement of
his Knight on E3 it's restricting all of
Black's pieces eval bar dipped there for
a moment but now the Knight is hanging
and Bishop B5 comes close to picking off
the C4 Pawn instead the Knight jumps
into F5 and Rook takes E4 is gonna
follow wait rookie Rook D2 and if you
take the pawn takes What a fine when he
promotes and the Knight can't stop the
pawn from E3 because you capture it
artemiev is the devil he set this up
that was insane
but it's not over Bishop E3 is an
excellent group and it's followed by an
even crazier tactic oh my gosh the C
Pawn is pinned now so if you take this
away you lose the rook and F2 is hanging
and you can't play Rook F4 because the
Knight covers and you can't play Knight
D1 because it's under attack and now
what you have to find The Knockouts too
yeah that's eliminate the pawn and then
strike white where it hurts Rook d8 to
E8 hits the Knight on E3 I don't know if
that's the move four seconds for our
Tammy if he's got to find a way to
coordinate oh my gosh dude
if Brooke takes either he's Knight G1
King G3 Knight E2 with the fork winning
this Rook on no way C3
Knight G1 can basically be pre-moved
maybe Rook A1 is worth fighting for
right sometimes you get fake you get
wrong pre-moves The Rook from d8 though
Robert can slide over to E8 and then the
Knight on E3 is also experiencing
tremendous problems with Knight G5 check
attempting to dislodge the king from the
night yeah two different ways to
dislodge the king with Rook F2 check
available so Rook E8 looks great goes
Knight G1 he wants 92. where's this King
even going
rookie 8 is possible he gives a check
buys himself a little bit of time you
might repeat oh he plays rookie he just
knows he's in charge right now he's
playing perfectly this is unbelievable
he's made every computer move you called
it you said you know he made it play
Slowly at first but even in time
scrambles he plays impeccably and look
at this Knight G1 check is already going
after this Knight over here he found
that square for his Pony and now Maxine
also down 20 seconds
b e a utiful and Maxime is running out
of defensive resources Rook A1 Knight D4
check ends it let's see if our team if
can find Checkmate he doesn't need to he
just gobbles all of the pawns he can
move his Rook back to D2 and then simply
promote his C Pawn I think embil might
resign the one thing you have to watch
that was G5 watch out on that F7 Square
you cannot allow the Rooks to attack it
he throws in Knight G1 where's this King
going if he goes hear me there's rookie
three check or Knight H3 and then take
G5 oh that's good but kick takes G5 he
goes if you take this Pawn there's 92 oh
H3
but now oh Knight takes F7 check wait a
second
but then I take your knight on H3 and
it's not totally over there in that Rook
end game you're up two points
oh that is such a good Intermezzo that's
game over artemia look at that he's calm
coolclock he just gives the head nod he
goes I'm in division one here at the
chesswell Masters
he is indeed and he does that on the
strength of a ridiculous sequence of
moves that he played all with 10 seconds
and under on his clock he defeats Maxine
by shella grav and that means we will
have only one Armageddon between Lim lay
and a resurgent maxim chagaya who
managed to crush limlay on Demand with
the white pieces and what an Armageddon
that is going to be what an upset Robert
that is going to be if chugaev can
strike in the Armageddon
yes and we will be heading to Armageddon
what does that look like because some
people hear that word like is the world
ending do I have to go say goodbye no
it might be for one of these two players
because they want to make it into
division one so the players they're
going to bid for their time with a base
time of 10 minutes so Daniel I mean it's
going to be exciting stuff
it is indeed and the bids are an art and
it's a science right some players they
bid less because they insist on getting
the black pieces some bids some players
they want the white pieces because there
is no increment in Armageddon this is
what players tend to forget the most
often Robert without increment it's a
completely different game so flagging is
very much on the table
it's not just on the table it is
recommended you must go for it if the
opportunity arises but we are going to
take a quick break and when returned
we'll find out what the players bid and
we'll give you all the information that
we have so we'll be right back here at
the chesswell Masters plan we're down to
Armageddon
hello and welcome to this video
my name is Christoph zileki I'm an
international master in chess from
Germany and I'm here to share with you
why in the opening plays such an
important role in modern chess the
opening in chess is like coming prepared
with a battle plan you play a move but
it's part of a larger strategy you want
to have an idea what to do against every
possible response that your opponent may
play against you want to have a plan a
strategy laid out before the game even
starts this can be really deep on the
top level of 10 20 30. you don't need
that much but you want to be prepared to
get a game that you enjoy playing it's
more fun to play and give you more
chances to win more games I've always
loved studying the opening figuring out
new ideas how to beat my opponents and
set traps this is now my profession
writing courses on openings for
chessable I've created more than a dozen
the most popular ones being of the keep
it simple series I have received a new
the order of the year what I invite you
to do is go to chessable.com and check
out how to play the opening better get
fun positions and win more games
foreign
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent-approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids that feels just like playing
but chess is a great way to learn
patience strategy and critical thinking
chess kit features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to Mastery there
are more than 50 000 chest muscles and a
whole library of entertaining videos
that teach strategies tactics openings
and end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
foreign
Lim are contesting the final spot here
at the chessable Masters they want to
make it to the division one knockout
that will be contested at the start of
April Grandmaster Robert Hess we could
not have asked for a better finale to
this amazing day of action
if you told me we're gonna hit
Armageddon I would have been stoked but
I would not have expected this matchup
Lim lay he dominated game one it was a
positional battle where it fell at
Chicago he was barely doing anything
moving back and forth while Lim lay
improved his position then in game two
should guys struck back in a decisive
manner that was as one-sided as it gets
so Donya now that we know who the
players are they had to bid for who
would start with black and draw odds
indeed both players choose a bid 10
minutes or under the player who bids the
lower amount of time starts wins the bid
and starts with that time the other
player starts with 10 minutes not with
what they bid the player who had the
higher bid automatically starts with 10
minutes and gets the white pieces
the bids can we announce them are we
allowed to announce them I think we can
is it a trade secret yes we're allowed
to announce that Maxim chigai have been
9 minutes and 37 seconds he wanted the
white pieces and he got them because Lim
bid seven minutes and 44 seconds
specifically not 43 not 45 he bid 744
that means Lim has the black pieces and
he has draw odds which means that if the
game ends in a draw black automatically
wins Maxim chugayev has two minutes
extra on the clock but he has to win
this game to make his way to the
division one knockout and what that
tells us is that he really wanted the
white pieces after that win in the
second game of their match and for Lim I
feel like he didn't really care seven
minutes 44 seconds I would prefer to
have black I want those drawds but if I
get white that means my opponent doesn't
have that much time so I like the bid
from Lim lay and well I like the bid
from because he wanted white we get B3
what do you make of it done it it's an
obscure Choice against the Sicilian
there's no question that Lem looked up
that Knight D2 nonsense that shigai have
played and which resulted in incredible
success so now Chicago chooses a
different sideline limb is not really a
sicilian player though so his choice in
the last two games is really really
puzzling what's not puzzling is his last
move he says you don't want the center
I'll take it thank you very much
I'm puzzled by the fact that she drives
thinking D5 was obvious e takes D5
showing off the pre-move Islam Lane
Queen E2 check wow that's a big move
there is it could be Bishop H3 yes
I think Bishop H3 is a big positional
threat because it creates massive
pressure on the e-file Knight C6 Bishop
H3 perhaps black has Queen E7 Robert the
problem if you put your queen on E7 is
that how are you going to get your Dark
Sword Bishop out and you've got problems
with that already because White's Bishop
aims at the G7 Square here is the moment
of truth no chooses the more
conventional path ah he wants okay this
is actually very clever Knight G5 is
automatic here
it absolutely is and this is your one
chance to play it because if you allow
Bishop B7 then the bishop on E6 is free
to move that's right and the reason why
Knight F6 happened it blocks the queen
but black could not start with a bishop
move because the G7 Pawn was hanging
before the nightcut I just showed it
really quickly G7 is loose you can't
develop your Bishop first so Knight
comes out and now Knight G5 that's
automatic to me but why is it not
automatic to Chicago like Knight G5 you
have to probably bring your queen up to
one of these squares wait D7 like do you
take with a queen sure let's go into the
end game
but now there's Bishop takes F6 and
after GF you can pick up the pawn on D5
what a tactic and white emerges with
excellent winning chances in this Pawn
up end game and shatters Black's Pawn
structure Knight G5
is on the board wow is a big move from
Chicago and lay he's thinking here he
probably did not want to get into this
position but now that he's here we just
saw that you can't go ahead and take
with the queen on E6 which means your
Pawn is going to be on that square and
then white will get his Bishop to H3 so
a tricky opening choice is paying off
right now for Max Team Chicago he is
ahead by two minutes on the clock and
there is no inquiry well keep reminding
you of that zero increment the players
will try to flag each other if they get
down to the scramble
that means a rook versus Rook or a rook
and three versus rook and three is
completely winning for the side that has
a big time Advantage if you've got 20
seconds you have zero chances to save an
open-ended drawn end game one in which
you can play forever so every second
that is ticking off Lim's clock right
now Robert is golden he doesn't know
what to do he see that Knight takes E6
is coming next he sees that the E6 Pawn
is going to be a massive weakness and he
probably has also just discovered that
taking on E6 with a queen loses the pawn
maybe he should go for that anyway and
hope that your guy if Mrs Bishop takes
F6
I don't think Chicago is going to miss
that he's playing too strong in these
last couple games with the white pieces
it's great start for him but the fact
that Lim is thinking it could lead to
about it
very important for chagayev not to
automatically trade Queens but it's a
moot point he takes with a pawn and
Bishop H3 again crucial to play it
immediately he's allowed black to Castle
yeah that was inaccuracy and that's one
of those that he should have said just
to bring up an analysis board here that
Bishop H3 instead of castling right away
it hits this Pawn now if you try to
Castle you lose the house Bishop takes
Pawn there is a pin you lose your queen
so you'd instead have to deal with this
Pawn with your king you don't want to
play Knight d8 that stops you from
casting anyway if you bring your king up
to F7 or to eat you know something like
this your King's out in the open white
has all the time in the world you can
play D3 Knight D2 Knight F3 something
like that you can just Castle but the
point is that white has a Target Black's
king is not safe and sound this was a
surprising Miss to my eyes
this was low hanging fruit Knight G5 was
the hard move understanding that this is
a positive transformation for white
should guy have did that but then rushed
it just a little bit I still think he's
better and his last move was an
excellent one what is he trying to do
he's trying to carve out the light
squares for his bishop and potentially
Robert for the B1 Knight which could
bring it bring out to C3 and in the
event the black plays D4 the entire
complex of Center squares become massive
weaknesses Knight E4 even Knight A4 ip6
is nothing to sneeze at either this is
still a difficult position for black but
what a move King B8 and play quickly
I've mentioned this throughout the day
Hikaru Nakamura all the top players they
say play good moves quickly I think I
might have even the best move and played
very quickly by The Pawn on D5 you
didn't want to take twice there there
were some tactics the eve e-file opening
up is bad news for the queen here so
Knight A4 Dunya really really nice
choice to go to the corner but to put
pressure on the C5 Pawn
and Rook hf8 solidifies the Knight opens
up potential pressure on the F2 Pawn the
issue is that the mobility of Plex
Knight on F6 is a really restricted E4
and G4 are both inaccessible but your
guy has to find a way to continue
applying pressure on Black's Queen side
I was going to propose rookie to see one
he goes Rook a to D1 so he's sort of
playing in the center is he thinking is
he flirting with the idea of D4 creating
total pandemonium in the center
but I don't think it's a good idea
because black has lacked a plan if you
play D4 for black that Bishop on G2
thanks you very much thank you so much
for that open file that's too much to
deal with open diagonal I should say H5
played said we're seeing Alpha zero
style play from Lim Latin he's getting
greedy give me this Pawn on H5
well now's the time Bishop takes F6
played but is he going to follow through
with Queen takes H5 bigger question
should blackplay Knight D4 here I think
he absolutely should use the opportunity
to centralize his Knight and generate
serious counter play
wow and it looks like Knight D4 hits the
queen things are getting spicy you can
take on H5 and just want to give a shout
out to a few things happening anishikiri
is playing Armageddon for division two
and Alexi serrana he was declared the
winner of the European Championship
congratulations to him that was an
over-the-board classical event played
over 11 rounds and he just finished his
division three match and is running
immediately to the closing ceremony so
good on Alexi to take part here after a
grueling tournament congratulations to
our new European chess champion but
Donya right here chagaya he can take his
Pawn on H5 what is the idea for black
five isn't white just take oh give up
position
the pawn on D5 is the bane of White's
existence if you could take your own
Pawn you would do that in a heartbeat
that Bishop on G2 it wants nothing more
than for that pawn to be gone I think
should I have seriously underestimated
the extent of Black's counter play on
the king side rookie Jade is coming and
in the center the Knight on D4 is really
dominating a lot of key squares White
Queen Robert after Queen takes h5e5 is
experiencing massive problems Rook to h8
comes very very close to trapping that
Queen
wow oh my goodness uh this queen where
else going to go by the way you can take
a pawn you go to seat four but there
might even be a B5 to look at there with
a fork this is getting dicey
Queen C4 B5 there's Knight takes C5 but
I think Queen C4 will still be met with
E5 and black would like nothing more
than to get a bad Bishop versus good
night scenario after high five and
Bishop takes C5
you're showing this on the board yeah
yeah just why not go for this H4 throw
your oppon forward maybe even H3 at some
point you could try to get on the light
squares yourself and we have seen a move
played it was Queen takes H5 E5 the
response and then Knight to B6 that
Knight can wrap around to the C4 Square
done it if this queen were to move and
goes to G7 Rook h8 next looks like it
traps this White Queen
it does indeed the queen is currently
hanging so Rook h8 is out of the
question and shigayv has to figure
something out Rook h8 is a massive
threat you can't defend that pawn all
you can do is open up a retreating
Square for your queen that retreating
square is currently occupied by The Rook
that your guy have put on D1 he should
have put it on C1 immediately I think
it's not too late you've got to go Rook
C1 bringing the queen back and Advance
the H Pawn up to H3 or H4 if black
doubles on the H file
yeah this is looking like a position
where black is the side for choice I
don't care what the eval Bar says and
looking at the clock we started with a
two minute and 16 second lead for Maxime
Chicago that is now down to just about a
minute the position easier for black to
play White is up two full pawns it's
hard to even realize that one of them is
on D5 as Daniel's been saying please
just scream take this off the board I
don't care where it is but just don't be
there because the bishop on G2 wants to
link the diagonal but it's blockaded
thanks to this bishop on D6 so I like
your Rook C1 I feel like black will just
play on the king side with Rook h8 F5
moves of that nature I do think that
Lemley has great chances here the other
move that I was attracted to was Knight
C4 and sacking the queen for The Rook
but that seems Mighty speculative Rook
hat is on the board good on chigaya for
investing time calming himself down and
finding the only way to keep some
Intrigue alive Lim is not the most
experienced time Scrambler of the bunch
I think I have he wants to bring this
down to a Time scramble
and then they has done well in the
Champions chess tour in years past so he
is familiar with the rapid stuff but
you're right he doesn't play as much as
some of the other players in this field
so look at this he's spending a lot of
time here Daniel what do you think he's
gonna do is he gonna go immediately for
the Checkmate threat where is this Pawn
going he's going one or two squares
these are difficult questions for white
to answer but you need to pose them you
can't just spend all your time
because otherwise your opponent is going
to answer them on your turn I think the
answer to the first is H3 and the reason
is that black lacks the light squared
Bishop so that pawn is ridiculously
difficult to attack I think black has to
run that F Pawn down the board all the
way to F3 if it can make it there
there's no other Firepower to add to the
attack after H3 you could try Queen F5
and then maybe a sack on H3 but white
could meet him at the top with Queen to
G4 or Knight B6 to C4 don't forget about
that idea and the bishop on D6 becomes
loose if the bishop moves white doesn't
have to be told twice D6 is going to
come with very very strong effect there
goes the F1 limlay didn't have to be
told twice I'm moving the airport Queen
G6 very quickly defending this Pawn on
D5 it shall not move and F4 is a pretty
big threat in many of these positions so
is E4 in some positions well let's shut
down that Bishop maybe try to carve out
some of the light squares for the Knight
but what about Avengers doubling Brooks
in the sacrifice you mentioned that type
of idea Bishop hitting G3 could be scary
I just am not sure what White's plan is
so Dania help me out what should
chigayib do
well with this time Advantage dwindling
he has to decide really quickly whether
he wants to take on D6 there's our
answer and I think he's trying to pile
up on the C5 iPhone this might be
Black's only remaining Target he wants
to play Queen C1 induce the move B6 and
blast open the queen side with B3 to B4
and then operate down the C file and
again if black screen moves I think he
automatically pushes the d-pawn up to D6
to open that diagonal up for goodness
sake
as soon as you get the opportunity you
likely want to play it and right now
limley he's down to about two minutes
and 30 seconds he spend quite a lot of
time on this move he knows a critical
moment he might play E4 to shut down
this bishop but that would invite D3 so
oh I like this I know the Rooks are
staring in the correct direction F4
looking like a bigger and bigger threat
F4 is a huge threat white could pile up
on the E5 Pawn now the black stroke has
left E8 so Rook C to E3
forces E4 and then maybe you try D3 to
open up the position and stick a rook on
E6 eventually even if it comes with an
exchange sacrifice but this is a huge
moment for chagayev who cannot back down
now the attack is coming he's got a
hunker down put a seat belt on and
prepare for it
and Rook E3 looks really nice but E4 D3
you're trying to Chisel open the center
here but he goes F4 right away he wants
it all play F4
wow what a quick find by you and by
Chicago that's not an easy move to play
you closed down the king side H3 is
surprisingly solid and the G3 Pawn now
it's black who wants to take his own
Pawn
wow both sides get out of here with the
pods in front of their pieces at that
point we're gone black would have good
chances can you go he does it I was
about to ask can you go up to the pawn
he says yes rookie eight check is just a
swap of Rooks not too scary the king
runs away F4 will drop after that and
Donya the great night against not the
best Bishop in the world but doing a
defensive task that Dynamic still
persists
Pawn on A6 turns out to be so valuable
what a forward-thinking third move by a
limb to play A6 and generate that look
for his King it takes the sting out of
rookie eight check which I don't think
is a really human move because the queen
of D6 is going to be accessing the F4
pawn and queen takes F4 followed by
Queen F2 check is basically made in two
Rook takes H3 there and queen H2 is a
classic mating pattern
oh my goodness what are we in for here
as both sides drop down to two minutes
but what is a natural move here because
if you play Rook E4 Lex still take this
Pawn F4 you distract The Rook away to
take the other Rook so I feel like I'm
not seeing a movie King H1 Queen H6 with
Queen H6 oh no it's so Direct
yeah
yeah and actually the Checkmate is
pretty sick you can this is gonna happen
Lim lay he has been finding tactics all
day and two guy have now sees it Brook
takes and then Rook H1 check is the
deadly threat so even if you play a move
like rookie a check I believe that King
A7 is the move you take this rule bam
you don't take this because you get
mated but I still am I'm getting rid of
my Rook the pawns couldn't get out the
way the Rook can check and check mate in
two different ways this is mate Queen
t6h1 was made Lim lay just turned the
tables real fast and it's because his
King has actually been the safer of the
two
magisterial attacking prowess by Lim and
how symbolic it is that white finally
drops lower on the clock than his
opponent and it comes at the moment when
shigaya realizes the Checkmate is simply
Unstoppable Rook takes H3 and we've
talked about it now for a while Robert
once this Pawn disappears from the board
the pressure down the H file is way too
strong to Bear Rook Geet h8 I think
shigayv wants to give that check on E8
but it's not gonna help even with two
pieces on the H file black should be
able to win even the simple Rook to H4
and then picking up F4 should be more
than sufficient for an easy win you know
what the problem is Tanya is that in the
event of say a trade I think we'll
likely see this move so I won't make it
on the board after Rook h8 that once the
trade happens ah here we go thanks to
our producer giving us analysis board
that if we trade oh can't drop quickly
enough here and you take this Rook you
don't have a piece coming to E2 to stop
the check the Knight is too strong and
if you go rookie two I could take your
Rook maybe but that's Checkmate in one
oh what a mating construction and rookie
eight check is on the board two or three
accurate moves stand between Lim and the
division one knockout he is finding them
with room to spare the threat of Rook H1
that forces white to take the rook and
we know how that is going to turn out I
think Chicago he will probably Force
black to find Rook H1 but that is basic
Brian or like Wong Lim
this is such a good game I mean white
had the advantage according to the
computers the engines but in a human
game between these two it just felt like
it was too much to defend and
unfortunately for Chicago he was playing
really well but this is should be game
over in a few minutes even Rook H2 just
a quiet first move that's been played
now Queen H5 next going for the pin and
win of this Rook on E2
that's done there's sick tactics Galore
I was gonna say queen E1 you could have
taken on G2 should Gaia still trying he
kind of hunkers down curls up into a
ball and what a move
[Music]
that is a fork on E2 hitting the king
and winning back the queen with interest
Lim Lei is just a man on a mission he is
not never from the beginning of this
game trying to just be calm he said you
know I'll take what happens I'll deal
with it and now rookie seven
he's got to deal with the threat of Rook
takes B7 check and queen F7 a last ditch
attempt by chugayv to whip up counter
play against Black's King like Huang has
to keep his eye on the clock I was about
to say the same thing but 43 seconds he
goes with renewing the threat of Rook H1
with Queen H2 Checkmate to follow while
hitting that Rook that was on E7 gosh
not letting go no he does not want to
lose this game but that is a good move
great move you have to block that is
resignation and Lim lay makes it through
to division one of the chessable Masters
Danya that was great display and look at
your guy if he is fuming
and you can't blame him he came Oh So
Close first he comes back with the white
pieces excellent opening preparation he
was better this game there's no doubt
that he was objectively better
throughout but I don't think that he can
be too upset with the way that he played
it was a situation where you basically
had to make one perfect move after
another and even with the extra time
that was a very tall order
and I feel for him because for a player
like shigaya you know he is somebody
who's very strong in the 2600s he's just
not getting invited to these Tata steel
round robin events or Norway chess so
this was a time to shine he put on a
great display of Chess but unfortunately
for him he ran into a brick wall in
Armageddon in Lim lay but Chicago he
goes to division two there are many
great names there he is going to have a
fun time of it but of course division
one was within his grasp and is going to
be kicking himself for a little bit
there are many great names and speaking
of many great names here are the eight
names that will be contesting uh the
chessable Masters knockout final
division one Carlson Nakamura so caruana
and from today's plan of course Lim lay
was the latest qualifier defeating
chigay of aronian with a smooth win over
Dennis lazovic a lot of our friends safe
two o's not Rebecca Torah win
vladislavartamy of demonstrates
ridiculous skill in two-time pressure
situations to defeat the Frenchman with
three names but those are not the only
players who will be participating in the
chessable Masters we've got division two
and division three and there's a lot of
money on the line Robert in both of
those divisions yeah there definitely is
a ton at stake but I want to note that
if you look at the people who qualified
from the plan Lim lay levonne aronian
Vladimir federuse of blessed artemiov
they were the people who finished first
second third and fourth so they chose
their opponents wisely and that's saying
a lot because Federal save picked Abdus
atarov he was like I could choose
between him and Maxine for sure legrov
that was a specific Choice it worked out
perfectly maybe it was a stylistic clash
that he thought was favorable and as
somebody who was in Norway uh for the
air things Masters I mean you can just
tell how much people put into this event
the players they care so much we just
saw from chagaya I mean he was pretty
distraught because for him the
opportunities don't grow on trees they
don't come every day and he was that
close to pulling a Ralph mahmet off or
Alexi serona and getting into division
one with the super Grand Masters but I
mean when we look at it you look at the
eight names here I don't think I see
anybody that's not super Grandmaster
nobody who's not a super Grand Master
Vladimir fetisev might be below 2700
right now but his Peak is well over that
Mark he I think has a serious chance of
scoring some upsets and I know Vladimir
very well he Savers the opportunity to
to match wits with Magnus Carlson and
hikara Nakamura who will have their work
cut out for them hikaru's not looking at
this field and saying oh Wesley and
Fabiano are the only players those four
qualifiers are monsters in their own
right and how great it is Robert to see
Levon aronian on the upswing once again
he's been amazing the last couple of
tournaments and I think everybody's a
fan of LeBron
yeah hard not to be and when you look at
these eight players I think what you're
getting at is sometimes when we get a
field you're like that's the opponent I
want to play and we expect certain
results no matter who plays who we are I
mean they could go down I always talk
about this that when Magnus Carlson came
on chess.com a few years back he wanted
to become the number one rated player on
the site it was Vladimir fedosev the big
fish who stopped him in his tracks They
played 15 games Federal save one eight
or eight total points and Magnus only
scored seven so Federal save he has gone
Toe to Toe with the best in the world he
will not back down from a fight he
relishes the opportunity and when you
look at the rest of the cast iron he's
been in the top forever Lim lay former
World Blitz Champion is an absolute
Beast artemiev over 2 800 in bday Blitz
rating he is a Speed Demon and then of
course the players who are already
qualified done yet there is not a single
person to point out and Target no match
is easy
no match is easy Vladimir to save
hikaranakawora in a World Cup a couple
of years back a lot of players might
have forgotten that he also came in
second in the world rapid Championship a
couple of years ago so FedEx has a very
strong pedigree a track record of doing
well against the top guys in Rapid
vladislava Tammy if I called it at the
start of the tournament don't fall
asleep on him artemiev is a monster and
I think he's gonna go very far in this
knockout he's got Magnus carlson-esque
style he's got the ability to survive
and thrive in time pressure and he
displayed all of those skills and more
uh today
way to address the Siberian elephant in
the room vladislav artemiev he does work
today he gets himself in time trouble it
does not matter he finds the best moves
I mean the Precision he showed today in
against Mexico when he had mere seconds
on his clock that was a sight to behold
so Dania it's been a fun day man I mean
we really had some great chess in the
Swiss and then we got some great
pairings in the uh knockout there the
matches that we saw and it's not really
a knockout it was a knock down because
you're knocked down to division two
while the winners go division one and
the winners of division two they will
have a chance to match wits with those
in division one in the next uh chessable
master so before we wrap up a quick
overview of uh the full schedule for
those of you who are calendar-minded and
of course we know the division two in
division three the Armageddon there is
still going so we are going to wrap up
the show and we will bring you the full
standings uh in our next broadcast but
uh the final of the chessable Masters
April 3rd through 7th and then there
will be four more events to look forward
to in May and July and August and
September that will be followed by the
CCT playoffs and the finals in the first
and the half time of December we've got
so much to look forward to Robert the
best news yet is that we're only one and
a half tournaments in and the next big
test for these players is going to be at
the start of next month
yeah it's such a fun format
opportunities given to so many different
players we saw Maxine Chicago he almost
made the most of it but he'll be in
division two and division two is full of
superstars in their own right Dunya of
course you will have the coverage of
that and speaking of coverage and you we
have the pro Chesley coming up more of
that next week so I feel like chess fans
and us you you know us commentators we
are spoiled for Choice when it comes to
the best chess players playing online
there's no such thing as too much chess
when we woke up the sun was barely up
now the sun is still barely up but it's
on its way down but the chess action is
definitely not on its way down this was
so much fun I woke up today it's a new
week and I just had a smile on my face
because I get to cover some of the most
fun most interesting most high level
tournaments out there in existence there
will be more of the same coming your way
in April and Robert nobody I'd rather do
it with honestly
I appreciate that well that brings a
smile to my face as does the continued
support of our many fans the people who
root on these players cheer for their
favorite streamers and watch some great
chess unfold we appreciate you taking
your time to join us learning the game
enjoying the game keep on doing it we'll
be back soon enough but for now we say
goodbye this was the chessable Masters
playing and next time you'll see us for
the Champions chest or it will be the
chessful Masters so have a good one
everybody and enjoy the rest of your day
foreign